THIS COMMITTEE ON GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE WILL COME TO ORDER. GOOD
MORNING AS WE CONTINUE TO TAKE
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN RISK THE SENATE
CONTINUES TO WELCOME THE PUBLIC
AND HAS PROVIDED ACCESS TO BOTH
IN PERSON AND TELECONFERENCE TO
THE PATIENT. FOR PUBLIC COMMENT
. FOR INDIVIDUALS WISHING TO
PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA THE
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS. THE
PARTICIPANT TOLL FREE NUMBER AND
ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. AND I WILL
ANNOUNCE IT NOW. TODAY'S
PARTICIPANT NUMBER IS.
877-226-8163 AND THE ACCESS CODE
IS. SEVEN SIX TWO TWO FOUR SIX
TWO. I WILL MAINTAIN DECORUM
DURING THE HEARING AS IS
CUSTOMARY IN ANY INDIVIDUAL WHO
IS DISRUPTIVE MAY BE REMOVED
FROM THE REMOTE MEETING SERVICE
OR HAVE THEIR CONNECTION MUTED.
WE HAVE HAD NO PROBLEMS WITH
THAT SO I DON'T EXPECT TO HAVE
ANY TODAY. WE ARE HOLDING OUR
COMMITTEE HEARINGS HERE IN THE-
STREET BUILDING I ASK ALL
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO BE
PRESENT IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED SO THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH
A QUORUM. AND BEGIN OUR HEARING
. WE HAVE TWENTY ONE BILLS ON
TODAY'S AGENDA AND THREE BILLS.
PROPOSED FOR CONSENT THE CONSENT
ITEMS ARE ITEMS NUMBER NINETEEN
TWENTY. AND TWENTY ONE. ITEM
NUMBER FOUR SB TEN THIRTY TWO BY
SENATOR BAKER WAS PULLED FROM
THE AGENDA BY THE AUTHOR AND
WILL NOT BE HEARD TODAY. BEFORE
WE HEAR PRESENTATION ON THE
BILLS WE NEED TO ESTABLISH A
QUORUM CONSULTANT PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATORS CAPITO HERE
CABALLERO PRESENT NIELSEN.
TORONTO DORADO PRESENT HERTZBERG
. WIENER WIENER PRESIDENT YOU
HAVE A QUORUM WE HAVE A QUORUM.
NOW LET'S HEAR FROM OUR FIRST
AUTHOR WELCOME SENATOR DOLLY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE THE
PATIENCE YOU MAY PRESENT YOUR
BILL S. B. TWO OH SEVEN GOOD
MORNING MANAGER MEMBERS I'M HERE
TO PRESENT S. B. TWO OH SEVEN.
SB TWO OH SEVEN AUTHORIZES THE
SISKIYOU COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS TO TRANSFER ALL
DUTIES OF THE OFFICE OF ROAD
COMMISSIONER TO THE COUNTY
DIRECTOR OF REQUIREMENT OF
PUBLIC WORKS STATE LAW CURRENTLY
REQUIRES A COUNTY COMPLY WITH
THE REQUIREMENTS THE OFFICE OF
ROAD COMMISSIONER. IN ORDER TO
RECEIVE ALLOCATIONS FROM THE
HIGHWAY USER TAX ACCOUNT HUTA
WHICH INCLUDES. A REVENUES FROM
STATE GASOLINE TO EXCISE TAX
VACANCY OCCURS THE OFFICE OF IN
THE OFFICE OF THE ROAD
COMMISSIONER THE COUNTY HAS A
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAYS TO FILL THE
VACANCY PRIOR TO THE SUSPENSION
OF THE WHO TO A POOR APPROACH.
APPROPRIATIONS AS WE HAVE WE
HAVE WE AS WE HAVE DONE FOR
OTHER COUNTY STRUGGLING TO
MAINTAIN FISCAL BALANCE. DUE TO
PACIFIC LEGAL REQUIREMENTS THAT
DO NOT ACCURATELY REFLECT THE
CONSTRUCTION OF LOCAL.
GOVERNMENT WORKFORCES. THIS BILL
ENSURES THAT SISKIYOU COUNTY
WILL CONTINUE TO RECEIVE FUNDS
NECESSARY FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
DEVELOPMENT AND MAINTENANCE.
WE'VE ALSO INCLUDED AN URGENCY
CLAUSE TO ACHIEVE THE COST
SAVINGS MORE QUICKLY. WITH ME
TODAY I HAVE. TO TESTIFY HAVE
ANGELA DAVIS WHOSE ACCOUNT
ADMINISTRATOR- FOR SISKIYOU
COUNTY AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH NOW LIKE TO- CALL ON THE
LEAD SUPPORT WITNESS ANGELA
DAVIS WHO- MISTER MODERATOR I
WELCOME TO THAT MEETING AND I
BELIEVE SHE'S ON THE PHONE. YES
GOOD MORNING ANGELA DAVIS COUNTY
ADMINISTRATOR WITH THE COUNTY OF
ISSUE I AM SUPPORT OF SB TWO OH
SEVEN AND I AM AVAILABLE FOR ANY
QUESTIONS THAT YOU MAY HAVE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
APOLOGIZE FOR THE DESTRUCTION-
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE TODAY
AND WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ANYBODY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IS THERE ANY
BODY IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL IF SO PLEASE
COME FORWARD AND SPEAK AT THE
MIKE. SING NINE MISTER MODERATOR
IF WE COULD CHECK IN TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO. PRESENT
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. HE WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONE FILED BY ZERO. AND ONE
MOMENT AND I'M SURE WE SHOULD
HAVE SOMEBODY YOU'D UP IN JUST A
SECOND WITH AN OPERATOR. VERY
GOOD. ANYBODY ELSE PLEASE GO
AHEAD AND GET ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. AND WE WILL
GO LIVE THIRTY SEVEN YOUR OPEN.
THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
THIRTY SEVEN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
SEARCH TO FIND SUPPORT. AND THEY
ARE NOT RESPONDING THEY TOOK
THEMSELVES OUT TO Q. MEDICARE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY. NOBODY ELSE HAS QUEUED
UP THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND I
WILL MOVE TO OPPOSITION IS OR
ANYBODY. WHO WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL HERE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED. SINGMAN MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD QUEUE UP
MEMBERS THAT WOULD WISH TO
TESTIFY ON THE LINE WHEN THE
TELECOMMUNICATION LINE. THAT'S
FINE OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
WHEN FILED BY ZERO TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. MADAM CHAIR NOBODY
IS QUEUING UP THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE-
TODAY WE'RE HERE TO CONCUR IN
THE ASSEMBLY AMENDMENTS ARE
THERE ANY QUESTIONS ON THE
AMENDMENTS. SEEING NONE I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. SOME OF THE
BILL IS MOVED TO SENATOR DOLLY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CONCLUDE I
WOULD JUST SAY- THIS IS A COMMON
SENSE BILL WE'VE DONE THIS MANY
TIMES TO RULE COUNTIES AND-
PERSUADED IVOTE. THANKS VERY
MUCH- IF YOU COULD PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SENATORS CABALLERO HI
CABALLERO HI NIELSEN. DURAZO
DORADO HI HERTZBERG. WIENER
WIENER HI THREE DESERVE. THE
BILL HAS THREE VOTES WE WILL
HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE REST OF THE
MEMBERS LATER ON IN THE DAY SO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. MEMBERS ARE
GONNA MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER TWO
ON THE AGENDA. LOOKING DO WE
HAVE SENATOR SKINNER HERE.
SENATOR MCGUIRE. DO WE HAVE
ANYONE HERE. THAT HAS A BILL ON
OUR LIST. ALL COMERS THERE WE GO
WILL TAKE UPS SENATOR WIENER YES
ABSOLUTELY. WHEN WE START WITH
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN WHICH SHOULD
BE S. B. EIGHT THIRTY FOUR.
SENATOR WIENER THE FLOOR IS
YOURS SB EIGHT THIRTY FOUR.
GREAT I THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
MADAM CHAIR I COLLEAGUES TODAY
I'M PRESENTING SENATE BILL EIGHT
THIRTY FOUR. WHICH WILL MAKE
CLEAR THAT THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD- BASED ON RECOMMENDATION
BY THE ATTORNEY GENERAL HAS THE
AUTHORITY- TO REVOKE THE TAX
EXEMPT STATUS OF NONPROFITS-
THAT IN THAT IT- EITHER ENGAGE
CHEN OR INSIGHT ACTIVITY TO
OVERTHROW OF THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT OR THE GOVERNMENT OF
ANY STATE THAT ENGAGED IN
INSURRECTION. OR RELATED CRIMES-
TO OVERTHROW OUR DEMOCRACY-
ALTHOUGH UNDER EXISTING LAW
UNDER COMMON LAW- WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS IS ALREADY EXISTS WE
ALSO THINK IT'S INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT TO MAKE IT CRYSTAL
CLEAR IN STATUTE THAT THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL. AND THE
FRANCHISE TAX BOARD HAVE THIS-
THORGY- THE I. BECAUSE WE ALL
SAW WHAT HAPPENED ON JANUARY SIX
OF TWENTY TWENTY ONE- WHEN WE
HAD ARMED INSURRECTION S. WHO
ATTEMPTED TO VIOLENTLY
OVERTHROW. THE UNITED STATES
GOVERNMENT TO VIOLENTLY
OVERTHROW OUR DEMOCRACY AND TO
VIOLENTLY- PROVIDE- THE SEATING
OF THE PRESIDENT THE DULY
ELECTED PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES. NEVER BEFORE HAPPENED IN
OUR DEMOCRACY- AND WE ARE DEEPLY
CONCERNED THAT THIS COULD HAPPEN
AGAIN. AND WE KNOW THAT
TRAGICALLY THERE ARE NONPROFITS
THAT ARE REGISTERED AS
NONPROFITS WEATHER HERE IN
CALIFORNIA OR ELSEWHERE- THAT.
HELPED ENGAGE AN INSURRECTION
INCITED- INSURRECTION AND WERE
INVOLVED AND CONTINUE TO THIS
DAY TO RAISE MONEY OFF OF THE
NOTION OF VIOLENTLY OVERTHROWING
THE U. S. GOVERNMENT. I'M PEOPLE
IN CALIFORNIA CAN WRITE CHECKS
TO MAKE CONTRIBUTIONS AND WRITE
OFF THOSE CONTRIBUTIONS ON THEIR
CALIFORNIA TAXES ARE CALIFORNIA
TAXPAYERS ARE LITERALLY
SUBSIDIZING ORGANIZATIONS. THAT
ARE SEEKING TO OVERTHROW THE
GOVERNMENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
AND SO SB THIRTY FOUR WILL MAKE
CLEAR THAT- THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
IN THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD CAN
PUT A STOP TO THAT CAN EITHER
DENY OR REVOKE TAX EXEMPT STATUS
IF THEY FIND- THAT- THESE
NONPROFITS ARE ENGAGING IN THIS
ACTIVITY. IN ADDITION FOR OUT OF
STATE NONPROFIT SEEKING TO RAISE
MONEY IN CALIFORNIA THEY NEED
TO- UNDER CALIFORNIA LAW
REGISTER WITH THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL TO DO THAT THEY CAN BE
DENIED THAT REGISTRATION SO THAT
WE DON'T HAVE. ORGANIZATIONS
RESULT ELSEWHERE WHO ARE RAISING
MONEY TAX DEDUCTIBLE MONEY I
HEAR IN CALIFORNIA- WE WORK VERY
HARD. TO STRUCTURE THIS BILL I
TO MAKE SURE THAT IT IS
ABSOLUTELY- CONSTITUTIONAL AND
CONSISTENT WITH THE FIRST
AMENDMENT THIS BILL DOES NOT IN
ANY WAY UNDERMINE FREE SPEECH
PEOPLE CAN MAKE STATEMENTS THAT
THEY WANT TO MAKE. BUT THIS IS
ABOUT ORGANIZATION AND THAT ARE-
EITHER ENGAGING IN OR INCITING
INSURRECTION. AGAINST- THE
GOVERNMENT- WE HAVE LETTERS ON
FILE OF SUPPORT FROM TO THE
PREEMINENT CONSTITUTIONAL LAW
SCHOLARS IN THE UNITED STATES
PROFESSOR LARRY TRIBE OF
HARVARD- AND JEAN IRWIN
SEVERANCE KEY OF UC BERKELEY
SCHOOL OF LAW. WHO BOTH HELPED
US RIGHT THE BILL AND HAVE
SUBMITTED LETTERS OF SUPPORT-
AND ALSO CONFIRMING THAT IN
THEIR VIEW THE BILL IS QUITE
CONSTITUTIONAL- SO WITH ME- HERE
TODAY I THINK PROBABLY
VIRTUALLY- TO TESTIFY ARE
LAWRENCE BASKET FROM- CALIFORNIA
IN THE BILL. STATE BRAUN- AND
KENDAL KERR'S SIDE FROM THE ANTI
DEFAMATION LEAGUE THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD WE'LL START WITH THE
FIRST WITNESS- LAWRENCE BASKET
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO PROCEED.
HELLO I'M HERE AS A VOLUNTEER ON
THE DEMOCRACY REFORM WORKING
GROUP OF INDIVISIBLE CALIFORNIA
STAY STRONG WHICH IS A COALITION
OF OVER EIGHTY INDEPENDENT LOCAL
INDIVISIBLE GROUPS WITH OVER
EIGHTY THOUSAND ACTIVISTS TOTAL
OF CALIFORNIA- INDIVISIBLE
GROUPS FORMED ACROSS THE COUNTRY
AFTER THE TWENTY SIXTEEN
ELECTION. TO VOTE THE ABUSIVE
BIGOTED AND TREACLE PUBLIC
REGISTRATION WITH THE EXECUTIVES
LEADERS APPROACHED ORDERED
SOCIETY AND WE ORGANIZED TO
PRESSURE OUR GOVERNMENT FOR PRO
DEMOCRACY POLICIES THAT ENACT
EQUALITY FREEDOM JUSTICE AND
TRUTH- SB EIGHT THIRTY FOUR
DOESN'T MAKE THE ACTIONS OF OR
THE INSTRUCTION IS ILLEGAL THOSE
ARE ALREADY ILLEGAL ALTHOUGH THE
TICKET WHERE TAX EXEMPTION FOR
DOING SO. AND ACTIVISTS
ORGANIZATIONS ARE SUPER OF
COURSE WAS THE TERRIBLE SO
FOMENTING ATTEMPTED COUP IS THE. OPPOSITE THAT. I DON'T SAY
THAT- FOR FEDERAL AND STATE THE
TO APPLY. FOR THE TREES ACTS OF
TO MAKE A MÀ OF COST TO. AND THE
LAW AND- A LOT OF IN PRINCIPLE
THOUGH IT HOLD THEMSELVES THE
EXACT LIVING PEOPLE TO UPHOLD
THEM. AND WITH THAT THE FORTY
FOUR THIRTY EIGHT THIRTY FOUR
THAT MEANS A YOU HEAR THE SENATE
TODAY- WHEN PEOPLE PRODUCT
DECLINE CORRECT WITH FORCE BUT A
BENEFICIAL LEGAL PRINCIPLES. HER
KNOWLEDGE BOYS AND FREEDOM
JUSTICE AND EQUAL. TRUTH FALL-
SO- IN THAT PAIN- WE HAVE
PROTESTED OUTSIDE THE- SOME OF
US THE PRESENCE IS OUTSIDE THE
FEDERAL DJ BUILDING. IN SAN
FRANCISCO TO PUSH OF THE DOJ TO-
TO PROSECUTE OTHER CRIMES OF. A
JANUARY SIXTH TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY TWENTY ONE I'M SORRY
TWENTY TWENTY- IN ADDITION TO-
ARE ARE. THE VIGIL TO SUPPORT-
TREATED PROXY SO OKAY
INDIVIDUALS THE STRONG INTO AND
AYE VOTE ON SB A THIRTY FOUR
THANK YOU. VERY MUCH. AND I'M
SURE IT'S ACTUALLY GONNA BE BETH
HOLD FROM THE EIGHTY- BECAUSE
OUR REGION WITNESSES THAT PRICE
STUCK AT THE- VERY GOOD WELL I'M
BETH HOLD. THANK YOU CAN. I'D
LIKE SAY THANKS I'M WIENER IN
THE FOR US POSTED BY ACCORDING
SB EIGHT THIRTY FOUR AM IN
NINETEEN THIRTY RISK. WHEN ASKED
CRIME IMPACT IN BIGOTRY ADL THE
LEADING RIGHTS INTO HIS ORG.
KEEPING WITH MISSION EDL PERFECT
X. IN. AND EXPOSE EXTREMIST.
IDEOLOGUES BACKGROUND IN THE
WAKE OF JANUARY SIXTH ATTACK ON
THE U. S. CAPITOL IN THE WRITING
I HATE EXTREMISM ACROSS THE
COUNTRY WE HAVE BECOME
INCREASINGLY CONCERNED ABOUT THE
WAYS IN WHICH EXTREMISTS AND
HATE. GROUPS OPERATING AT. MAYBE
IS USING THEIR TAX EXEMPT THE
FOR THEIR BY. HATEFUL JEFF. LAST
YEAR WE REALLY OUR FINEST AND
ALL BROUGHT A LOT I SIX PROPERTY
TURN. INDICATED REPORT AFTER
KERR THREE IN. WE HAVE A
EVIDENCE OF RAIN OF GROUP MAYBE
MAKE THE TRIP. THAT CAN FILING
IN ORDER SECURE TAX EXEMPT
STATUS IN THE FIRST. INDIGENOUS
SOUTH HEALING PAIN OR FEAR THE
WITHOUT REASON THEY'RE BURNING
FUNDS RICH FRIENDS MEMBER I
THINK. OF THE THAT ENTITY ITSELF
. IF ALLOWS RATE MONEY ARE. WELL
WAITING STATE INCOME AND
EMPLOYMENT PASS. THANK OR-
CONSIDE CROP TAX DAY IN TAX
THEY'LL PAY. AND EMPLOYMENT
PARKING. PERHAPS LOOKING.
COUNTRY THE FINAL SEE THREE OR-
ARE TALKS ABOUT THE- TAMBIÉN ORG
MAYBE TAX. THAT AS GOVERNMENT
ENDORSED WHICH GIVE I DON'T WANT
THE THREE INCREASED. LET
COMMITTEE TAKEN. PRESSURE OFF
THEIR CAR DUE PROCESS AND TO
ENSURE THAT THE LAW DOES NOT AND
ON. THREE TWO. ABOUT THE
OPPORTUNITY CONTINUE WITH ON. TO
ENSURE THE THERE ARE. FOR NOT
OFFICE INTO THE TURBO FUND IN.
FOR ILLEGAL. MARMONT AND CAN BE
DONE TO IN THAT. GROUP IN ABUSE
THEIR K. EXEMPT STATUS AND HOW.
ARE ELSE. AT EIGHT THIRTY THANK
THAT IN THE RIGHT TO. WE YOU TO
SUPPORT THE AGE THIRTY FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY. FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY. WE'RE GONNA ON
TO- COMMENTS IN SUPPORT BUT I
NEED TO- STATED THE BIG THAT TO
THE- REGARD THE LAW OF THE- AND
OUR TECH. CAN COME CHAIRS ME.
TIME LIMITS ON TESTIMONY- WE
GENERALLY HERE- LIMIT THAT LEAD
MRS TO TWO MINUTES EACH THEY'VE
DONE A GREAT JOB- OF KEEPING
WITHIN THAT TIME PERIOD I
BELIEVE. ON EACH SIDE WILL BE
PERMITTED AN EQUAL AMOUNT OF
TIME TO- TO BE ABLE TO TESTIFY
AND ALL OTHER WITNESSES WISHING
TO TESTIFY. MUST LIMIT THEIR
COMMENTS TO NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE ON THE MEASURE
SO WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO- NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
MEASURES FOR IT ANYONE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE. LINE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO. IN SUPPORT OF
S. EIGHT FOUR PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FILED
BY ZERO TO TESTIFY SUPPORT FOR.
SB EIGHT THIRTY FOUR. AND ONE
MOMENT THIS YEAR- MADAM CHAIR WE
DO HAVE A COUPLE PARTICIPANTS
QUEUING UP ANYBODY ELSE. PLEASE
TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY AND PRESS
ENTER- ONE FILED BY ZERO. AND
OUR FIRST PROJECTS THAT WILL BE-
LINE EIGHTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME'S FRIDAY I AM WITH
CHANGE BEGINS WITH ME AND WE
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB EIGHT THIRTY
FOUR THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE. I
WILL BE OFFICE ONE MOMENT MADAM
CHAIR. AND LOCAL I. FORTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
MALCOLM FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC WINTERS COUNCIL IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CAN EXPLAIN AND LYFT. THANK
YOU MEDICAREWILL GO TO LINE
FORTY NINE YOU ARE OPEN. HELLO
THIS IS DR GARVEY PHD SAN JOSE
CALIFORNIA AP SB THIRTY FOUR
THANK YOU VERY MUCH NEXT PLEASE
. I'M SURE THERE'S NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND- MY
APOLOGIES I FORGOT I NEGLECTED
TO ASK IF THERE'S ANYBODY IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THAT'S
IN SUPPORT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
. VERY GOOD WILL MOVE ON TO-
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION- WE HAVE
NO LEAD WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THAT WOULD LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION TO. THIS
BILL. SEEING NO MOVEMENT IS
THERE ANYONE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
AT THIS TIME WE ARE BILL SB
EIGHT THIRTY FOUR. EXPRESS
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. MADAM CHAIR
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP VERY GOOD-
WE WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR CONCERNS. THERE IS
A MOTION BY SENATOR DORADO.
SENATOR WE KNOW WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CONCLUDE RESPECT RESTAURANT
I'VE A VERY MUCH- PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY
SENATORS CAMBIADO HI CABALLERO
HI NIELSEN. DORADO DORADO HI
HERTZBERG. WIENER AYE WIENER HI
THREE ZERO THREE TWO ZERO YOU'RE
WINNING SO FAR BUT I THINK YOU
NEED A FEW MORE VOTES SO WE'LL
PUT IT ON CALL- ARE YOU PREPARED
TO TAKE UP ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN
- OKAY I TOTALLY MISTER SENATOR
SKINNER. FLOOR'S YOURS. WELCOME. S. B. EIGHT FIFTY FOUR. I'M
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- PRESENTING. SB EIGHT
FIFTY FOUR HOPE FOR CHILDREN
AFTER AND I WANTED TO START
FIRST WITH ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS
TO CLARIFY THE LANGUAGE- THE
PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS TO
RECOGNIZE THAT ARE ONGOING
COVERT NINETEEN PET PANDEMIC.
HAS BEEN VERY DEVASTATING AND-
MANY FAMILIES HAVE LOST LOVED
ONES. AND IF YOU ARE A CHILD WHO
LOST. AT THE END OF DECEMBER OF
TWENTY TWENTY ONE THE ESTIMATION
OF CALIFORNIA IS THAT TWENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND CHILDREN LOST A
PARENT OR PRIMARY CARE GIVER TO
COPE IT AND THE MAJORITY OF
THESE WE DON'T HAVE THE FULL
DATA BUT THE MAJORITY WE KNOW
OUR LOW THE PARENTS WERE LOW
WAGE ESSENTIAL WORKERS. SO THESE
ARE CHILDREN WHO IN SOME CASES
WILL RECEIVE FEDERAL SURVIVOR
BENEFITS UNDER THE SOCIAL
SECURITY. ACT IF YOU HAVE A
CERTAIN NUMBER IF YOU HAVE A
WAGES THAT WERE QUALIFYING. THEN
YOUR- YOUR SURVIVORS RECEIVE
THOSE BENEFITS BUT IN MANY CASES
A LOT OF THESE CHILDREN WILL NOT
RECEIVE SUCH BENEFITS BECAUSE
EITHER THEIR PARENTS DIDN'T
WORK. IN A THE YPE OF WAGE DROP
THE CONTRIBUTED TO THAT WERE DID
NOT HAVE ENOUGH QUARTERS OF
THOSE WAGES. BUT ADDITIONALLY
THESE CHILDREN ARE GOING TO HIT
EIGHTEEN AND NOT HAVE PARENTS TO
RELY ON SO WHILE MANY OF US
DON'T NECESSARILY HAVE PARENTS
THAT CAN SUPPORT US BEYOND
EIGHTEEN. MANY OF US FOR AT
LEAST IN THE SITUATION WHERE A
PARENT COULD HELP US EITHER HELP
US WITH OUR FIRST AND LAST
MONTH'S RENT. OR YOU KNOW
COLLEGE YOUR PURCHASE A CAR OR
WHAT HAVE YOU THESE ARE CHILDREN
WHO WILL NOT. SO ARE WHAT THIS
BILL WOULD DO IS ESTABLISH HOPE
SAVINGS ACCOUNT FOR THOSE
CHILDREN. WITH A DEPOSIT OF
POTENTIALLY UP TO FOUR K. FOR
CHILDREN WHO ARE UP TO NINE
YEARS OLD. AND UP TO EIGHT K.
FOR CHILDREN BETWEEN TEN AND
SEVENTEEN THE THEORY BEING THAT
LASTS FOR THE CHILDREN WERE
YOUNGER BECAUSE THESE WOULD BE
PUT IN INTEREST BEARING ACCOUNTS
AND IT WOULD GAIN VALUE OVER
TIME. BUT ADDITIONALLY THESE
HOPE SAVINGS ACCOUNT WOULD BE
SET UP FOR CHILDREN OF LONG WHO
ARE IN LONG TERM FOSTER CARE ON
THE SAME THEORY THAT THEY ALSO
DO NOT HAVE. FAMILIES TO RELY
ON. AND RESEARCH ACROSS THE
COUNTRY SHOWS THAT. CHILDREN WHO
KNOW THAT THERE IS SOME SECURITY
FOR THEM WHEN THEY HIT THAT
INDEPENDENCE AGE. YOU MUCH
BETTER IN LIFE- I'D LIKE TO HAVE
MY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT AND
WE'LL START WITH- IS IT A CODY
OR YES CODEPEN FILLED IN FROM J.
BAY AND A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH.
GOOD MORNING. THANK YOU THE
MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS CODY I'M
TWENTY FOUR YEARS OLD
REPRESENTING JOHN BURTON
ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH AS A FORMER
FOSTER YOUTH. I REENTER FONG
THERE RIGHT BEFORE MY
SEVENTEENTH BIRTHDAY AFTER MY
ADOPTIVE PARENTS ABANDONED ME
AND I WAS LEFT WITH NOTHING.
AFTER MY FOSTER PARENTS KICKED
ME OUT OF THEIR HOME. I FACE
MANY DIFFICULTIES. I DIDN'T
QUALIFY FOR THE SERVICES OF
EXTENDED FOSTER CARE SO I
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS MORE
THAN ONCE. WHICH RESULTED IN
TRAUMATIC EXPERIENCES. I FIRST
STARTED COLLEGE A FEW MONTHS
BEFORE MY EIGHTEENTH BIRTHDAY.
I'VE BEEN GOING TO COLLEGE SINCE
TWO THOUSAND AND FIFTEEN. MAKING
TWENTY TWENTY TWO MY SEVENTH
YEAR IN COLLEGE. I WILL BE DONE
WITH MY EDUCATION UNTIL TWENTY
TWENTY THREE. OR LATER MY
SCHOOLING WAS EXTENDED BECAUSE
OF THE DRAMATIC EXPERIENCES I
FACED. MAKING IT DIFFICULT TO
KEEP UP MY GRADES. FUNDING
PROVIDED THROUGH SB EIGHT FIVE
FOUR WOULD HAVE PREVENTED ME
FROM BECOMING HOMELESS AND IN
SOME CASES THE TRAUMATIC
EXPERIENCES I SUFFERED THAT
FOLLOWED WOULD ALSO HAVE BEEN
PREVENTED. WELL MY PARENTS DID
NOT PASS AWAY FROM GOLDEN
NINETEEN I DID LOSE BOTH OF MY
PARENTS ABRUPTLY AND BILL PASSED
AWAY WHEN I WAS YOUNG. I'VE LOST
PARENTS AND CAREGIVERS AND I
KNOW HOW HARD IT CAN BE TO
NAVIGATE. YOUNG ADULT LIFE
WITHOUT THE FINANCIAL EMOTIONAL
AND SOCIAL SUPPORT A FAMILY. ONE
THING I WOULD LIKE POLICYMAKERS
TO REMEMBER WHEN CONSIDERING SB
EIGHT FIVE FOUR. IS THAT A WILL
GIVE THOSE WHO BENEFIT FROM THEM
THIS MONEY IS THE FREEDOM TO
ESCAPE TOXIC SITUATIONS. POVERTY
GAPS AND SOME FOSTER HOMES WITH
CARE GIVERS THAT SEEK TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE. OF CHILDREN YOUTH
WHO'VE ALREADY LOST SO MUCH THIS
MONEY WOULD HAVE GIVEN ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PLAN MY DEPARTURE
FROM MY FOSTER CARE. ON MY OWN
TERMS. WHEN I SEE THE BENEFITS
OF SB EIGHT FIVE FOUR. COULD
HAVE OFFERED ME WHEN I WAS A
CHILD I SEE THE DEFINITION OF
HOPE. WHICH IS WHY I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT ON SB EIGHT FIVE
FOUR. PLEASE GIVE HOPE TO THE
FOSTER YOUTH CURRENTLY IN THE
SYSTEM SO THAT THEY CAN AVOID
SOME OF THE HEARTBREAK. AND
TRAUMA THAT I EXPERIENCE. IS SO
THAT THEY CAN PLAN FOR A BETTER
TOMORROW I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND ATTENTION AND
LISTENING TO MY STORY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE TODAY
AND SHARING YOUR STORY- I HAVE
AS A LEAD SUPPORT WITH WITNESS
AND LINDA CHAVEZ QUESADA WHO IS.
ON THE TELECONFERENCE ON. MISS
CASADA THANK YOU THANK YOU CHAIR
CABALLERO- AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PROVIDE TESTIMONY TODAY MY NAME
IS ELENA TRAVIS WITHOUT THAT AND
THE CHIEF IMPACT OFFICER AT AND
POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA OR ETHNIC
AT NEW INITIATIVE LED BY FORMER
STOCKTON MAYOR MICHAEL PAD AND I
THINK IT'S FOCUSED AS YOU MIGHT
GUESS FROM THE NAME UNDERGRAD HE
PROPERTY AND CREATING
OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL IN OUR STATE
AND WE'RE SO PLEASED BECAUSE
FONT THERE AT THE EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR WITH GRACE AND CHILD
POVERTY CALIFORNIA. AND
LIBERATION IN A GENERATION. ALL
RIGHT HEALTH WE'VE ALL HEARD OF
HARSH IS HOME TO THE FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE WORLD
WITH THE WEALTHIEST COMMUNITY.
AND BUT WE HAVE THE HIGHEST
POVERTY RATE IN THE US. AND WE
HAVE A MORAL AND PRACTICAL
IMPERATIVE TO CONFRONT THIS
CONTRADICTION HAD. WITH OUR
BUDGET SURPLUS WE CAN PLANT NEW
SEED THAT CREATES A LONG TERM
ECONOMIC STABILITY FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS. NOT JUST A
PRIVILEGED FEW. WE CANNOT ACCEPT
THE FACT THAT 28% OF BLACK
HELPFUL 90% OF LATINO
HOUSEHOLDS. HAVE ZERO NETWORK IN
CALIFORNIA. THAT MEANS THEY HAVE
NO SKATING AND THEIR CAMPING ON
THEIR MAKE NEXT PAYCHECK JUST TO
EAT. I HOPE THAT BEGINS TO
CHANGE THAT IT CREEK INVESTMENT
ACCOUNTS FOR THE TWENTY SEVEN
THOUSAND CHILDREN. AND YOUR
SKINNER JUST MENTIONED SHE
WALKED- GIVER TO COLLECT YOU.
HAD AS A LITTLE FIVE YOUTH. TO
PROTECT VULNERABLE OF CHILDREN.
INTO ADULTHOOD WITH LIMITED IF
ANY FINANCIAL SUPPORT. I MEAN
THE ONE HUNDRED POSITIVE UP TO
FOUR THOUSAND FOR CHILDREN UP TO
AGE NINETEEN EIGHTY THOUSAND FOR
YOU. AGES TEN TO SEVENTEEN.
ALEXANDER MENTIONED AT THE EIGHT
FIFTY FOUR OF FIFTY TO HELP
CHILDREN BEEN LEFT OUT OF
PROVIDE OR TEN. MANY WHO DIED OF
COULD BE NINETEEN DID NOT HAVE
ENOUGH WORK CREDITS TO QUALIFY
THEIR CHILDREN UNDER THE FEDERAL
PROGRAM. THE CHILDREN WILL
FINANCIALLY GO WITHOUT THE PORT
AND LYFT THE STATE ENERGY.
FINALLY TO. NO ES B. FOUR WILL
KEEP THE WAY FOR ALL ONE POINT
SIX MILLION CHILDREN BORN INTO
POVERTY IN CALIFORNIA. TO BREAK
THE CYCLE OF POVERTY IN BILLS
WELL. AND THAT IS THE KIND OF
BOLD POLICY WE NEED TO CREATE
OPPORTUNITY AND POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA. THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME AND I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
AN IDOL HONESTY BEFORE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
NOW WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO-
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT. LIKE TO
INVITE ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED PLEASE LINE UP TO BE
PREPARED TO TESTIFY WELCOME.
THANK YOU- THE SENATE JIMENEZ-
POLICY ASSOCIATE WITH GRACE AND
TOP PUBLIC CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT. AND IF THE TERROR LOS I
CAN ALSO LIST A COUPLE OF PEOPLE
OF ORGANIZATIONS WHO CAN'T BE
HERE PERSON. I YES ABSOLUTELY
THANK YOU CHILDREN'S DEFENSE
FUND CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS-
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR
FREEDOM. CENTER IN LOS ANGELES
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. A MADAM
CHAIRMAN MICHAEL RAT AGAIN ON
BEHALF OF THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SANTA CLARA COUNTY
HERE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
. SEAMAN I WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. MY
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD Q. THOSE
WHO WOULD WISH TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR
SB EIGHT FIFTY FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TIME WHEN FILED BY ZERO TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT
FIVE FOUR. AM SHARE WILL BEGIN
WITH LIKE TWENTY FIVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YEAH WE HAVE EQUAL RIGHT
BACK AGAIN JOHN CALIFORNIA
ADVOCATES NETWORK IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
NEXT PLEASE. THANK FORTY EUROPE
PLEASE CONTACT. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF COAL
BOARDMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU NEXT PLEASE
ONE THANK YOU MY TWENTY EIGHT
YEAR ARE OPEN. GOOD MORNING
JONATHAN GO NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALLING IN
STRONG SUPPORT THAT HE EIGHT
FIVE FOUR THANK YOU SO MUCH
THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE FIFTY
ONE. PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING COULD NAY SAN ON BEHALF
OF CALIFORNIA COURT APPOINTED
SPECIAL ADVOCATE ASSOCIATION OR
CALIFORNICA IS THE COURT SB FIVE
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT
TWENTY TWENTY NINE YOUR. TWENTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. MEMBERS
PERSONAL OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
MEDICARE MEMBERS OF SOME OF THEM
ARE BEHALF PUBLIC HEALTH
ADVOCATES GOING IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. I FORTY TWO YOU
ARE OPEN. HELLO MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THIS IS
EMILY WALTON ON BEHALF OF HOPE
THAT PROVIDE RESEARCH CHANGED
CALLING IN FROM THE PORT SB
EIGHT FIVE FOUR. THANK YOU. THE
FINAL REMINDER OUT PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
FOR SB EIGHT FIVE FOUR AND WE
WERE RELYING FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING KAREN
MEMBERS BUT THE THING THAT I
NEED IF NOT NOT THEY HAVE
CHILDREN NOW WITH SUPPORT SB
EIGHT BY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SHARE WE HAVE EXHAUSTED THE
QUEUE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
WORK- NOW WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NOT RECEIVED
A LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS SO I'D
LIKE TO CHECK AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY IN ROOM TWO AT TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED. LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION. SEEING NO ONE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LAMEST MODERATOR. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS OPPOSITION TO SB
EIGHT FIVE FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT FIFTY
FOUR. AND NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME. VERY GOOD WILL
BRING THE BILL BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. SENATOR
WIENER I THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD I THINK
WERE. AS WEAK- NOT COME OUT OF
THE PANDEMIC BUT MOVE INTO
HOPEFULLY MORE POSITIVE PHASE
OVER ALL THE PANDEMIC- IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT NOT TO JUST.
YOU SAY OKAY WE'RE GOING BACK TO
REGULAR LIFE AND IT'S ALL OVER-
BECAUSE WE WANT TO GET BACK TO
REGULAR LIFE AND HAVE A BETTER
SENSE OF NORMALITY- BUT WE
ALWAYS HAVE TO REMEMBER THE
WRECKAGE- THAT THIS PANDEMIC
LAST- ON THIS GLOBE AND- IN THIS
COUNTRYAND HERE IN CALIFORNIA
AND SO MANY PEOPLE. ARE
PERMANENTLY IMPACTED- BY THIS
PANDEMIC COMING IN THE NUMBER OF
BREADWINNERS LOST PARENTS
GRANDPARENTS- SIBLINGS- FAMILIES
THAT- HAVE NOT RECOVERED
ECONOMICALLY. OR OTHERWISE YOUNG
PEOPLE WHO HAVE NOT RECOVERED-
AND TRAGICALLY FAMILIES OF MAY
NOT EVER. RECOVER AND SO THIS
EXPOSE I THINK A MAJOR. GAP IN
OUR SOCIAL SAFETY NET- AND THIS-
LEGISLATION WILL HELP FILL THAT
SOMEONE IT REALLY. THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR DOING THIS IMPORTANT
WORK AND I'M HAPPY TO MOVE THE
BILL. VERY GOOD I MISS CENTER
DRAWS A- THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR
BUT ESPECIALLY THANK YOU TO YOUR
WITNESS WHO WAS HERE TODAY-
THERE'S NOTHING MORE POWERFUL
THAN TO HEAR THE COURAGE THAT
YOU HAVE IN THE TO KEEP ON KEEP
ON GIRLFRIEND. OKAY SO LET
ANYTHING HOLD YOU BACK AND- THE
PRODUCT YOU. ABSOLUTELY WAS
POWERFUL TESTIMONY AND WE REALLY
APPRECIATE YOU BEING HERE TODAY
TO SHARE IT WITH US- AS
DIFFICULT AS I KNOW IT IT IT IS-
WE HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR
WIENER- PLEASE ENTER. THAT-
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS CAPITO HI CAFIERO HI
NIELSEN. DURAZO DORADO HI
HERTZBERG. WIENER WIENER HI.
THREE ZERO THREE TO ZERO WILL
LEAVE THAT ON CALL AND- ALLOW
OTHER MEMBERS TO ADD ON- TODAY
UNFORTUNATELY WE HAVE FOR SENATE
HEARINGS IN SESSION AND WE'RE
GOING TO BE IN AND OUT TRYING TO
PRESENT OUR BILLS SO I'M GOING
TO TRANSFER. THE GAVEL TO BE
ABLE TO GO PRESENT AVAIL. AND I
THINK SENATOR WITH HER YOU'RE
THE NEXT ONE UP UNLESS WE TAKE-
IT ARE YOU PREPARED TO TAKE UP
YOUR BILL SENATOR MCGUIRE I
THINK HE WANTED TO TALK TO ME
BEFORE I LEFT OUT THAT'S THE
ONLY REASON I SAY THAT. YES SO
WE'LL LET YOU PRESENT SENATOR
WIENER AND WILL HAVE A SENATOR
DORADO CHAIR. OKAY WHAT WE'RE
WE'RE WE'LL WE'LL GET TO THAT WE
WERE GOING IN IN ORDER AND SO WE
CAN. NEITHER WE CAN TAKE YOUR
BILL UP NEXT SENATOR MELENDEZ
YES WE'LL GO AHEAD AND TAKE YOUR
BILL THAT. THAT WOULD BE
TERRIFIC THAN BE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN. THIRTY ONE YEAH.
OKAY THINK OF THAT MIGHT BE I
MIGHT BE A COMMITTEE OF ONE FOR
A WHILE- THAT'S WHAT WE DO AND
IT. OKAY ONE MOMENT- THIS. YEAH
EXACTLY- OKAY THANKS IT AGREE
AND THE GAL MOST IMPORTANT PART
OF THE JOB. OKAY WE'LL GO TO
ITEM THIRTEEN FIRST SB FOURTEEN
ELEVEN CENTER MONTESSORI DID YOU
WANT TO THE OTHER ONE FOR YOU
KNOW EITHER ONE IS FINE OKAY SO
WE'LL DO ITEM THIRTEEN TEAM S.
B. FOR THAT I. AM WELL. IT'S
ITEM. SO I AM THIRTEEN SHOULD BE
SENATE BILL FOURTEEN ELEVEN
AMONG THE SECOND- TWO OR THREE
I'M SORRY THAT I'M THERE MIGHT
JUST BE A MISTAKE ON MY ON THE
SPREADSHEET I HAVE. WHERE YOU
HAVE. HOW MANY BILLS DO- I HAVE
TWO ONE IS SENATOR PAT BATES AND
I AM OKAY I'M SORRY THAT'S WHAT
WAS THAT- IT'S- RIGHT NOW IT'S
UNDER OKAY SO- WHICH ONE DO YOU
WANT TO SEPARATE EITHER ONE IS
FINE I HAVE- FOURTEEN WILL START
WILL DO IN ORDER. TO DO ITEM
THIRTEEN SB THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE
BUT CENTER BATES BUT YOUR ON THE
GO WITH HER- AND PRESENTING SO
CENTER MELENDEZ FOR SENATOR
BATES. OKAY REPRESENTS. HAVE I
GET THE RIGHT ONES IN ORDER HERE
IRATE WELL GOOD MORNING- MISTER
CHAIR AND CENTER DRYSDALE- I AM
HERE TO PRESENT. SB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE. I WANT TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS ON BEHALF OF MY JOINT
AUTHORS- SENATOR BATES- IT
SENATORS SB THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE
CREATES THE CALIFORNIA DEFENSE
COMMUNITIES INFRASTRUCTURE
PROGRAM AND SEEKS TO PROVIDE
MATCHING FUNDS FOR LOCAL
INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS NEAR
MILITARY BASES. THESE MATCHING
FUNDS WILL HELP COMMUNITIES
pCOMPETE FOR FEDERAL DEPARTMENT
OF DEFENSE FUNDS FOR THE SAME
PROJECTS CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA
PROGRAM WILL MIRROR THE FEDERAL
PROGRAM WHICH CURRENTLY PROVIDES
FEDERAL FUNDS FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
PROJECTS SHOWN TO BENEFIT BOTH
THE COMMUNITY AND THE MILITARY
BASE. SOME OF THESE PROJECTS
BENEFIT THE COMMUNITY
SURROUNDING MILITARY BASES AS
WELL AS OUR MILITARY SERVICE
MEMBERS AND OF COURSE THEIR
FAMILIES. AN EXAMPLE OF A
PROJECT ELIGIBLE FOR THESE FUNDS
WOULD BE THE SCHOOL SPORTS
COMPLEX BEING BUILT NEAR FORT
IRWIN. AND OTHER PROJECTS AND
ERA IN CALIFORNIA THAT I
RECEIVED FEDERAL FRIENDS UNDER
THE DOT PROGRAM INCLUDE A
GROUNDWATER RESILIENCY
CONNECTION NEAR MARCH AIR
RESRVE BASE A FIRE STATION CAMP
NEAR CAMP PENDLETON NEAR CENTER
BATES IS DISTRICT. AND A WATER
TREATMENT FACILITY NEAR VENTURA
COUNTY NAVAL BASE NEAR SENATOR
WILKES AND SEND AN EARLY MESSAGE
DISTRICT AM I BELIEVE ON THE
PHONE HOPEFULLY- IN UPPORT WE
HAVE THE MONTEREY BAY DEFENSE
ALLIANCE. AND TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT BUT I AM- WITH THAT I
ASK FOR YOUR ITEMS THANK YOU.
OKAY WHEN I GO TO OUR LEADS-
WITNESSES ARE THERE ON THE PHONE
. I'M SORRY. NINE OTHER AREN'T
WHAT WE HAD WELL I APOLOGIZE I
THOUGHT THEY WERE GOING TO BE ON
THE PHONE OKAY WE'LL JUST CALL
IS THERE ANYONE IN THE ROOM WHO-
WOULD LIKE TO FIND FAVOR OF SB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE. HEY WHEN
OUT OF THE PHONE LINES OUR
MODERATOR- PLEASE GIVE UP ANYONE
IN SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IF
YOU ARE SUPPORT OF SB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
WHEN FILED BY ZERO. THANKS.
MISTER CHAIRMAN NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP OKAY WE WILL NOW GO
TO OPPOSITION IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE ROOM OPPOSED SB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE. SEEING NINE- CAN
YOU QUEUE UP ANY OPPOSITION ALL
ON THE PHONE LINE. WOULD LIKE TO
EXPRESS OPPOSITION SB THIRTY
NINETY FIVE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND
NOBODY IS QUEUING UP NEXT YEAR
OKAY WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE I CENTERS ARE ALSO ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS PUBLIC
QUESTIONS HERE- BUT HE COULD'VE
LOOKED THIS UP MYSELF SORRY BUT-
WHAT WHAT IS THE NUMBER OF A
MILITARY INSTALLATIONS AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. YOU KNOW THE
NUMBER OF COMMUNITIES THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT THAT WOULD.
BENEFIT FROM WELL. YEAH I MEAN
IT COULD BENEFIT ANY OF THE
COMMUNITIES WHO WISH TO YOU KNOW
SEEK THESE FUNDS IT IT DEPENDS
ON WHAT'S GOING ON AND THERE'S
YOU KNOW NOT EVERY COMMUNITY
THAT HAS A MILITARY INSTALLATION
YOUR BUYER SERVICE MEMBERS WOULD
NECESSARILY NEED IT WOULD JUST
DEPEND ON THE NEEDS OF THAT
COMMUNITY. RIGHT I'M JUST TRYING
TO TRYING TO SEE HERE THERE
THERE IS A- I GUESS YOU ACCEPTED
THE AMENDMENT THAT EIGHTY
PERCENT- WE DID YEP. OF THE-
MEDIA STATEWIDE INCOME SO I'M
JUST TRYING TO GET A SENSE. JUST
BASED ON THAT. NOT WHETHER OR
NOT THEY WOULD. ACTUALLY DO IT
JUST BASED ON THE INITIAL OF
YOUR BILL IF YOU HAVE ANY SENSE
OF. FIVE COMMUNITIES TWENTY
COMMUNITY I'M- A- YOU KNOW I
DON'T OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD I
MEAN LIKE I SAID IT WOULD DEPEND
ON THE NEEDS OF THAT COMMUNITY
WHETHER THEY HAVE THE FUNDING
THEMSELVES TO FIND THIS. OR
WHETHER IT'S SOMETHING THEY
WOULD WANT TO COMPETE FOR. OKAY
GREAT- YOU MAY CLOSE WELL THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- WITH THAT I WOULD
SIMPLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE
WHEN YOU HAVE A FULL COMMITTEE
HERE. YOU VERY MUCH- SO- IS
THERE A MOTION UNDER THE RUSSELL
. OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION ON SB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE AND WILL
CALL THE ROLL THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED THE FIRST
AMENDED AND RE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS CAPITO. NIELSEN TORONTO
TORONTO HI HERTZBERG WIENER AYE
WIENER HI WE HVE A TO VOTE SOME
WILL PUT THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS I THANK YOU WILL NOW GO
TO ITEMS THE NEXT ITEM WHICH IS
SEIZE ME SB FOURTEEN ELEVEN I
CENTER MELENDEZ YOU MAY PRESENT
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR- GOOD
MORNING ONCE AGAIN I'M HERE TO
PRESENT SB FOURTEEN ELEVEN WHICH
SEEKS TO ELIMINATE INCOME TAXES
ON RETIREMENT PAY RECEIVED BY
THE END OF. THE UNIFORMED
SERVICE INCLUDING THE ARMED
FORCES OF THE UNITED STATES THE
NATIONAL GUARD AIR NATIONAL
GUARD IN THE COMMISSION CORD THE
U. S. PUBLIC HEALTH SERVICE I'M
I WOULD LIKE TO FIRST BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS WHICH AT A SUNSET
CLAUSE TO THE BILL OVER ONE
POINT EIGHT MILLION ROADS ARE
VETERANS RESIDING CALIFORNIA
MORE THAN ANY OTHER STATE IN THE
NATION AND MANY OF THESE
VETERANS FACE THE STARK REALITY
OF LIVING IN CALIFORNIA WITH THE
INCREASED COST OF LIVING IN
TWENTY TWENTY TO KIPLING YOUR
MAGAZINE. M. I'M SORRY I HAD
MYSELF FROM OTHER LARGE STAYS
COMPLETELY EXAM TO MILITARY
RETIREE PAY AND HAVE SEEN THEIR
RETIRED MILITARY POPULATIONS
GROW BECAUSE OF THEIR EFFORTS-
ALTHOUGH OUR MILITARY POPULATION
IS DECLINING IN CALIFORNIA AND
WE ARE ONLY ONE OF FIVE STATES
ARE DECLINE IN THE NUMBER OF
MILITARY RETIREES FROM. TWO
THOUSAND TO TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN
SB FOURTEEN ELEVEN IS AIMED AT
STOPPING THIS VETERAN MIGRATION
AND MAKING IT EASIER FOR THEM TO
LIVE IN CALIFORNA. A TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN STUDY BY
GOVERNOR BROWN'S MILITARY
COUNCIL IN PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
SAN DIEGO MILITARY. SO FUNDING
NOW PAS FISCAL. WHEN EXEMPTING
VETERAN RETIREMENT INCOME- AND
IN FACT THEY EVEN IDENTIFIED THE
RELATED ECONOMIC GAMES AS
SUBSTANTIAL. THE PASSING SB
FOURTEEN ELEVEN SHOWS OUR
VETERAN POPULATION WE APPRECIATE
THEIR SERVICE TO THIS COUNTRY IN
THE VALUE. I'M IN THE IMPACT
THAT THEY HAVE IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND WITH ME HERE TODAY I'M
HOPING IS HERE IS HOW OTHER
HUNDRED MENDEZ WHO IS A RETIRED
U. S. MARINE. GAVE TWENTY ONE
YEARS OF HIS LIFE I'M IN SERVICE
TO THIS NATION IS- HE'S ON THE
LINE OKAY I THOUGHT HE WAS GOING
TO BE HERE I'M SO WITH THAT. I
WOULD ASK YOUR ITEM OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- SO WILL NOW- IT
IS OTHER HUNDRED MENDEZ ON THE
LINE. SAMATAR. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH YEAH OKAY YOU MAY PROCEED.
OKAY GOOD MORNING BURKE LOWER
THINKING EACH AND EVERY ONE OF
THE DISTINGUISHED CALIFORNIA
THERE'S A VERY HUMBLE FIFTY
THREE ALL THIS MORNING. AGAIN MY
NAME IS NOT A HUNDRED MENDOZA I
WAS BORN AND RAISED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. FIRST GENERATION OF
AMERICAN CITIZENS FROM MEXICAN
IMMIGRANTS. I'M THE ONLY MEMBER
IN MY FAMILY TO GO INTO THE
YOUNG YOURSELF FORCES. AFTER
ALMOST TWENTY ONE YEARS OF
DEDICATED. SERVICE THE COMBAT
DEPLOYMENT AND SEVEN PERMANENT
CHANGE OF STATION AND COUNTLESS
HOURS AWAY FROM MY FAMILY SO
MYSELF ONE OF THE LUCKY ONES.
THAT WERE ABLE TO HIRE ON OPEN.
THAT IS NOT A VERY SMALL THAT
YOU NEED TO DO IN THE MILITARY
RIGHT NOW MY WIFE AND I WILL BE
TAKING YOU CHALLENGE. AND I'M
NOT SO FAR FUTURE. I THINK YOU
ARE CLOSER TO RETIREMENT.
TRANSAMINASES WILL BE FACING YET
ANOTHER CHALLENGE. WHERE YOU
KNOW WE WANT TO. CONTINUE LIVING
HERE IN THIS GREAT STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE CALL HOME FOR THE
LAST FIFTY YEARS. BUT LET TUNING
AT THE VETERANS VETERANS THAT
SERVICE NUMBER. HONORABLY
SERVING NIGHT OF COURSE IS ONE
OF THE TWO FIVE EIGHT TO TWELVE
YEARS. HI VETERANS AND MILITARY
PERSONNEL WILL HAVE NOTICED THAT
SOME FORCES FOR TWENTY YEARS OR
MORE. HONORABLY. A STRONG
MILITARY AND- WE ARE PRETTY WITH
HI TAX. AYE ACOSTA LIVING. FOR
EXAMPLE MY ELECTRIC BILL IS OVER
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS IN MY HOUSE
YEAH THE BILL WHICH WAS FIVE
YEARS AGO WHAT'S FORTY DOLLARS
NO IT'S WELL OVER A HUNDRED. HI
GUYS THAT'S QUITE THE WITH NO IN
FIVE. ON TOP OF ALL THAT THERE
ARE NO REAL TANGIBLE BENEFITS
FOR RETIRED VETERANS OR- NOT
ABLE TO CALL THIS PLACE HOME.
CALIFORNIA OFFERS REFERRALS FOR
VETERANS THAT ARE ABLE. BYE PUTS
A GREAT DEAL OF STRESS FOR THE
REST OF THE RETIRED VETERANS YOU
ARE NOT ABLE TO BUT HAVE GONE
THROUGH. YOUR ABOUT FELLOW
GLOBAL TECHNOLOGY FIXTURES.
EVENTUALLY ABLE. THE SENATOR
SAID- THERE ARE. YOU CAN COUNTY
CALIFORNIA THERE ARE FORTY
MILLION OF POPULATION ONE POINT
ARE VERY ACTIVE LET THEM NOT
ARE. RETIRED VETERAN. BUT
HEARING CALIFORNIA NEAR ONE OF
THE ONLY STATE WITH THE MOST
POPULATED MILITARY BASES. THAT
ANY OTHER STATE IN THE COUNTRY
FOR EXAMPLE CAN'T COUNT YET THIS
MORNING POINTS AVAILABLE. FOR
FORMER UNITED STATES ARMY YOU
ARE STILL VANDENBERG AIRFORCE
BASE. AND ON LAW FOLK HERO. THEY
SHOULDN'T. BE ABLE. INTEGRATED
SUPPORT COMMAND ALLEN. BUT THE
PROJECT BLUE BOOK YOU'LL MODOC.
ONE WITH THAT BEING SAID. AT THE
AT THE END OF THE TOURNAMENT
IT'S OUR CLOSER LOOK TO AS FAR
AS OUR FUTURE. HM CALIFORNIA
DOES NOT OFFER THAT MUCH
BENEFITS FOR. RETIRED VETERANS
TO STAY. NEAR MY FRONT HAVE A
TARGET DATE HI. I'VE GONE. TO
OTHER PLACES THAT OFFER MUCH
THEIR FAMILIES RIGHT. MY
PROPOSAL IS WHAT PEOPLE CAN
LEARN TO BE ELIMINATE THE
TEMPTATION OF THE UNIFORMED.
SERVICES AND I OUT OF APPROVED
SB ELEVEN. SB FOURTEEN ELEVEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU SO
MUCH THE FOOTBALL THANK YOU SO
MUCH AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE- OKAY IS THERE ANYONE IN
THE HEARING ROOM WANTS TO- SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF SB FOURTEEN ELEVEN
. OKAY SEEING NO ONE WILL GO TO
THE PHONE LINES MISTER MODERATOR
IS THERE ANYONE- QUEUED UP FOR
IN FAVOR OF FOURTEEN ELEVEN. IF
YOU ARE IN FAVOR OF SB FOURTEEN
ELEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO AT THIS TIME. WHEN FILED
BY ZERO- SB FOURTEEN ELEVEN.
MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS GIVING UP
. OKAY IS THERE ANYONE IN THE
ROOM HERE OPPOSED TO SB FOURTEEN
ELEVEN. WE DON'T HAVE I THINK
FFICIAL OPPOSITION SAYING NO
ONE- MISTER MODERATOR IS THERE
ANYONE ON THE PHONE LINES IN
OPPOSITION TO FOURTEEN ELEVEN.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO SB FOURTEEN ELEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME WHEN FILED BY ZERO. MISTER
CHAIR NOBODY IS COMING OUT. OKAY
WILL PROVIDE TO THE COMMITTEE-
CENTER DRAW SAID YOU'VE ANY
QUESTIONS OR- OKAY- OKAY WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR ALSO AND-
CENTER MELENDEZ YOU MAKE CLOTHES
I'M THANK YOU VERY MUCH I JUST
WANTED TO POINT OUT THAT- I'LL
HUNDRED MADE THIS POINT IN A
STATEMENT. NOW WE HAVE I THINK
ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION VETERANS
IN CALIFORNIA BUT YOU KNOW. ANY
OF THEM AREN'T RETIREES THEY DO
THEIR FOUR YEARS THERE- TEN
YEARS WHATEVER IT IS AND THEY'RE
ACTUALLY RETIRED SAYS IT'S
ACTUALLY QUITE A SMALLER NUMBER
OF THOSE WHO WOULD BE. I'M
BENEFITING FROM THIS AND I JUST
THINK IT'S A- IT WOULD BE A
WONDERFUL THING FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA TO SHOW THEIR
APPRECIATION FOR VETERANS IT IN
IN THIS SMALL WAYS TO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR- WILL
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS CAPITO
. NIELSEN DURAZO I DORADO HI
HERTZBERG. WIENER AYE WIENER HI
YOUR IT'S TO VOTE TO PUT ON
COFFEE AFTER NUMBERS YOU LIKE
THANK YOU SENATOR. OKAY I SEE
THAT- OR MAJORITY LEADER IS HERE
CENTER MCGUIRE YOU MAY- PRESENTS
S. B. EIGHTY FOUR. WELCOME
WELCOME WELCOME HOME UNDER THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR SECURE IT'S GOOD
TO SEE YOU TO SEE CENTER DRIVE
SO AND ACTUALLY CONSULTANT
CANAL- IN THE- JONATHAN IN ANTON
AND IT SELLS WONDERFUL TO BE
BACK THANK YOU SO MUCH I'M
REALLY GRATEFUL TO BE WITH- BE
WITH YOU MISTER CHAIR AND CENTER
DRIVE SO- FIRST OF ALL MISTER I
WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO THE STAFF
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL. I
ALSO WANT TO MAKE A COMMITMENT
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE WORKING WITH
THE CHAIR AS WELL AS THE
INCREDIBLE GOVERNANCE AND
FINANCE STAFF TEAM ESPECIALLY ON
ANY CHANGES TO THE LOCAL
PLANNING LANGUAGE AS THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD OBVIOUSLY PERSON
TO ME IN THIS COMMITTEE IS WILL
BE WORKING A 100% UP WITH THE
CHAIR IF THERE ARE ANY CHANGES
WHICH CANDIDLY I'M SURE THERE
WILL BE. HERE AS THE BILL I
WOULD SHALL BE HONORED IF YOU'D
BE WILLING TO MOVE THIS FOR
TODAY SO EIGHTY FOUR WOULD
PROVIDE A PATH TO EXPEDITE
UNDERGROUNDING OF ELECTRIC
UTILITY LINES AND HIGHEST FIRE
RISK ZONES THOSE LINES ARE MOST
AT RISK AT STARTING A WILDFIRE.
I DON'T WANT TO BE FLIPPED THIS
BILL WILL TRULY SPLICE
ESPECIALLY AFTER WHAT WE'VE SEEN
SINCE TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA UNDER
THE APPROACH THAT'S EMBEDDED IN
THE LEGISLATION ITSELF GONNA
SAVE RATEPAYERS MONEY SB EIGHT
EIGHT FOUR WHILE ALSO REDUCE
CARBON EMISSIONS BY STOPPING
MEGA FIRES BEFORE THEY START WE
KNOW THAT. UNDER BLINDS REDUCE
FOR STARTS BY NINE. AND THIS
LEGISLATION WILL HOLD ELECTRIC
UTILITIES ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
TIMELINE FOR FAR TOO LONG YOU
KNOW THIS AMERICA'S LARGEST
UTILITY PG&E HAS FAILED ITS
CUSTOMERS AND MADE CALIFORNIA
UNSAFE LITERALLY FOR YEARS THE
UTILITIES UNDER FUNDED
MODERNIZATION ABOUT FIRE SAFETY
EFFORTS WHICH IS HAVE HAD
DEVASTATING IMPACTS IN THE
GOLDEN STATE. NOW THEY HAVE A
NEW CEO AND SHE WANTS TO CHANGE
THIS WHICH I'M GRATEFUL FOR
WE'VE BEEN WORKING WITH THE CEO
AND I ALSO WANT TO SAY THANK. TO
THE WOMEN IN MEN TELL THE
WORKERS WITH P. GENIE THAT WE
ARE WORKING WITH THEM AS WELL-
AND KNOW THAT THE CONVERSATIONS
ARE GOING TO CONTINUE.
CALIFORNIANS HAVE LITERALLY RUN
FOR THEIR LIVES WHETHER HOMES
BURNED TO ESCAPE PLANES FROM
UTILITY BECAUSE WILDFIRES.
OTHERS WHO WERE UNABLE TO RUN.
FIRST YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR
THESE UTILITY BECAUSE WILDFIRES
HAVE CHARRED MILLIONS OF ACRES
OF FOREST LAND IN LEVEL
COMMUNITIES. GENERATING
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS EQUAL
TO MILLIONS OF VEHICLES ANNUALLY
IN FACT IN TWENTY TWENTY THE
SMOKE FROM FIRES GENERATE THE
EQUIVALENT EMISSIONS OF TWENTY
EIGHT MILLION VEHICLES- AND
BLANKETED MANY PARTS OF THE
STATE WITH UNHEALTHY SMOKE. FOR
WEEKS. CALIFORNIA SAT IN THE
DARK WITH FOOD SWIMMING IN THE
WARMER FRIEDRICH. FOR DAYS ON
END DURIN WIND DRIVEN PUBLIC
POWER SHUT OFFS IN THE BEEN LEFT
WITHOUT ACCESS TO CRITICAL
LIFELINE SERVICES WHEN POWER
LINES GO DOWN. THIS IS BEEN A
REALITY MY OPINION THIS IS BEEN
A REALITY. FOR FAR TOO LONG. FOR
THE FIFTH LARGEST ECONOMY IN THE
WORLD. AND WE CAN'T ACCEPT THIS
WE CAN'T ACCEPT THIS AS WHAT OUR
LIVES ARE GOING TO BE THERE IS A
BETTER WAY WE MUST MOVE IT
FORWARD AND CREATE A PATH FOR A
BRIGHTER FUTURE. SB EIGHT EIGHT
FOUR WILL PROVIDE A PATH TO EXT.
COUNTING OF TEN THOUSAND MILES A
PG&E LINES IN THE HIGHEST FIRE
RISK ZONES CURRENTLY P. JEANNIE
UNDERGROUND'S ABOUT A HUNDRED
MILES OF THEIR ELECTRIC LINES
ANYWAY SO HERE'S WHAT IT'S GOING
TO DO AND I'LL BE QUICK THROUGH
THE BULLET POINTS. IT MAY. IT
MANDATE FOR METRICS WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED BY THE CALIFORNIA
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION ON
UNDERGROUNDING PROJECTS
INCLUDING TIME LINES FOR
COMPLETION. FINANCIAL PENALTIES
FOR NOT HAVING TIME LINES IN THE
UTILITY WOULD HAVE TO PROVE
SAFETY PROTOCOLS. ARE MET PRIOR
TO RECEIVING A RATE OF THE
RETURN. DEVELOPS AT THIS BILL
DEVELOPS A PATHWAY TO EXPEDITE
UNDERGROUNDING CONSTRUCTION BY
STOP WISHING A SHOT CLOCK AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL. THEY HAVE TO
APPROVE OR DENY IT WITHIN A
HUNDRED FIFTY DAIS. THE
LEGISLATION WOULD SAVE
RATEPAYERS MONEY WHICH IS
ABSOLUTELY. THAT WOULD MANDATE
UTILITIES USE AVAILABLE FEDERAL
INFRASTRUCTURE FUNDS TO
CONSTRUCT UNDERGROUNDING PROJECT
BEFORE USING USING RATEPAYER
FUNDS. IN IT WOULD MANDATE
TELECOMMUNICATION COMPANIES
UNDERGROUND THEIR UTILITIES IN
THE SAME TRAINS AS THE
ELECTRICAL UNDERGROUNDING. THIS
BIG ONES POLICY HELP AS A
CASHIER AND MAKE OUR STATE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SYSTEM. MORE
RESILIENT ESPECIALLY IN THOSE
HIGH. HIGHEST FIRE RISK ZONES.
AND IT ALSO GUARANTEES A TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY DAY JUDICIAL
REVIEW IN CALIFORNIA COURTS. IF
AN UNDERGROUNDING PROJECT FACES
A SEQUEL LAWSUIT.THE
LEGISLATION WILL ALSO FURTHER
REDUCE THE DEVASTATING CLIMATE
IMPACTS WILDFIRES HAVE HAD IN
OUR STATE. THE BILL SUPPORTED BY
CAL FIRE FIREFIGHTERS BECAUSE-
THE THIS UNION REPRESENTING
THOUSANDS OF THE HARDEST WORKING
MEN AND WOMEN IN CALIFORNIA.
DEFENDER COMMUNITIES IN
RESIDENTS FROM THESE UTILITY
BECAUSE WILDFIRES WHICH ARE
GROWING WORSE. AND WORSE EACH
YEAR. I WANT TO BE TRANSPARENT.
THIS IS A BIG BILL I GET IT. AND
WE'RE HAVING MULTIPLE
CONVERSATIONS WE ARE TO GET THIS
DEAL DONE WE'VE BEEN WORKING
WITH P. JEANNIE AND THE WOMEN
AND MEN WHO ARE REPRESENTED BY
THE LEXICAL WORKERS ON THE
LANGUAGE BILL. WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE OUR ACTIVE DISCUSSION
IN THE WEEKS TO COME WE'RE ALSO
WORKING WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ON THIS BILL WE'RE WORKING WITH
THE OTHER UTILITIES IN I WANT TO
BE VERY CLEAR NOT EVERY A
LEXICAL UTILITY IS CREATED
EQUAL. S. G. G. S. D. GENIE IN
THE SAN DIEGO REGION HAS BEEN A
LEADER IN THE WEST IN
UNDERGROUND IN THEIR LINES SO I
DON'T WANT. BLANKET OVER ALL
UTILITIES BUT JUST BEING CANDID
PG&E MUST DO BETTER. WE'VE ALSO
BEEN MEETING WITH TELECOM I TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS AND I'D LIKE TO TALK
ABOUT SOME OF THE AMENDMENTS
THAT WERE TAKEN FROM THE ENERGY
COMMITTEE. HERE IN GOVERNANCE
AND FINANCE TODAY. THE NUMBER%
ONE THERE ARE WIRELESS AND THEN
MEANS TODAY. TO THE LIMITS ARE
GONNA CLARIFIED THAT EXISTING
MICRO CELL SITES THAT ARE UP ON.
UTILITY POLES THEY DON'T HAVE TO
BE. PUT UNDERGROUND OBVIOUSLY
THAT WOULD NEVER WORK. NUMBER
TWO- WE ARE MAY BE MUCH MORE
STRATEGIC IN REGARDS TO WHICH-
HOLES IN LINES WOULD HAVE TO GO
UNDERGROUND. IT IS GOING TO BE
BASED OFF OF HOW. HIGHER RISK
AREAS ARE. IDENTIFIED IN THE
MANAGEMENT PLANS. I'M IN
ADDITION TO THE OTHER AMENDMENTS
. WE'RE GOING TO A REQUIRE
ELECTRIC- INDEPENDENT. L. I EAT
ELECTRIC UTILITIES TO
CONTINUOUSLY DEMONSTRATE A
REASONABLE EFFORT TO EXHAUST ANY
FEDERAL STATE AND OTHER FUNDING
BEFORE SEEKING RECOVERY FROM
RATEPAYERS. AND IT ALSO IS GONNA
REQUIRED CPC TO CONSIDER THE
RELIABILITY AND AVAILABILITY
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES WHEN
APPROVING APPLICATIONS FOR
UNDERGROUNDING TRICK
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE LAST THING
I'M GONNA SAY. IS THIS. IN THE
PREVIOUS COMMITTEE HI WE HEARD
FROM. SOME TELECONFERENCE IN IT
IS THAT THIS IS GOING TO RAISE
THE COST OF BROADBAND IN THE
STATE. AND I GOTTA TELL YA I'M
VERY PASSIONATE ABOUT BROADBAND
BECAUSE WHERE I LIVE. IT'S THE
MOST UNSERVED UNDERSERVED REGION
IN CALIFORNIA ONE OF THE MOST
UNDERSERVED REGIONS IN THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA. AND
THERE WAS AN IMPLICATION THROUGH
THE WORD SET- IT'S GONNA MAKE
THE DEPLOYMENT OF BROADBAND MORE
EXPENSIVE IN THE STATE. THERE
COULDN'T BE A MORE DISINGENUOUS
ARGUMENT AND I DON'T NEED TO GET
FIRED UP ABOUT THIS BUT IT WAS
REALLY UPSETTING TO ME BECAUSE I
WANT TO BE CANDID. THIS STATE IS
HAVING TO SPEND SIX BILLION
DOLLARS. SIX BILLION DOLLARS. TO
DEPLOY BROADBAND TO UNSERVED AND
UNDERSERVED URBAN COMMUNITIES.
BECAUSE INCUMBENTS. INCUMBENT
TELECOM WON'T SERVE THEM. AND
THEY HAVEN'T SERVE THEM FOR
YEARS YOU'RE NOT GOING TO SERVE
THEM NOW THEY'RE NOT GONNA SERVE
LATER. AND THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THESE LINES THE TEN THOUSAND
MILES A LINES. ARE GOING TO BE
BURIED IN SOME OF THE MOST RURAL
PARTS OF THE STATE. WHERE THESE
INCUMBENTS WILL NEVER INVEST. OF
THE DOESN'T MAKE BUSINESS SENSE
BUT THE STATE WELL WITH OUR SIX
BILLION DOLLARS. SO I JUST WANT
TO SAY. THAT ARGUMENT IS A BIT
HOGWASH- AND I WANTED TO ADDRESS
THAT BECAUSE IT WAS SO
DISINGENUOUS WHEN I HEARD THAT
IN THE ENERGY COMMITTEE. AND
AGAIN I DON'T NEED TO BE FIRED
UP ABOUT IT BUT IT WAS QUITE
FRUSTRATING THE LAST THING YOU
SAY IS THIS. WE'VE TAKEN UP A
LOT OF BIG BILLS OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS ON UTILITIES AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS. EVERY BILL
WE HAVE WORKED ON TOGETHER WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO STRIKE A DEAL. THAT
HAVE MADE OUR STATE MORE SAFE
AND ADDRESS CONCERNS FROM
INDUSTRY. WE HAD SB SIX SEVENTY.
THAT RELATED TO POWER OUTAGE
REPORTING FROM TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN WE HAD SB THREE FORTY
ONE. RELATED OUTAGES IN BACKUP
POWER FROM TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
BOTH OF WHICH STARTED WITH
SIGNIFICANT INDUSTRY OPPOSITION
AND WE HAD TO WORK OUR WAY
THROUGH THE- AS A SESSION MOVED
ON. WE AND I KNOW THAT EIGHT
EIGHT FOUR IS STILL A WORK IN
PROGRESS. BUT YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE BILL
WITH ALL STAKEHOLDERS. AND YES
WE MAY HAVE DISAGREEMENTS IN
COMMITTEE TODAY. BUT MY HOPE. MY
HOPE IS THAT WE'RE GOING TO GET
THIS RESOLVED. I WANT TO BE
HONEST. THE WEST UNITED STATES
IS ONLY GETTING HOTTER AND DRIER
. IN THE THREAD A WILDFIRE IS
ONLY GETTING WORSE EVERYONE
KNOWS THAT THE ONLY PATH
FORWARD. IS FOR ELECTRIC
UTILITIES SPEED UP THE PACE OF
MOVING POWER LINES UNDERGROUND
LIVES ARE LITERALLY AT RISK NOW
BE HONORED TO BE A TO WORK WITH
THIS COMMITTEE ON THIS BILL
THERE IS NO OTHER CHOICE THE
PACE OF MOVING POWER LINES ARE
BROWN. AND WITH ME TODAY I'VE
TERRY MCHALE REPRESENTING THE
WOMEN A MAN OF CALIFORNICA
TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY ONE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
AT THE APPROPRIATE TIME TO
SECURE. I THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
IS REGARDED LEADER- WHEN I'M
GOING TO MISTER MACALLAN SUPPORT
MISTER CHAIRMAN. BANDURAS SO
THIS BILL IS SO LONG OVERDUE
THOMAS EDISON WHO KNEW A FEW
THINGS ABOUT ELECTRICITY- WHEN
HE FIRST FIGURED OUT WHAT HE WAS
HARVESTING ALSO DECIDED HE
NEEDED TO. UNDERSTAND THAT A-
SURE THAT WAS INHERENT AND IN
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY TWO HUNDRED AND
FORTY YEARS AGO. IN MENLO PARK
NEW JERSEY THOMAS EDISON HAD
UNDERGROUND CONVEYANCE OF
ELECTRICAL POWER. HERE IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA REALLY
ACROSS THE COUNTRY WHAT WE'VE
BEEN DOING INSTEAD IS AFTER
EVERY MAJOR EMERGENCY WE HAVE A
STUDY. IN THE LAST TEN OR TWELVE
YEARS HAVE BEEN TEN OR TWELVE
MAJOR STUDIES DEALING WITH THE
EFFICACY IN THE NEED FOR THIS
UNDERGROUND CONVEYANCE. THE
PROBLEM IS IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS AND THAT'S WHAT BRINGS ME
HERE. IS THAT IN THE LAST FIVE
YEARS WELL WE'VE BEEN FIDDLING
AND NERO COULD HAVE BEEN
HANDLING THIS PUBLIC POLICY
BETTER THAN WHAT'S BEEN DONE
NOW. WELL WE'VE BEEN BERNIE. THE
FIREFIGHTERS HAVE BEEN FORCED TO
DEAL WITH THE WITH THE MOST
DANGEROUS AND HISTORIC FIRES IN
OUR HISTORY. IN THE LAST FIVE IN
SIX YEARS WE HAVE NOT SEEN JUST
FIRES WE'VE SEEN MEGA FIRES. WE
SEE AN ENTIRE COMMUNITIES
DESTROYED WE'VE SEEN BUSINESSES
LOST WE'VE SEN LIVES LOST. AND
MR MISTER WINNER. WE KNOW HOW
THESE FIRES ARE STARTED WE KNOW
WHO'S CAUSING THEM AND WE KNOW
THAT ULTIMATELY WE'RE GOING TO
GO UNDERGROUND AND I THINK
THAT'S THE ESSENCE IN THE BASIS
OF WHAT THE MAJORITY LEADER IS
DOING TODAY. I WOULD SAY WHERE
THERE IS SOME DISAGREEMENT THIS
IS A UTILITY PROBLEM THIS IS NOT
A. TELECOM PROBLEM. THE TELECOM
PEOPLE HAVE NOT CREATED THE
DANGER TO THE FIREFIGHTERS. AND
I'M HOPING AND I'M PLEASED TO
HEAR THE SENATOR TALKED THAT
THERE WILL BE MORE DISCUSSION IN
THAT REGARD. BUT IT IS LONG
OVERDUE THE CENTER HAS ALSO
MENTIONED THAT THE HISTORIC
FIRES THE LAST FIVE YEARS. ARE
GOING TO BE WORSE THIS YEAR. YOU
KNOW WE DIDN'T HAVE. THE WINTER
RAIN WE HAVEN'T HAD THE SNOW.
WE'RE SEEN THE PROBLEMS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE AND OF COURSE END
OF END OF DROUGHT AND OF
DISEASED TREES AND ALL OF THESE
ARE GOING TO BURN MORE
VOCIFEROUSLY IF WE DON'T START
DEALING WITH THIS FUNDAMENTAL
PROBLEM. OF MODERNIZING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT A HUNDRED
AND FORTY YEARS AGO THOMAS
EDISON WAS SAYING WAS NECESSARY
IT IS TIME IT IS NEEDED WE ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU. I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
MCCALLUM WELL NOW IS THERE ANY
OTHER. BURKE TESTIMONY HERE IN%
THE HEARING ROOM OF SO PLEASE
COME FORWARD. WELCOME GOOD
MORNING CHAIRED TWENTY MEMBERS
MY NAME IS KATHERINE BRANDENBURG
AND I REPRESENTS AN ACCLAIMED
POWER AND WE SUPPORT THE MEASURE
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THIS COMPORT. JOHN KENNEDY WITH
RC RC WE DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION SO IF I CAN HAVE A
COUPLE SECONDS TO EXPLAIN- SO WE
DON'T HAVE A POSITION BECAUSE WE%
DO HAVE SOME SERIOUS CONCERNS
WITH SOME OF THE TIME FRAMES
INVOLVED IN THE BILL WE'VE BEEN
VERY UPFRONT AND HONEST ABOUT
THAT. BUT WE'RE VERY INTERESTED
IN GETTING THIS PROJECT DONE
FASTER IN OUR COMMUNITIES A LOT
OF OUR COUNTIES WANT THESE
PRODUCTS A LOT OF OUR COUNTIES
NEED THESE PROJECTS WE NEED. FOR
THE RIGHT PROJECTS THAT ARE OUT.
BECAUSE THEY'RE CRUCIAL TO
IMPROVE ENERGY RELIABILITY AND
TO REDUCE WILDFIRES. SO WE'RE
ALSO INTERESTED IN BETTER
COORDINATING SOME OF THESE
UNDERGROUNDING EFFORTS WITH SOME
OF THE OTHER PROVIDERS TO SO WE
HOPE THAT WE CAN WORK WITH YOU
AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD TO
RESOLVE THESE ISSUES THE TELCO
ISSUES AND OTHER ISSUES. AND
APPRECIATE YOU TRYING TO HAVE
THESE DISCUSSIONS TODAY. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU AND ARE GOING FOR
WILL JUST ASK PEOPLE TO STOP
THEIR NAME AFFILIATION IF ANY
AND THE FACT OF THEIR- SUPPORT.
BY DAVID COUGHLIN NOW BEHALF OF-
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF CITIES JUST
ONE ECHO THE EARLIER COMMENTS
WHAT WE DON'T HAVE A FORMAL
POSITION WITHIN ENJOYING. THE
CONVERSATIONS WITH BOTH THE- THE
SPONSORS AND THE- AUTHOR OF THE
BILL FOR INAPPROPRIATE THOSE
DIALOGUE MOVING FORWARD THANK
YOU THANK YOU.ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT PUBLIC COMMENT HERE IN
THE ROOM- SEEING NINE WILL MOVE
TO THE PHONE LINES TO MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE QUEUE UP. ANY
SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR
. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT FOR SB EIGHTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME WHEN FALL BY
ZERO. I ONE MOMENT HERE. WE GO I
WANT TO HELP NOT GREATER ANYBODY
ELSE PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZERO TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
FOR SB EIGHT EIGHTY FOUR. CHRIS
THE. L. ONE MOMENT MYSTRA THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE THEY WERE
STILL WITH THE OPERATOR. MMHM.
AND WE WILL GO LINE SIXTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD SIXTY TWO.
MEMBERS GREG COOK RERESENTED BY
THE CALIFORNIA POWER AGENCY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS LEGISLATION
THANK YOU. I AM A SECURE NOBODY
ELSE CUED UP GREAT WILL NOW GO
TO OPPOSITION TO- S. B. I JOIN
AT THAT ARE VICE TERRACE HERE
UNTIL AFTER THIS BILL I WANT HIM
TO GAVEL OVER TO- TO HIM WELCOME
CENTER- WE'RE NOT GONNA
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT EIGHTY
FOUR- WE HAVE TO. LEAD OPPONENTS
COMING TO US FROM SAN DIEGO GAS
ELECTRIC- AND YOLANDA BENSON
FROM US TELECOM- YOU'LL EACH
HAVE TWO MINUTES- SO- FIRST UP.
SURE YOU CAN OVERSTAFFED DOESN'T
MATTER THE ORDER. OKAY THANK
YOU- GOOD MORNING MEMBERS- AND
CHAIR- STOCK HERE BUT THE
MEMBERS THAT ARE HERE- USTELECOM
AN OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT EIGHT
FOUR WHILE WE FULLY TRULY
APPRECIATE. WHERE THERE WERE THE
SENATORS COMING FROM IN TRYING
TO MITIGATE THESE HIGH FIRE
AREAS AND CREATE RESILIENCY WITH
WHAT'S HAPPENED IN THIS DISTRICT
WE DON'T WANT TO MAKE LIGHT OF
THAT. HOWEVER THERE IS A VERY
BIG COST TO TELECOM- I REPRESENT
US TELECOM WE ARE FACILITY BASED
WIRELINE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
COMPANIES IN BROADBAND PROVIDERS
IN THE STATE- THERE. THE COST TO
UNDERGROUND IS SOMETIMES TEN
TIMES THE AMOUNT TO BE AERIAL.
AND WE NEED TO HAVE THE
DISCRETION UNLIKE THE ELECTRICS
TO HAVE THE POSSIBILITY OF
OPTING IN AND DECIDING WHERE TO
GO UNDERGROUND WE DO NOT GET
THAT FRESH. THIS BILL MAN IT'S
THAT WE GO UNDERGROUND WHETHER
OR NOT IT WORKS FOR OUR
RELIABILITY OF SERVICE WHETHER
IT'S ECONOMICALLY FEASIBLE AND
MANY AREAS THAT IS NOT GOING TO
BE FEASIBLE AS WELL AS I SAID
THERE IS A COST. OF ONE OF OUR
COMPANIES DID WHICH IS JUST ONE
IS CERTAINLY JUST A JUST A COST
ONE OF OUR COMPANIES HOME HAS
PUT OUT A NUMBER OF. IT COSTS
ABOUT FIFTY THOUSAND FOR THEIR
COMPANY AND COST MORE FOR MANY
MORE FIFTY THOUSAND TO GO AERIAL
AND FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND TO GO
UNDERGROUND SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT
THE CUMULATIVE TOTAL THIS IS
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS. WE DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO RECOVER MANY
OF THE ELECTRIC UTILITIES
THROUGH THEIR RATE. POTENTIALLY
WOULD BRING EVEN HAVE FEDERAL
FUNDS AS THE AMENDMENTS WOULD BE
PUTTING UP FOR OUR PUT FORTH IN
OUR IN THE BILL. WE DO NOT HAVE
THAT KIND WE ARE RELUCTANT TO
RAISE RATES WE ARE IN A
COMPETITIVE MARKET WE DON'T WANT
TO RAISE RATES ON OUR CUSTOMERS.
I'M NOT SURE THAT OUR CUSTOMERS
WILL BE OKAY DECISIONAL
SURCHARGE FOR PAIN FOR PG&E IS
UNDERGROUNDING THIS IS THIS IS
PROBLEMATIC THERE IS A COST. AND
WE DO WANT TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH WITH THE- THE SENATOR BUT
THE COSTS ARE OVERWHELMINGLY WE
CAN'T RECOVER THEM. WE KNOW THAT
THIS LEGISLATURE THIS BODY
INCLUDING THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
HAVE PUT MORE FOR TO TRY TO
REACH THOSE LAST UNDERSERVED AND
UNSERVED AREAS OF CALIFORNIA
WHICH ARE MAINLY RULE. THIS
CREATES A NEW DINING. NOT HAVE
PROTEST IN THE PAST NOW HAVE THE
ABILITY TO SEE HOW THEY CAN
RECOVER THEIR COSTS. BY GOING TO
THAT LAST MILE- SO DID THE
INVESTMENTS THAT THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT HAS MADE THAT YOU
HAVE MADE FROM THIS LEGISLATURE.
REALLY DO CREATED DIFFERENT
DYNAMIC WE DN'T KNOW HOW MANY
OF THOSE GRANTS WOULD BE IN
THESE HIGH FIRE AREAS. BUT I
WILL TELL YOU IF IT COSTS TEN
TIMES MORE TO GO UNDERGROUND
IT'S GOING TO COST TEN TIMES
MORE. IN USING THE MONEY THAT
THIS BODY HAS PUT FORWARD WE ASK
FOR THE DISCRETION TO GO
UNDERGROUND WHEN IT WORKS. TO
WORK WITH THE UTILITIES AS WE DO
NOW WHERE WE CAN COLLABORATIVELY
AND IN PARTNERSHIP WORK
TOGETHER. AND SHARING COST WHERE
IT'S FEASIBLE- BUT WE CANNOT
SUPPORT THE BILL AT THIS TIME AS
CURRENTLY WRITTEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- WHEN I GOT A NEXT
WITNESS WHO WILL HAVE- FORTY
FIVE SECONDS BECAUSE I WENT
OVER. THAT ONE WELL OVER THE TWO
MINUTES- SO YOU CAN USE. YOUR
CAN ARGUE AMONGST YOURSELVES
LATER- SO I BELIEVE THERE'S A
DIFFERENT WITNESSES TESTIFYING
BY PHONE- IT'S NOT NIKOLINA
HERNANDEZ- MISTER MODERATOR CAN
YOU QUEUE UP OVER THE LEAD
WITNESSES ON OWN. YOU CAN ADD
ANOTHER PHOTO YOU ARE I'M SORRY
YOU ARE HERE THE LEAD WITNESS
OKAY- SO YOU CAN GO AHEAD I'M
SORRY ONLY HAVE ABOUT FORTY FIVE
SECONDS. THANK YOU I'M- NOT A
DOCTOR AND A COMMITMENT TO THIS
ISSUE AND WORKING WITH
STAKEHOLDERS REMAIN OPPOSED TO
FOCUS MY COMMENTS ON THE PROJECT
PART. THE PERMITTING LAYING OUT
ALREADY APPLIED TO PERMIT THAT
WE SUBMIT THE PUBLIC AGENCY- ALL
FOR THE PC ALREADY APPROVED
UNDERGROUNDING PROJECT THE W. P.
THREE THAT IS THE MOST HERE
PLAN- THERE'S A FULL ANALYSIS WE
HAVE A COMPREHENSIVE HOLISTIC.
APPROACH IN TERMS OF
FEASIBILITY. ON'T DELUDE.
PROJECT TOUCH TONE THAT FOR
BECAUSE- OFF. THAT WOULD BE. IN
THE COURTS SO IT'S UNCLEAR HOW.
DID LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM WHICH REQUIRES
UNIFICATION BY THE GOVERNOR BY
TWENTY FORTY WHAT ACTUALLY X.
BUT I PROCESS ON ALL THE THINGS
TO SAY THAT. WE DON'T BELIEVE
THAT YOU WOULD YEAH
UNDERGROUNDING IN FACT IT COULD
POSSIBLY BY THREE TO FIVE YEARS.
NOT TO MENTION IT UP THREE
MILLION. THE PER MILE. BROWN AND
THOSE CALLS WILL ULTIMATELY BE
BORNE CUTS TO AND OUR WITH GOING
TO GET THE CAN'T GREAT SHOCK TO
GET. WELL TO REBEL ISSUES WE GET
READY TO COME AS YOU CAN TO
REDUCE THE RISK OF WILDFIRES-
LAST OVER THE LAST FIFTEEN YEARS
WE'VE INVESTED OVER TWO BILLION
DOLLARS. ACCORDING TO ME WE
DON'T SEE AND BY DOING TO DEBUT
REMAIN OPPOSED AND RESPECTFULLY
CORRECT MY- OPINION. ABOUT
THINGS YOUR- THANK YOU FOR MUCH.
IS THERE ANY HAD. OP HE AND ROOM
COME FORTH. MISTER ACTING CHAIR
OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS BERNIE
RUSCA WITH CALIFORNIA CABLE AND
TELECOMMUNICATIONS ASSOCIATION
FOR ALL THE REASONS FOR IT OUT
BY MISPRINTS AND WE ARE OPPOSE
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANY
ADDITIONAL OPPOSITION TESTIMONY
HERE IN THE HEARING ROOM. SAYING
I WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MISTER MODERATELY PLEASE QUEUE
UP OPPOSITION TO S. B. IT FOR.
THERE IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO SB EIGHT EIGHT FOUR PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE
FILED BY ZERO FOR OPPOSITION TO
SB EIGHT EIGHT FOUR. AND WE WILL
BEGIN WITH LINE SEVENTY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SHARE MEMBERS NEED
SOUL OF ON BEHALF OF FRONTIER
COMMUNICATIONS OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED TO REMOVE THE
TELECOMMUNICATIONS PORTION OF
THE BILL THANK YOU. AND WE'LL GO
TO LINE TWENTY FOUR YOU ARE OPEN
. MORNING CHAMBER DANGER BECAUSE
THERE WAS SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
EDISON WE ARE RESPECTFULLY
OPPOSED TO ASK THE EIGHTY FOUR
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT MISTER
CHAIR WE DO HAVE A FEW MORE
QUEUING UP WITH OPERATORS AND
WE'LL GO TO LINE SIXTY THREE.
SHARE A MEMBERS ONLY SHOULD
CREATE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALCHAMBER RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
DR THANK YOU. TWENTY THIRTEEN
YOU ARE OPEN. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR THE JONATHAN ERA BELL ON
BEHALF OF THE TI EIGHTY THREE
ASSOCIATION FOR THE WIRELESS
INDUSTRY ALSO IN OPPOSITION. AND
THE FINAL REMINDER PLEASE PRESS
R. ONE ZERO TWO. I TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION TO SB EIGHT EIGHT FOR
AN ONLINE SIXTY FIVE PLEASE CALL
AT. TRANTER ON BEHALF OF TELECOM
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO SP FOUR
. SURE THERE ARE NO OTHER
PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE WILL
BRING IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
TO THE COMMITTEE- ARE THERE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS ABOUT SB EIGHT
EIGHTY FOUR. A CENTER THERE ALSO
A I JUST WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU AND THANK YOU
FOR HAVING THE PASSION BECAUSE-
YOU KNOW EVERY TIME WE GET
CONFRONTED WITH HAVING TO MAKE A
DECISION IS GOING TO BE.
IMPACTFUL AND REALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE WE ALL GET CHEYENNE
PULL BACK ON AND YET WE KNOW
WHAT WE'RE CONFRONTING AND SO I
APPRECIATE VERY MUCH THE PASSION
AND THE THOUGHTFULNESS THAT YOU.
PULL AND I'M CONFIDENT. EVER YOU
COME UP WITH IS GOING TO BE THE
RIGHT WAY RIGHT THING TO DO AND
I ALSO APPRECIATE THAT YOU
WORKING WITH THE ORGANIZATION'S
OF MEN AND WOMEN LABOR
ORGANIZATIONS. BECAUSE THEY'RE
ON THE GROUND THEY KNOW WHAT
IT'S LIKE. THEY CAN TELL YOU
THEY'RE THE EXPERTS AS FAR AS
I'M CONCERNED ON ALL OF THIS SO
PRECIADO- ALL OF THAT AND I WILL
BE SUPPORTING. MOVE THE- THANK
YOU SO MUCH. TO THE CARE IS
THERE ARE UP DO YOU WANT A
RESPONSE FROM HISTORY YES YEAH
I'LL BE THIRTY SECONDS I JUST
WANNA SAY THANK YOU TO SENATOR
ROSALYN. I KNOW YOU SPENT YOUR
LIFE ACTUALLY GOING AGAINST THE
SYSTEM ISN'T AS STRONG FOR
WORKING PEOPLE SO THAT MEANS A
LOT COMING FROM YOU AND JUST
WANNA SAY THANK YOU. BECAUSE
THAT IS WHAT YOU DEDICATE YOUR
LIFE TO DO. BIG DECISIONS ON HOW
TO BE ABLE TO IMPACT WORKING
FAMILIES. ARE IN REALLY GRATEFUL
FOR THAT. AND YOU HAVE MY WORD.
ALL THOSE FOLKS WHO ARE POSTED A
WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE TO MEET
WITH. HIM AGAIN WE GOT TO BE
ABLE TO GET THIS THING DONE AND-
I WILL WORK WITH THIS COMMITTEE
IN THE CHAIR. THANK YOU THANK
YOU CENTER NELSON. YES IT.
MCGUIRE HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO
WORK OUT ANY. ACCOMMODATIONS TO
SOME OF THE COMPLAINTS THUS FAR
LODGED I KNOW YOU'RE GONNA HAVE
SIGNED THEM MOVING AHEAD. BUT
WHAT HAS BEEN THE PROGRESS THUS
FAR THANK YOU SO MUCH AND WANT
TO SAY THANK YOU TO AT CENTER
NIELSEN FOR HIS WORK ON
WILDFIRES HAS BEEN AN HONOR TO
WORK WITH YOU THEY'RE GONNA BE
FOUR MINUTES THAT WERE BRINGING
FORTUNE ENERGY COMMITTEE TODAY I
THAT WE'RE GONNA BE TAKING
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE ONE IS
GOING TO BE REQUIRING THAT- ALL
OF THESE UNDERGROUND. ARE ONLY
IN. OUR RISKS BASED OFF OF THE
SHIPMENT PLANS THAT UTILITIES IN
THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES.
INDEPENDENT DELAYS IN THE
UTILITIES COMMISSION. ON A
BLAST. IT ALSO IS GONNA REQUIRED
THAT. ANY MICRO CELL SITES FOR
EXAMPLE ARE GONNA BE LEFT ON THE
POLLS OUR GOAL. BY THE WAY WHAT
WE CAN'T DO IT RIGHT THAT WE ARE
NOT PUT IN A CELL A QUICK MEANT
THAT ARE ON UTILITY POLES
UNDERGROUND IT WON'T WORK IN
THAT IS NOT OUR INTENT. MORE
CLARIFYING THAT THOSE THOSE THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE WILL REMAIN ON
THE POLE. NUMBER TWO- FIX EVEN
NUMBER THREE THAT- THE I'LL USE
HAVE TO CONTINUOUSLY DEMONSTRATE
THEIR THAT USED THEIR USING NON
REPAIR FUNDS SO FOR EXAMPLE.
FEDERAL INTEREST FUNDERS FIVE
BILLION DOLLARS AVAILABLE ON ANY
ADDITIONAL STATE OR OTHER
MONIES. BEFORE THEY SEEK
RECOVERY FROM RATEPAYERS IN THE
LAST ITEM IS THAT- THE CPUC HAS
TO CONSIDER THE RELIABILITY AND
AVAILABILITY OF
TELECOMMUNICATIONS SERVICES
BEFORE THAT LINE IS UNDERGROUND
I SAID THAT'S THOSE ARE FOUR
MAJOR THEM IS THAT WE'RE TAKING
HEY I'M AND WHAT.
AND WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE CAIR ON LOCAL
PERMITTING WE'RE GONNA CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE CHAIR ON ALL
ISSUES OF BROADBAND THAT WAS MY
COMMITMENT TO CAROLINE CABALLERO
I AND- YOU HAVE MY COMMITMENT
WE'VE WORKED ON SOME PRETTY
HAIRY ISSUES OVER THE YEARS AND
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU SNES AND
FOR YOUR PARTNERSHIP AND THIS
ISSUE CUTS THROUGH PARTY LINES.
EIGHT WE CAN'T GO ANOTHER SUMMER
AND FALL. WITH ANOTHER MASSIVE
WILDFIRES CAUSED BY UTILITIES.
WE HAVE TO MOVE WITH SPEED. ON
AND THAT'S WHY I COMMITTED TO
THIS AND- THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
I'M SURE COMING BACK TO BE ABLE
TO REPORT BACK TO YOU ABOUT OUR
PROGRESS IN THE COMING WEEKS AND
MONTHS. RIGHT THANK YOU THANK
YOU BOTH- I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD
FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON THE ISSUE
I'LL BE HONEST I WISH THIS BILL
WEREN'T NECESSARY YEAH. AND THE
REASON OF THIS BILL IS NECESSARY
IS BECAUSE WE HAVE A FAILED
COMPANY PG&E- A COMPANY THAT IS
BROKEN AND THAT FRANKLY HAS
HELPED. RIGHT IN THE BREAK
CALIFORNIA OR BIG SWATHS OF
CALIFORNIA IN TERMS OF ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES. THAT ARE BURNING
DOWN- I JUST MASSIVE THREATS-
BECAUSE- THIS COMPANY HAS FAILED
TO MAINTAIN UPGRADE AND
MODERNIZE ITS SPRAWLING
INFRASTRUCTURE. THIS IS A
COMPANY THAT HAS HAD A MASSIVE
MONOPOLY. THROUGH I'M- IT
THROUGH THE MAIL THE BULK OF
CALIFORNIA- AND YET IT HAS
FOCUSED ON ITS SHAREHOLDERS. AS
OPPOSED TO INVESTING TO HAVE THE
MOST THE SAFEST AND MOST
RELIABLE ELECTRIC INFRASTRUCTURE
FOR THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA-
AND THAT HAS TO CHANGE AND WE'RE
NOW STUCK HOLDING THE BAG. WE'RE
NOT HOLDING THE BAG AND AMOUNT
OF TAXPAYER RESOURCES THAT IS
HAD TO GO TO CLEAN UP THE MESS
THAT PG&E HAS CREATED IS JUST
EXTRAORDINARY AND BREATHTAKING
AND I WISH THAT WE COULD HAVE
USED THOSE FUNDS TO. FIX OUR
SCHOOLS AND TO IMPROVE OUR
TRANSPORTATION SYSTEMS AND SO ON
AND SO FORTH INSTEAD WE'VE HAD
TO JUST CLEAN UP PG&E IS MASS.
OVER AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN-
AND IT'S LIKE- IT'S LIKE YOU SEE
THE MOVIE OVER AND FORGET AND WE
SAY WE'RE GOING TO DO THIS THING
AND THEN WE DON'T I YOU KNOW I
DON'T THINK YOU DO NEED TO BE A
SHAREHOLDER. OWNED COMPANY AND I
HAVE. INTRODUCED LEGISLATION A
FEW YEARS AGO TO MAKE IT A
PUBLICLY OWNED COMPANY- THAT
LEGISLATION DID NOT EVEN GET A
HEARING- INVEST- BUILDING. AND
WE NEED TO HAVE STRUCTURAL
CHANGES OF PG&E. SO THAT IS
ACTUALLY. FOCUSED LIKE A LASER.
ON HAVING RELIABLE SAFE SERVICE
IT DOESN'T BURN DOWN ENTIRE
CITIES IN CALIFORNIA I DON'T I'M
VERY SKEPTICAL THAT PG&E IS
CAPABLE OF DOING THAT AS LONG AS
IT IS BEHOLDEN TO WALL STREET
WHICH IS WHAT IS HAPPENING RIGHT
NOW. BUT WE ARE WHERE WE ARE-
AND SO THIS LEGISLATION IS AN
IMPORTANT STOP IN IN TRYING TO
DO WHAT SHOULD'VE BEEN HAPPENING
ALL ALONG TO MAKE THIS
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFE AND SO I'M
HAPPY TO SUPPORT AND I COMMEND
THE AUTHOR FOR DOING VERY HARD-WORK THERE'S A LOT OF
STAKEHOLDERS INVOLVED HERE- AND
I CAN ONLY IMAGINE THE AMOUNT OF
TIME AND ENERGY THAT YOU. HAVE
PUT INTO IT CONTINUE TO PUT INTO
IT AGAIN IF YOU'RE- AND- WITH
THAT- ALL ENTERTAINED I'M A
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL. THANK
YOU HAVE ONE DOWN THERE HELLO I
APOLOGIZE. AND I'LL BE A MOTION
TO PASS AS AMENDED SO- WITH
THAT- SENATE MCGUIRE YOU MAY
CLOSE THE SECURITY SERVICES
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ELOQUENT IN
PERSONAL REMARKS THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN VERY FOCUSED ON THIS ISSUE
AS WELL AND I'M GRATEFUL FOR
YOUR LEADERSHIP. TRULY
UNNECESSARY YOU HAVE MY
COMMITMENT THAT WE'RE GONNA
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH TERM
CABALLERO. ON ALL ISSUES LOCAL
PERMITTNG IN BROADBAND. BEGIN
WORK IN PROGRESS THERE WILL BE
CHANGES AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING DIRECTLY WITH HER AND
UNDERSERVED NOW. AND I LEFT OUT
JESSICA IN THE VERY BEGINNING
AMAZING TAX GROUP CONSULTANT AND
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
HER WORK AS WELL AND WITH
RESPECT ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU
SO MUCH GOOD. THANK YOU. WHEN I
CALL THE ROLL. THE IS PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATORS
CAMBIADO. NIELSEN. DORADO HI
DORADO HI HERTZBERG. WIENER AYE
WIENER I IT HAS- TWO VOTES AND
WILL PUT ON CALL FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH US
AND REQUIRE AND I WILL NOW
PASSED THE GAVEL OVER TO OUR
VICE CHAIR SENATOR NELSON. AND.
NEXT BILL IS NUMBER SIX DODD.
WHAT IT. TURNS OUT OF NEWMAN I
DIDN'T SEE OF THEIR GENDER THE
NEWMAN PLEASE COME FORWARD. SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN SIR. YEAH
THANK YOU COMMITTEE MORNING
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS ARE PRE
SHOULD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN WHEN PASSED SB THIRTY
SEVENTY SEVEN WILL ACCEPT THE
TOURNEY'S FREEZE AWARDED AND
CONSUMER PROTECTION LEGAL
SETTLEMENT FROM BEING COUNTED
AGAINST THE CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS
ADJUSTED GROSS INCOME. I'D LIKE
TO COME OVER TO PROBABLY THINK
COMMITTEE STAFF THE SPONSORS IN
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD FOR
THEIR ASSISTANCE WITH THE MOST
RECENT AMENDMENTS TO ENSURE THAT
THE INTENT OF THE BILL WAS
CAPTURED ACCURATELY. CALIFORNIA
LIKE OTHER STATES THAT
RIGOROUSLY ENFORCE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS ALLOWS LAWYERS TO
REPRESENT CLIENTS IN CONSUMER
PROTECTION CASES. WITHOUT
CHARGING THEM DIRECTLY FOR THE
LEGAL SERVICES IN A PROCESS
CALLED FEE SHIFTING. THIS ALLOWS
EVERYDAY PEOPLE TO PURSUE
CONSUMER PROTECTION LAWSUITS BY
REMOVING THE COST BARRIERS
ASSOCIATED HAVING A QUALIFIED
AND KNOWLEDGEABLE ATTORNEY
REPRESENT THEM. DEBT COLLECTION
FINANCIAL LENDING CREDIT
REPORTING VEHICLE SAFETY AND
OTHER CONSUMER PROTECTION CASES
ARE OFTEN TIME CONSUMING AND
COSTLY RESULTING IN JUDGMENTS OR
SETTLEMENTS INCLUDE SUBSTANTIAL
LEGAL FEES. IN RECENT YEARS
COMPANIES ON THE LOSING SIDE OF
CONSUMER PROTECTION LAWSUITS
HAVE MADE A PRACTICE OF ISSUING
IRIS TEN NINETY NINE FORMS THE
TRIGGERING ALL OR SOME. OF THE
ATTORNEYS FEES AS PERSONAL
INCOME RECEIVED BY INDIVIDUAL
PARTICIPATING TUMOR PROTECTION
LAWSUIT. THE PRO RATED AMOUNT OF
LEGAL FEES A TRIBUTE TO A
PLAINTIFF CAN BE VERY LARGE EVEN
THOUGH THE PLAINTIVE ACTUALLY
RECEIVED NO CASH BENEFIT FROM
THEM AND CAN REPRESENT A
SUBSTANTIAL TAX LIABILITY AS A
RESULT. IN MANY CASES EXCEEDING
THE ACTUAL WORD AN INDIVIDUAL
PLAINTIFF MAY HAVE RECEIVED.
TOURNEY STREAK BUT TRIBUNE AS
INCOME THEY ALSO THE PLAINTIFFS
ELIGIBILITY FOR IMPORTANT
PROGRAMS LIKE THE CALIFORNIA
EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT HOUSING
BENEFITS. EDUCATION BENEFITS OR
MORE MORE. FURTHER IT'S
IMPORTANT NOTE THAT THE
ATTORNEYS WHO WOULD ACTUALLY
RECEIVE THESE AWARDS ALSO
RECEIVE A FORM TEN NINETY NINE
FOR THE PAYMENT OF THEIR FEES.
RESULTING IN THE SAME SETTLEMENT
FUNDS INFECTION TAX NOT ONCE BUT
TWICE FRUITING TOURNEY'S THESE
AS A TAX LIABILITY ASSIGNABLE TO
A PLAINTIFF IN A FEW SHIFTED
CASE UNDERMINES THE INTENT. OF
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING CONSUMER
PROTECTION LAWS MORE OVER THE
PROSPECT OF THAT HAPPENING HAS
BEEN LEVERAGED BY CORPORATE
DEFENDANTS. TO INTIMIDATE AND
DISSUADE CONSUMERS FROM MOVING
FORWARD WITH AN OTHERWISE
RIGHTEOUS CASE SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN WILL EXTENDED TWO
THOUSAND FOUR FEDERAL TAX
AMENDMENT. TO PROVIDE AN ABOVE
THE LINE DEDUCTION FOR FEE
AWARDS RECOVERING CONSUMER
PROTECTION CASES SEVEN ATTORNEYS
FEES WILL NOT COUNT AGAINST AN
INDIVIDUAL'S ADJUSTED GROSS
INCOME. ON THEIR STATE TAXES
THIS COMMONSENSE EXEMPTION WILL
RELEASED RELIEF CONSUMERS OF
UNDUE UNJUSTIFIED FINANCIAL
BURDENS WHILE REINFORCING
PROTECTIONS FOR CONSUMERS WHO'VE
BEEN HARMED AS A RESULT OF A
PRODUCT DEFECT OR ILLEGAL
BUSINESS PRACTICES- I
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME TO TESTIFIED BY
PHONE TODAY ARE ROBERT CARROLL.
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION CALIFORNIA.
WAS MARY SHANAHAN PRESIDENT OF
CONSUMERS FOR AUTO. RELIABILITY
SAFETY OR CARS. IN PROCEED WITH
YOUR WITNESS REFERRAL FIRST-
WHICH ONE DO WITH- MISTER AND
BOTH ARE ON THE PHONE. PLEASE
PRESS ONE IN THE MISTER
CHAIRMAN. AND LYFT GERMAN THE
MEMBERS. MARLBORO THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION CALIFORNIA WHERE
TRUCKERS FINANCER OF ENERGY IN
THISBILL SB THIRTEEN TWENTY
SEVEN- THEY'RE VERY BRIEFLY TO
THE NAVAL ON THE GENDER AND LOTS
OF FOLKS HAVE TO BE SIMULTANEOUS
PLACES- THIS IS A SIMPLE MATTER
OF DOUBLE TAXATION- THE
ATTORNEYS WHO TOOK ON THESE
CASES ARE ALREADY BEING TAXED
FOR THE RINKER MENTIONED HER
NEWMAN SAID. AND THERE'S NO
REASON WHATSOEVER WHY THE
CONSUMER ON THE TAXES WELL
ACTIVE CASES THAT WE'VE SEEN-
INCLUDE FOR EXAMPLE. PEOPLE WHO
GET A LEMON AND THEY JUST WANT
THE MANUFACTURER HAS THE DEALER
TO TAKE THAT BACK IF THIS IS A
SMALL PURCHASE YOU GO BACK TO
THE STORE AND GET YOUR REFUND
THAT'S IT. BUT IN THIS SITUATION
BEFORE BEING SERVED WITH THAT
TEN NINETY NINES FOR TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS AND THEY
CAN'T EVEN BE ABLE TO REMOTE WE
CALCULATE HOW THAT CAME FROM BUT
WHAT HAPPENED- SO TO DOUBLE
TAXATION MATTER AND WE DON'T SEE
IT UNIFORMLY APPLIED. WE SEE
CERTAIN COMPANIES BEING
EXTREMELY AGGRESSIVE- WHICH IS A
SORT OF INTIMIDATION TACTIC
AGAINST CONSUMERS ATTEMPTING TO
EXERCISE THEIR RIGHTS SO FOR
THOSE REASONS- AND WE WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR AND- COMMITTEE
STAFF AND HAS TO BE FOR ALL
WORKING WITH A SNORKEL SPONSORS
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT. SB THIRTY
SEVEN SEVEN THANK YOU. AND NEXT
WITNESS. MR FIVE CARE NUMBER BY
TO MARRY HIM CAN FOR AUTO
REALIZED AND OR CALL AND WE'RE
TO BE COACHED SB THIRTY SEVENTY
SEVEN ALONG WITH THAT CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA AND I
WOULD ADD TO- THE TESTIMONY
YOU'VE ALREADY HEARD ABOUT THE
BUILT IT NOT ONLY DO VICTIMS OF
ILLEGAL PRACTICES BASED HAVING
TO PAY TAXES ON INCOME THEY
NEVER RECIEVED WHICH IS
OBVIOUSLY UNFAIR BUT THEY MAY
ALSO BE COMING IN ELIGIBLE FOR
ASSISTANCE AND BENEFITS THAT
THEY AND THEIR FAMILIES
DESPERATELY NEEDED. AND THAT THE
STATE- INTENDS TO PROVIDE TO
THEM SOMETIMES TO KEEP THEM FROM
BECOMING HOMELESS OR MAKE SURE
THAT THEY HAVE ENOUGH TO EAT-
WHEN THERE'S A POSTED INCOMES
ARE INFLATED BY THIS UNFAIR
DOUBLE PACK AND JUST AS ONE
EXAMPLE OF CONSUMER WHO LIVE
THING GUARDINO WHO HAD A- WITHIN
MILITARY VETERANS SINGLE MOM
WITH FOUR KIDS ONE WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS- WAS COUNTING ON GETTING
HER EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
AFTER HE GOT LAID OFF. AND THEN
MAKE IN. SIX OUT DOLLARS THE HE
WAS A- TO GET WITH THE MAY
BECAUSE- SHE HAD PURCHASED A
LEMON FROM FIAT CHRYSLER AND
THEY CENTER A TEN NINETY NINE-
NOT FOR THE AMOUNT THAT SHE
RECEIVED AND REFUND BUT FOR. AN
ADDITIONAL SIXTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS. IN A SHE NEVER BOX- AND
HE ENDED UP HAVING TO SPEND SIX
MONTHS WRANGLING WITH THE IRS
AND ENLISTING THE AID OF A TAX
ACCOUNTANT IN ORDER TO FINALLY
GET THE EARNED INCOME TAX CREDIT
. AND- OKAY LIKE THAT MAKE US
VERY MOTIVATED TO. IMPORTANT THE
BILL AND IF I COULD JUST NOTE
FOR THE RECORD THAT THE
OPPONENTS OF THE BILL SUBMITTED
A LETTER TO THE COMMITTEE CITING
A CASE. WHERE CONSUMER- BROUGHT
OUT OF LEMON CASE AGAINST JAGUAR
ALLEGING THAT HIS VEHICLE WAS A
LEMON AND THAT THAT CASE IS
REALLY AN OUT LIAR FAR FROM
TYPICAL THE CONSUMER IN THAT
CASE WAS AWARDED ONLY NOMINAL
DAMAGES BUT HIS ATTORNEY WAS
AWARDED OVER. SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS IN ATTORNEY'S
FEES AND USUALLY WOMEN OWNERS
RECEIVE A REFINED AND THEIR
ATTORNEYS FEES ARE QUITE MODEST-
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT
IN JANUARY THE COURT OF APPEALS
REVERSED THAT DECISION KICKING
IT BACK TO THE LOWER COURT. AND
THAT THE COURT OF APPEALS ALSO
FOUND THAT IT WAS THE DEFENDANT.
JAGUAR THAT'D FILED MOTION AFTER
MOTION TO SUPPRESS INFORMATION
AND QUOTING FROM THE COURT'S
DECISION PERHAPS SUCH FEES WERE
JUSTIFIED AFTER ALL TRIAL WAS
DELAYED OVER TWO YEARS IN THIS
MATTER AND IT APPEARS THAT
JAGUAR'S ACTIONS FOR THE
IMPOTENCE FOR MOST OF NOT ALL OF. THE DELAY SO. JEFF TO GET A
OUT THERE THE CASE THAT THE
OPPONENTS BY THE- FIRE THE NORM
- AND THERE'S MORE TO THE STORY
AND WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE. FOUR SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN THANK YOU. CAN
THANK YOU. ELEVEN EIGHT
ADDITIONAL. TESTIMONY AND
SUPPORT. THERE ARE NONE THEN WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE. ON THE ON THE
PHONE PRESS RICHARD DO WE HAVE
ANYBODY IN Q. THANK YOU MISTER-CHAIR IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO WOULD
YOU LIKE TO TAKE OPPOSITION THE
STUDY SUPPORT FIRST AND Q. OKAY
. YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR
SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME WHEN BARBERO FOR
SUPPORT. ON SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY IS
KILLING UP. I DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITION. MODERATOR YOU'D LIKE
IF YOU'D LIKE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO. AND WE DO HAVE ONE QUEUING
UP ONE MOMENT PLEASE. FOR
EVERYBODY ELSE GOING HIT ONE
ZERO TO PUT YOURSELF IN QUEUE
FOR OPPOSITION TO SB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN. AND OUR FIRST
PURCHASE WILL BE ONE SEVENTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THERE
JEANNIE HALF WITH EXTERNAL
JOHNSON SB NATION CALIFORNIA-
CALLING IN. THANK YOU. AND AS A
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO.
YOU LIKE EXPRESSED OPPOSITION-
BE- THIRTY SEVENTY SEVEN WE DO
HAVE ANOTHER ONE WITH AN
OPERATOR ONE MOMENT PLEASE. THE
LINE SIXTY SEVEN YOU ARE OPEN.
THANK YOU BRITTANY AND FOR THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
HERE IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TODAY I JUST WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHORS STAFF TO THE PROPER
CONVERSATIONS THEY'VE ENGAGED
AND WE CERTAINLY LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING THOSE. THERE ARE NO
OTHER ARTICIPANTS CUED UP. THE
CHAMBER HAVE ANY REASONS FOR THE
OPPOSITION YOU STATED OPPOSITION
BUT DO YOU HAVE ANY REASONS. UP
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AGAIN SIR
IF YOU'D LIKE TO RESPOND. OKAY
WILL REOPEN ITS LINE THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR GO AHEAD SIXTY
SEVEN. THE CONCERN THAT WE HAVE
FROM AN EMPLOYER BASED
PERSPECTIVE IS- THIS COULD IN
SOME WAY INTENSIFIES- OF
LAWSUITS SURGERY FEES ARE ISSUES
SO I'M NOT A CONCERN WITH THE
DRESS OF THE AUTHOR AND STAFF IN
THE RECEPTIVE TO IT SO WHEN I
REFER TO THE CONVERSATION
WITHOUT THAT- THE SPECIFIC- AREA
THAT WE'RE CONCERNED ABOUT.
THANK YOU QUITE OFTEN THE
ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS YOURS
DON'T OFFER ANY REASONS AND- I
THINK IT'S HELPFUL TO HAVE YOUR
RATIONALE. TELL THANK YOU FOR
THAT COMMENT. ALL RIGHT TO ANY
OTHER IN Q. THAT'S IT THE
EXHAUSTION OF ALL OF THE SUPPORT
AND OPPOSITION MODERATOR. YES
HEY. ALL RIGHT WOULD YOU LIKE TO
GIVE US A CLOSING I'D SURELY
WOULD SO THANK YOU MEMBERS SO IT
YOU KNOW TO MR YOUNG'S POINT OF
VIEW I DO I'M ALWAYS CONCERNED
ABOUT UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES
WITH LEGISLATION SO THAT IS
SOMETHING WE'VE AGREED TO
CONTINUE TALKING ABOUT SO WE
DON'T WANT TO IMPLEMENTATION SET
OF EYES- YUDDHAM ADDITIONAL
LITIGATION WHERE IT'S NOT
NECESSARY BUT- AS BOTH
WITNESSES- YOU VERY CLEARLY
ELUCIDATED. THERE'S REALLY TWO
ISSUES HERE THE FIRST IS DOUBLE
TAXATION- YOU KNOW FIVE. WHICH
EVERYBODY WOULD AGREE IT.
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE IN THIS CASE
IT IS THE ATTORNEY TO RECEIVE
THE CASH BENEFIT- OF THE
PAYMENTS AS IT IS THEY WHO
SHOULD PAY THE TAXES FOR IT- THE
OTHER CONCERN IS. THE
DISINCENTIVE ASIAN OF THE
INTIMIDATION. ORCHESTRATION OF.
PROSPECTIVE PLAINTIFFS- FOR
PURSUING OTHERWISE LEGITIMATE
GRIEVANCES IN IN RESPONSE TO THE
THREAT. OF A TAX BURDEN THEY
MIGHT IT CRUZ SIMPLY BY- YOU
KNOW AVAILING THEMSELVES OF
THEIR- LEGAL RIGHTS IN THE
CALIFORNIA CONSUMER PROTECTION
LAW. THIS BILL DOES THAT BY
ELIMINATING THE DOUBLE TAXATION
WITH WITH WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AGO.AGAIN
I. DID YOU HAVE A QUESTION. WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SENATOR RUSSELL
. MOTION TO PASS. HELLO THE
OCEAN IS TO PASS BUT FIRST BE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATOR CAPITO.
NIELSEN NO NIELSEN NOW DORADO
DORADO HI HERTZBERG WIENER AYE
WIENER HI. TWO TO ONE THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU. YEAH GENERAL
CASKEY. YES MISTER MEISTER THIS
IS ITEM NUMBER SIX. OKAY. TEN
NINETY NINE CORRECT CORRECT
CORRECT AND FIRST OFF MEMBERS I
WILL BE ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
CONTAINED IN THE ANALYSIS AND
THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
IMPROVING THE BILL THIS MEASURED
TEN SB TEN NINETY NINE MAKES A
MODEST UP IMPORTANT- UPDATES OR
BANKRUPTCY LAW SPECIFIC TO THE
COMMITTEES- PURVIEW THE BILL
CAPS THE INTEREST RATE PAYABLE
ON DELINQUENT REAL ESTATE. TAXES
IN A BANKRUPTCY CASE AT 10%
RATHER THAN THE CURRENT 18% THIS
80% WAS SET UP IN NINETEEN
EIGHTY ONE WE REMEMBER THE
INFLATIONARY CASE AT THAT TIME
AND NOBODY HAS STARTED IN FORTY
YEARS TO UPDATED- SO YOU KNOW
THE STATE LAW PROVIDES THAT 10%
IN INTEREST ON JUDGMENTS AND
MAKES INTERESTS OVER 10% YOU
STRESS SO IT'S NFUSZ AND
COLLECTIBLE SO WE'RE TRYING TO
CONFORM THAT WITH THE- THE- THE
80% THAT'S PERMITTED ON PROPERTY
TAX CLAIMS. TO CONFORM THAT AT
LEAST WITHIN- THE BANKRUPTCY
ROUTE A BY THE WAY THAT THESE
CLAIMS ON THE PROPERTY TAXES
HAVE FIRST PRIORITY SO THEY GET
PAID FIRST OFF- WITHIN THAT HAD
A DEBTOR'S CHAPTER THIRTEEN AND
SUCCESS RATE AND CHAPTER
THIRTEEN IS REALLY PREDICATED ON
HOW THE DEBTORS ABILITY TO PAY
SO IF YOU'RE PAYING 18% ON THE
INTEREST THEN YOU. PRESS THE
ANOTHER 10% IT BE JUST BECOMES
YOU KNOW DIFFICULT TO FACILITATE
THAT THESE APPLICATIONS WITH ME
ON THE PHONE LINE IS A JENNY A
DOUBLING HE'S AN ATTORNEY SHE IS
A MEMBER OF THE- AND PART OF THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS OF THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF CONSUMER
BANKRUPTCY ATTORNEYS AND
ORIGINAL VOTE. AND THIS IS MRS
DOLING DOLING YES OKAY
MISSPELLING. THE WISH TO TESTIFY
. YES IDEA. PLEASE PROCEED. THE
MORNING THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME
I REPRESENTS DEBTORS CREDITORS
IN BANKRUPTCY TRUSTEES AND I'D
LIKE TO ADDRESS YOU COMPONENTS
OF S. B. TEN NINETY NINE I FIRST
ATTENDED A WHITE HOUSE STATEMENT
THEN THE PROPERTY TAX QUESTION
SB TEN NINETY NINE DOES NOT TAKE
AWAY THE COUNTY IS RIGHT AND
THAT. THE BILL PROPOSES A
REASONABLE CATHOLIC DOES NOT
INDICATE THE DEBTORS ABILITY TO
BRING THE PROPERTY TAX THAT THE
CURRENT OVER A THREE TO FIVE
YEAR BANKRUPTCY PLAN OF
REORGANIZATION IT SHOULD BE
NOTED THAT NEITHER THE IRS NOR
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD GET MORE
THAN 4% INTEREST IN A BANKRUPTCY
PLAN OF REORGANIZATION. THE
MAINTAINING THE FAMILY HOME
SHOULD BE A CORE CONCERN FOR
EVERYONE ESPECIALLY IN THE
FINANCE NATIONAL HOUSING CRISIS
WE ARE FACING FACING THIS BILL
DOES NOT REQUIRE SPECIAL OR
DIFFICULT CALCULATIONS WHATEVER
THE DEBT IS OWED ON THE DATE THE
BANKRUPTCY IT FILED WILL BE PAID
THAT 10% INTEREST INSTEAD OF 18%
DIFFERENT THAN WHAT ENCOURAGE
DELINQUENT HOMEOWNERS TO
REORGANIZE THEIR DEBT IN A
CHAPTER THIRTEEN BANKRUPTCY
WHICH PUTS MONEY BACK INTO OUR
COUNTY COFFERS AND CAN MEAN THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A HOMEOWNER.
STATING THEIR HOME OR NOT THE
ISSUE I JUST WANT TO BRIEFLY
TOUCH ON IS THE HOMESTEAD
APPRECIATION SECTION OF S. B.
TEN NINETY NINE. EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT FOR A VERY SIMPLE
REASON. WHEN A DEBTOR FOR. AND
ARE IS A FROM THE DATE THEY
FILED A CASE THAT SHOULD BE A IF
YOU CLOSE. INSTEAD TRUSTEE CAN
HUMAN AT THE FOR. I HOLDING.
OPEN TO ALLOW PROPER VALUES
INCREASE FOR THE TRUSTEES CAN
SELL THOSE HOMES. THIS IS AN
UNFAIR MANIPULATION OF THE
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION CODES THAT
ARE INTENDED TO PROTECT. A
MEDIAN PRICED HOME. THE FILING
THE BANKRUPTCY IS AND SHOULD BE
A LINE DRAWN IN THE SAND. THE
VALUE OF THE AFFECT ON THAT DATE
THE BANKRUPTCY IS FILED SHOULD
BE THE DETERMINING FACTOR. THIS
IS NO DIFFERENT THAN THE OTHER
WAYS THAT WE VALUE OUT THAT BUT
TO THE DEBTORS WAGES AND THE
BETTER THINK ACCOUNT ON THE DATE
THE BANKRUPTCY IS FILED. HAVE
BEEN BETTER CONTINUES TO WORK
AFTER THE BANKRUPTCY IS FILED
HIS HAIR IS DEPOSITED INTO HIS
BANK ACCOUNT INCREASING NOT BANK
ACCOUNT VALUE. BOTH BANK ACCOUNT
INCREASING IN VALUE SHOULD NOT
BE ABLE TO BE SEEN BY LAW. AND
ARE NOT ABLE TO BE SEATED. THE
ONLY RELATIVELY THE BANKRUPTCY
CASE OPEN IN PERPETUITY
UNDERMINING THE FRESH START
INTENDED BY CONGRESS. ATTENTION
INCREASE IN VALUE IN A HOME IS
NO DIFFERENT AND IT SHOULD
AMERICANS GET BETTER BENEFIT NOT
THE- BANKRUPTCY ESTATE AGAIN WE
JUST DON'T WANT AN UNFAIR
MANIPULATION OF EXEMPTIONS.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SPEAK ON HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY.
QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THE WITH
THE HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS. KNOWN
RESTORING THAT'S IT OKAY. ALL
RIGHT AND DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITE. ON THAT OKAY MORE
SUPPORT PLEASE COME FORWARD.
YOUR POST YEAH ALL RIGHT DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT. ON
THE PHONE. YEAH DO WE HAVE TO.
MODERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY CALL IN
. SUPPORT. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. ONE FILED
BY ZERO. MISTER CARE NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP ALL RIGHT WE HAVE AN
OPPOSITION WITH FORTY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE THE DALLAS
CELANESE ON BEHALF OF THE
TRUSTEES FOR REASONABLE
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION LIMITS WHICH
IS A GROUP OF BANKRUPTCY
TRUSTEES THE CALIFORNIA JUDGMENT
PRESERVATION ALLIANCE WHICH IS
COMPRISED OF JUDGMENT
ENFORCEMENT PROFESSIONALS BOTH
STRONGLY OPPOSED SB TEN NINETY
NINE. ON JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY
TWENTY ONE THANKS EXPONENTIAL
INCREASE OF THE HOMESTEAD
EXEMPTION WENT INTO AFFECT THE
DEPEND UPON YOUR AGE AND MARITAL
STATUS THE INCREASE RANGE
BETWEEN THREE HUNDRED AND 50%
28100% EVEN THOUGH THE
CALIFORNIA'S CONSUMER PRICE
INDEX ONLY INCREASED BY 21%
DURING THAT TIME PERIOD. SB TEN
NINETY NINE SETS IN MOTION
ADDITIONAL HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION
LIMITS. BEYOND WHAT WAS INCREASE
JUST LAST YEAR. ONCE AGAIN
WEALTHY DONORS ARE ENCOURAGED TO
SHELTER MONEY FROM MORE THE
CREDITORS. BY WAY OF EXAMPLE
THEY ATTRACT A BANKRUPTCY
TRUSTEE SELL THE DEBTORS ARE ONE
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLAR
RESIDENTS. AND THE RESIDENCE HAS
AN UNPAID PRINCIPAL BALANCE OF
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
AFTER SATISFYING SALES COSTS
PAYING OFF THE THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR MORTGAGE BALANCE
THE PAIN THE DEBTOR THERE SIX
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLAR
HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION THE NET
PROCEEDS WOULD BE APPROXIMATELY
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
PURSUANT TO BANKRUPTCY CODE THE
BANKRUPTCY TRUSTEE WOULD THEN
DISTRIBUTE THE NET PROCEEDS BY
PAYING THE DEBTORS WERE THE
CREDITORS. HOWEVER OF F. S. B.
TEN NINETY NINE WORDS WAS
ENACTED. THE DEBTOR WOULD ARGUE
THAT THE RESIDENTS APPRECIATED
DURING THE CASE. THAT THEY
SHOULD EXEMPTS SOME OR ALL THE
NET PROCEEDS FROM THE SALE. SUCH
ISSUE WOULD NOT ONLY HAVE TO BE
LITIGATED. BUT IT HAS THE
ADDITIONAL FACT FURTHER
INCREASING THE DEBTORS HOMESTEAD
EXEMPTION. ON THE SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLAR AMOUNT THAT WAS
JUST RECENTLY ADOPTED. OPPONENTS
CLAIM THAT TRUSTEES ARE
PURPOSELY SITTING ON DEBTORS
REAL PROPERTY SO CAN APPRECIATE.
THIS IS A SOLUTION IN SEARCH OF
A PROBLEM. DEBTORS CAN
IMMEDIATELY MOVE FOR VANAMAN
UNDER SECTION FIVE FIVE FOUR B.
OF THE BANKRUPTCY CODE. IT IS A
SIMPLE MOTION THAT OBVIATES THE
NEED FOR FURTHER INCREASES IN
THE HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION. ARE
THERE FOR THE TRUSTEES FOR
REASONABLE HOMESTEAD EXEMPTION
LIMITS. AND THE CALIFORNIA
JUDGMENT PRESERVATION ALLIANCE
RESPECTFULLY URGES THAT YOU VOTE
NO ON SB TEN NINETY NINE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. ANY ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION HERE
PRESENT. MODERATOR DO YOU HAVE
ANY COMMENTS. IN OPPOSITION HERE
IF YOU WOULD LIKE. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION TO
SB TEN NINETY NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE ZERO ONE FILED BY ZERO FOR
OPPOSITION TO THE SP TEN NINETY
NINE. I ONE MOMENT PLEASE. I
THEY TOOK THEMSELVES LIKE YOU IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO- SB TEN NINETY
NINE. WE DO HAVE ONE QUEUING UP.
MODERATOR ON ASIA ONE OF THE
PROCEEDING YEAH ONE MOMENT YES I
AM I'M SORRY YOUR SUPPORT THE
OPERATOR. SHOULD BE WITH THE
TWENTY SECOND AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
NINE. YES MY NAME IS GRETCHEN
LYNCHING BURGER AND I AM CALLING
ON BEHALF OF JUSTICE MATTERS WE
PROTECT THE RIGHTS OF CREDITORS
WHO ARE OWED MONEY. AND THIS
BILL IS ADDING THE WORD WAGES
INTO. THE- IN THE BILL AB AND
THE CREW THE MOUNT OF MONEY AND
IT'S NOT IN THE CRUDE AMOUNT OF
MONEY IT AS PAID. SO WE'VE
STARKLY OPPOSED AND FIFTY PER
NINETY NINE AND ASK FOR YOUR
NOTEBOOK THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NOBODY ELSE IS CUTE MISTER CHAIR
NOBODY ELSE. ALL RIGHT AT THIS
TIME SIR. IF YOU WANNA GO AHEAD
THEN YEAH I WOULD I'D- WHICH IS
BEING ADDED BECAUSE SOMETIMES
PEOPLE HAVE DISPUTED WAGES AND
THE IDEA IS THAT IF YOU'RE GOING
TO BANKRUPTCY THE TRUSTEE HAS
ALL THE POWERS TO SETTLE THOSE
WAGE CLAIMS THAT YOU HAD SO WE
WANTED TO ALLOW THAT THE DEBTOR
IF THEY'RE HAVING A DISPUTE AND
IT JUST HAPPENS THAT THE TIMING
WAS OFF- THAT THEY WOULD. THEY
WOULD RETAIN THOSE RIGHTS AND WE
PUT A CAP ON IT AS SAID AS SAID
IN THE PREVIOUS COMMITTEE AT
JUDICIARY DEAD- BURKE I WOULD
JUST URGE IN AN AYE VOTE THIS IS
A PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD.
NOTHING DRASTIC CARE THE
SNAPSHOT RULE IS APPLIED TO THE
DEBT AS WELL AS TO THE VALUE OF
THE PROPERTY AND THAT'S WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR ON THAT ON THE
VALUE OF THE HOUSE- JENNIFER.
GRANT CENTER LIKE ASKING YOUR
VERY KNOWLEDGEABLE IN THIS AREA
THANK YOU SIR PROBABLY OUR
RESIDENT EXPERT. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS THE LOAN
FROM BY SENATOR ALSO. CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND AND WE
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS
CABALLERO. NIELSEN AYE NIELSEN
AYE DORADO DORADO I HERTZBERG.
WIENER. TWO TWO ZERO THANK YOU
MR VICE CHAIR OF EUROPE RIGHT.
AND DINNER IN A HOTEL. MORNING
GOOD MORNING SIR. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND- MEMBER. I'M
PLEASED TO PRESENT SENATE BILL
ELEVEN EIGHTY ONE WHICH SEEKS TO
STRENGTHEN THE CALIFORNIA'S
TRACKING SYSTEM WITH REGARDS TO
TIRE FLOWS FROM CALIFORNIA AND
OTHER STATES IN CHEWBACCA
CALIFORNIA AND SONATAS AS MANY
OF YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN WORKING
HARD ON- RESTORING SOME VERY
IMPORTANT RIVER BODIES THAT THE
QUAN A RIVER. AND THE NEW RIVER
ALONG CALIFORNIA AND THE ALAMO
RIVERS WELL- ONE OF THE
CONDITIONS- THAT WE CURRENTLY
FACE AS THAT SO OFTEN TIMES-
DURING. HI OF. RAINFALL AND
SOMETIMES LOW RAINFALL WE GET A
LOT OF CONTAMINATION COMING IN.
THROUGH THESE RIVERS ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CONTAMINANTS IS ACTUALLY
USED TIRES CALIFORNIA HAS A
PROGRAM TO RECYCLE USED TIRES.
OFTENTIMES WHEN WE SELL THOSE
USED TIRES ARE OFTENTIMES PEOPLE
SELL UP BY THOSE TIRES AND
EXPORTING TO MEXICO FOR RE USE
WHEN THERE THE ACTOR ABSOLUTE
END OF LIFE SO THEY HAVE. THEY
POSE- ARE A THREAT AND A DANGER
TO THOSE MOTORISTS IN- IN SOUTH
OF THE BORDER. AND THEY ALSO-
END UP CONTAMINATING THE
ENVIRONMENT I'M WORKING WITH THE
GOVERNMENT OF BUCKET CALIFORNIA
ON THIS BILL WHICH WILL
INSTITUTE THEIR OWN PROGRAMS TO
AS ARE CERTAIN. YEAH YES SORRY
GO AHEAD CANCEL I BELIEVE WE'RE
ON S. B. ELEVEN OH FIVE I'M
SORRY MY- YEAH. I'M SORRY MAN
THE WRONG COMMITTEE HERE. I'M
SORRY OKAY. ELEVEN OH FIVE YEAH.
GREAT THANK YOU WELL THIS- THIS
IS THE ELEVEN OH FIVE IS THE-
REGIONAL EQUITABLE ENVIRONMENT
FROM THE HOUSING AGENCY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SORRY ABOUT THAT I
AM PRESENTING A TWO BILLS AT THE
SAME TIME TO DIFFERENT
COMMITTEES. BUT- THIS IS A BILL
THAT I'M WORKING ON WITH THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN VARIOUS
STAKEHOLDERS IN SAN DIEGO ON OF
COURSE ALSO WITH SANDAG SENDEK
IS CONCERNED IT GOES ASSOCIATION
OF GOVERNMENT SO OF PLANNING
AGENCY THAT HELPS COORDINATE-
WITH ALL THE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
DOWN THERE TODAY GO ON
TRANSPORTATION. ON OUR COMMUNITY
PLANNING ISSUES ENVIRONMENTAL
ISSUES. END OF THIS YEAR WERE
WERE WORKING. TO ADOPT THE
PROGRAM THAT HAS BEEN SIMILARLY
PROPOSED IN LOS ANGELES AND
ADOPTED IN THE SAN FRANCISCO
AREA WHICH WILL HELP TO-
INTEGRATES HOUSING CONSTRUCTION
INTO- SOME OF THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES SO- YOU KNOW IN
SAN DIEGO LIKE MANY OTHER PLACES
SAN DIEGO HAS FAILED TO MEET ITS
ANNUAL HOUSING PRODUCTION GOALS
TO PRODUCE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND OTHER HOUSING TO ADDRESS
CALIFORNIA'S NEEDS. ACCORDING TO
A RECENT HOUSING NEEDS
ALLOCATION ASSESSMENT THE CENTER
REGION IS FACING A HOUSING
SHORTAGE OF ABOUT NINETY
THOUSAND UNITS AND REQUIRES
ENOUGH ANOTHER NINETY THOUSAND
HOMES BUT TWENTY THIRTY JUST TO
KEEP UP WITH POPULATION GROWTH.
THE SHORTAGE HAS INCREASED
RENTAL AND HOME PRICES DRIVING
FOLKS UP FURTHER FURTHER AWAY
FROM NOT ONLY URBAN CENTERS BUT
WHERE THEY WORK AND WHERE
THEY'RE EMPLOYED. AND WE NEED TO
DO BETTER JOBS AND CALIFORNIA OF
CITING PEOPLE CLOSER TO WHERE
THEY WORK SO THAT WE CAN- YOU
KNOW- RELY LESS ON ON ENERGY AND
PROGRAM AND OTHER PRODUCTS TO
GET PEOPLE TO WHERE THEY NEED TO
BE TO WORK- UP. THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE. A IN AN AGENCY THAT WILL
HELP COORDINATE WITH CITIES AND
HELP ATTRACT FUNDING AND HELP
PRODUCE HOUSING- TO HELP MEET
THE NEEDS OF SAN DIEGO COUNTY-
THE NEW ASSOCIATION OF
GOVERNMENTS WITH SERVICE YOU'RE
AUTHORIZING ENTITY FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THE AT THIS AGENCY
SINCE THE IT'S ALREADY DOING A
JOB IN IN- REGIONAL DECISION
MAKING. A IN IN OTHER AREAS FOR
SAN DIEGO SO THIS WOULD HELP-
STREAMLINED INTEGRATION OF
HOUSING AND HELP IT- TO PLANET
LONG WITH OUR ROADS AND HIGHWAYS
I'VE ACCEPTED THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT SOME
CLARIFICATION TO HOW THE AGENCY
FUNCTIONS BEFORE VOTERS APPROVED
A REVENUE TOOL. AND SOME CHANGES
TO THE FEES AND TAXES TO LINE UP
THE LEGISLATION FOR BOTH SAN
DIEGO SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS
ANGELES OF MAKES IT CLOSER TO
THOSE BILLS. AS WELL AND- I HAVE
A WITNESS TODAY SENT TO COUNTY
SUPERVISORS HER LAWSUIT REAM.
BEISER YOU WISH TO TESTIFY.
BILLION ELEVEN AND YET THANK YOU
. I DID. TRY TO WRITE FOR A LOFT
AND REMARRIAGE THANK YOU SO MUCH
OF THE CHAIR AND THE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE AS IN A WAY SO
MENTIONED WE HAVE A HUGE HOUSING
SHORTFALL IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY
EVEN THOUGH WE'RE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO CREATE MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WE'RE STILL
ONLY BUILDING ENOUGH TO MEET
TÍNH PERCENT OF THE NEED AMONG
WORKING MIDDLE CLASS FAMILIES.
WHEN I TALK TO LOCAL STAKEHOLDER
ACROSS OUR REGION WE ALL
RECOGNIZE THAT WE'RE NEVER GOING
TO MEET THE SHORTFALL. GIVEN OUR
CURRENT LEVEL OF RESOURCES AND
ARE FRAGMENTED HOUSING APPROACH.
WE NEED A REGIONAL STRATEGY TO
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM. AND THE SAN
DIEGO REGIONAL EQUITABLE
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY HOUSING
AGENCY IS THE ONE SOLUTION THAT
HAS BEEN CONSISTENTLY REYES. AND
ALL MY MEETINGS WITH
CONSTITUENTS OTHER STAKEHOLDERS.
IMPACTED INDIVIDUALS AND ELECTED
OFFICIALS. SHE IS THE LINCHPIN
TO JUMP STARTING THE
CONSTRUCTION OF EQUITABLE AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY HOUSING
ACROSS OUR REGION. THAT'S WHY I
CREATED AND NOT SHARE AND THAT
REGIONAL I COULD HAVE BEEN. A
LONG.MAYOR TODD GLORIA RICHARD
DEVISED. IF YOU WERE CALLING
WE'VE GOT SEEN EITHER MODERATOR. IF IN TWO HOURS CREDIT A LOT.
FOR GOING AFTER GETTING SOME
BELIEVE WE ARE ARE. WHERE DOES
PLEASE MEET YOUR LINE. THANK YOU
. OKAY THANK YOU I'LL CONTINUE
PART ABOUT THAT I'M IS WHY OKAY
THANK YOU I KNOW HOW HAVE THIS
IS I THIS IS WHY AND NOW SHE SAN
DIEGO REGIONAL ACTOR HOUSING
SECTOR ALONG SAN DIEGO MAY TODD
. WHO SERVED AS THE VICE CHAIR
TO FORMALISE THE PROCESS OF
DEVELOPING AND REFINING THIS
PROPOSAL. THE SANDBAGS AND- IS
COMPRISED OF LOCAL OFFICIALS
FROM ACROSS OUR REGION. IN
ADDITION TO THIS FORMAL
SUBCOMMITTEE WITH BOTH CONVENE A
WORKING GROUP OR TASK FORCE THE
FORTY LOCAL STAKEHOLDERS. FROM A
WIDE VARIETY OF SECTORS AND
PERCEPTIVE. AND WE'VE BEEN
WORKING HARD TOGETHER TO INFORM
AND GUIDE OUR PROCESS THROUGH
DIVERSE INPUT. STAKEHOLDERS
INCLUDE. SUCH AS SENEGAL HOUSING
FEDERATION. SAN DIEGO BUILDING
AND CONSTRUCTION TRADES AND. THE
SAN DIEGO REGIONAL CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE. YOU SHOULD HAVE
RECEIVED A NUMBER OF THE GUYS
LET OF SUPPORT FROM THE VERY
GROUPS I TALKED FORCE MEMBERS I
SUPPORT OF THIS PROPOSAL. I
SHOULD NOTE THAT OUR APPROACH IS
NOT IDENTICAL TO THE PROCESS I
AM IN THE BAY AREA ALRIGHT LA
ALLUDED CERTAINLY MODELED ON
THOSE INITIATIVES. WE ARE
WORKING HARD WITH LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS TO DEVELOP GUIDING
PRINCIPLE CRITERIA AND
PRIORITIES THEY REALLY REFLECT
THE VALUES AND VISION OF SAN
DIEGANS. THESE INCLUDE
AFFORDABILITY SUSTAINABILITY
LIVABILITY EQUITY AND QUALITY
JOB. I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE PROPOSAL AND
THE BILL IN FRONT OF YOU TODAY I
VERY MUCH THINK THE COMMITTEE
FOR CONSIDERING THE SPELL AND I
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH CENTER WEST SO I'M SUPPORT
NETWORK. THANK YOU. YOU. DO WE
HAVE ANY OPPOSITION. SUPPORT
FURTHER SUPPORT HERE. FURTHER
SUPPORT IN Q. LADIES GENTLEMEN
ON THE PHONE LINE IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO EXPRESS SUPPORT- PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO-
MISTER CHAIR. COULD I JUST.
GENERATED S. B. ONE ONE ZERO
FIVE WE ARE. YES YES ELEVEN
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ELEVEN OH
FIVE EIGHT. SO IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF S. B.
ELEVEN OH FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND WE WILL GO
TO ONLINE SEVENTY EIGHT YOU ARE
OPEN. GOOD MORNING CAROL ROSS ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY IT'S A LOT OF
EACH IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. MODERATOR ANY OTHERS
THANK YOU YES ONE MOMENT WITH
THE OPERATOR AND WE WILL GO TO
LINE SIXTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
SIXTY YOU ARE OPEN. WELL LIKE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD
ANYBODY ELSE PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO POINT SEVENTY NINE YOUR
OPEN. HI MY NAME IS CAMILA
BERMAN MANAGING DIRECTOR FOR THE
SAN DIEGO AND KOKANEE BUT
HELPFUL AND I'M SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND WORKING FAMILIES WE
REPRESENT IN THE REGION. WHAT
PART OF A DIVERSE. GROUP THAT IS
WORKING WITH ANOTHER HUESO AND
THE BY THE LEFT IN RECENT
DEVELOPMENTS. COBALT RECOGNIZE
THE NEED TO BUILD MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BEEN DIEGO
THE ONLY BUILDING ENOUGH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BOTH THE
SPENT OF THE DEMAND- I FEEL
ABOUT FIVE OF THEM- HOUSING
SECTOR WILL CREATE THOUSANDS OF
GOOD PAYING JOBS THE WORKING
FAMILIES PARTY AGAIN AND- OUR
LOCAL COM AT A COMPANY. WILL
ALSO PROVIDE HOUSING FOR WORKING
CLASS FAMILIES WHO ARE
STRUGGLING AS A AT THE COST OF
LIVING CONTINUES TO RISE. WE
BELIEVE BACK THERE WAS A BIG
STEP TOWARDS GETTING A BIBLE
PLEASED THAT WOULD BEGIN TO
ADDRESS EVERYTHING HOUSING
CRISIS AND FTER WORK THANK YOU
SO. MUCH FOR YOUR TIME ON A BOOK
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. AND NEXT WILL
TO OPEN LINES AGAINST GO AHEAD
SIXTY. YEAH MY NAME ERIC MEYER
AND- RECORD HOUSE IT SAID HIGH
NEED OF CORP AND THE CITY OF
SANTA. SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF FEEL
OF OH FIVE. AT THE BASED
NONPROFIT HE'S THE AND
AFFORDABLE HOUSING DEVELOPER
OWNER AND OPERATOR WORKING IN AN
IMMIGRANT REFUGEE COMMUNITY OF
COLOR WE HAVE UNIQUE
UNDERSTANDING OF THE REALITY OF
OUR HOUSING AFFORDABILITY
CHALLENGES. OFF LIVING HAS
SURGED IN CALIFORNIA LED BY
HOUSING COST INCREASES OF OVER
20% RANSOM 25% IN HOME PRICES IN
THE LAST TWELVE MONTHS ALONE.
MEETING WITH THE REAR RENT
BURDEN ECONOMIC DISLOCATION
RISING EVICTIONS AND INCREASING
THAT INCIDENTS OF HOMELESSNESS.
OUR OUR FORMAL HOUSE RESPOND
CONTINUES THE- OVER THE PAST
DECADE WITH ONLY BUILT 12% OF
THE AFFORDABLE. HOUSING THAT OUR
REGION NEEDS HOUSING IS A
REGIONAL ISSUE THE UNDERSUPPLY
OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING IS NOT
LIMITED TO CERTAIN METRO AREAS.
OUR CURRENT PIECEMEAL APPROACH
IS NOT WORKING WE NEED A
REGIONAL BODY AND INCREASED
RESOURCES SB ELEVEN OH FIVE IS
THE NECESSARY TOOL FOR OUR
REGION'S CONSTRUCT AND PRESERVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. I ASK FOR
YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIR NOBODY ELSE'S
QUEUED UP. LET ME ASK A QUESTION
AT COULD YOU THIS LAST WITNESS.
WHY DO WE NEED ANOTHER LOCAL
HOUSING AGENCY CAN WE NOT DEAL
WITH WHAT WE'VE ALREADY GOT IN
PLACE. IN THE COUNTY. LUNCH IF
THE HOUSING AS I'M SURE ALL OF
YOUR WHERE IT IS NOT A LOCAL
ISSUE THERE ARE LOTS OF
DECISIONS BUT IT'S A REGIONAL
ISSUE WE HAVE MULTIPLE
JURISDICTIONS TRYING TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE- LOCALLY. AND IT WOULD
BE MUCH MORE EFFICIENT AND WE
WOULD HAVE MUCH GREATER ABILITY
TO ATTRACT ADDITIONAL RESOURCES
OF WITH A REGIONAL AND TO TAKE.
DOES NOT DO DID DOES THAT DOES
NOT THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY THAT OUR THE
ABILITY TO FORM A JPA. MISTER
CHAIRMAN THE ECONOMIC TRICK
QUESTIONS PLEASE AND I CAN DO
THAT IN MY CLOSING IF YOU FIVE
FIVE I CAN ANSWER THAT CENTER
AWAY SO WE'LL DO THAT. THE
CLOSER. MOST OF THE DRUGS YOU
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS. NO BUT I
WOULD MOVE THE BILL BILL IS
MOVED BY SENATOR GARAGE SO. YEP
WE'LL GET TO THE OPPOSITION. DO
WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION HERE
PRESENT. IN THE HEARING ROOM.
MODERATOR ANY OPPOSITION IN Q.
HE WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION THAT SKEWS ME SB
ELEVEN OH FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
WHEN FALL BY ZERO. MISTER CHAIR
. THERE'S NOBODY QUEUEING UP AT
THIS TIME. HEARING NONE THEN
SENATE HUESO THANK YOU MISTER
AND THOUGHT OF YOU KNOW SEND YOU
COUNTY IS- COUNTY WITH UP I
THINK IT'S APPROXIMATELY
EIGHTEEN CITIES IF MY
RECOLLECTION SERVES ME WELL AND
REMEMBER MY VERY SMALL SOME OF-
ARE LOCATED IN DIFFERENT PARTS
OF THE COUNTY AND SO OFTEN TIMES
YOU HAVE SOME CITIES THAT ARE
DOING THEIR FAIR SHARE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WHILE OTHERS
ARE NOT. AND SOME CITIES ARE
VERY LARGE EMPLOYMENT CENTERS
WHILE OTHERS ARE NOT AND THAT
OFTEN CREATES AN IMBALANCE THAT
THAT CREATES GRIDLOCK AND
TRAFFIC AND SO WHEN WE BUILD
HIGHWAYS AND SAID HE WILL COUNTY
IT'S KIND OF A PROCESS BY WHICH
WE WORK WITH THE CALTRANS SANDAG
AND THE LOCAL CITIES EACH CITY
GETS AN ALLOCATION OF FOR BASED
ON THEIR NEEDS. AND SO I THINK
THE IDEA BEHIND OUR PLANNING
EFFORT IS YOU WANT TO. UP A-
TARGET BUILDING HOUSING MOSTLY
WHERE YOU NEED IT. AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS ARE TRYING TO DO
THAT AND SO ONE CENTRAL AGENCY
CAN OFTENTIMES TO A BETTER JOB
AT. A DRAWING DOWN FEDERAL AND
STATE FUNDS AND THEY CAN HELP
WORK WITH CITIES TO HELP THEM
MEET. THEIR THEIR NEEDS BUT IT'S
ALSO GOING TO BE DONE BASED ON
ON ON DEMAND. AND I THINK THAT'S
OF THAT MODEL ESPECIALLY FOR
SENEGAL COUNTY IS VERY VERY
pTHE SUPERVISOR SAID WE'VE
ACTUALLY BEEN TALKING ABOUT THIS
FOR MANY YEARS NOW. HOW DO HOW
DO PLAN FOR HOW A HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT STATE WITHOUT.
WITHOUT NECESSARILY. CREATING
SPRAWL SPRAWL- WILL- BASICALLY
TOKO TAKEOVER ARE SMALL FARMS IN
OUR AGRICULTURAL AREAS I THINK
IN SAN DIEGO WE DON'T WANT THAT
WE WANT TO WE WANT TO DO MORE
INFILL WE WANT TO CITE. A
HOUSING NEXT TO MASS TRANSIT AND
WIND UP A COMPANY WIDE PLANNING
AGENCY CAN REALLY HIGHLIGHT THE
BEST PLACES TO DO THAT IN THE
MOST EFFICIENT COST EFFICIENT
WAYS TO DO THAT. AND THE MOST
EFFECTIVE WAY TO GET PEOPLE TO
WHERE THEY NEED TO BE AND LIVE
WHERE THEY CAN. UP THE
HEALTHIEST- THAT JUST MAKES
SENSE THAT YOU THROUGH IT DO IT
TO ONE CENTRAL. AGENCY I WANT TO
REMIND- THE COMMITTEE AND THE
PUBLIC THAT THIS IS A SANDY WILL
COUNTY SPECIFIC BILL. AND IT HAS
THE SUPPORT OF MANY OF COUNTY
LEADERS AND SENDEK LEADERS- WITH
THE SUPPORT LIST IS GROWING.
EVERY SINGLEDAY RECENTLY WEEK
WE GOT THE SUPPORT OF SENATE THE
CITY OF SAN DIEGO THE CITY'S
SOLANA BEACH. THE CITY OF LA
MESA THE CITY OF NATIONAL CITY.
THE CITY OF IMPERIAL BEACH WE
GOT A LETTER FROM- COUNCIL MET-
PREZ A COUNCIL MEMBER A STEVE BY
THE YEAR RECENTLY AND OTHER
LETTERS ARE COMING IN FROM OTHER
LEADERS. THEY THEY AGREE. THAT
THIS IS. AND SEND IT WILL AND IT
WOULD BE A FURTHER TOOL THAT
WOULD NOT NECESSARILY COST.
CITIES OR TAXPAYERS OR ANYONE
ELSE ADDITIONAL FUNDS. BUT IT
WOULD BE EFFECTIVE. IN HELPING
TO COORDINATE THE CREATION
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND BRING IN
THE MONEY NECESSARY TO DO IT.
ALL RIGHT DO WE HAVE ANY ANY.
FURTHER CLOSING THEN I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH OF
A- MOTION IT'S PAST SEVEN
MOROCCO. HELLO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND WE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE
ON APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS
CAPITO. NIELSEN HI NIELSEN HI
DORADO DORADO I HERTZBERG.
WIENER. TWO ZERO. TWO ZERO PUT
THE BILL ON CALL THANK YOU
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IN
CENTREBOARD JUST.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR GOOD
MORNING WHILE THIS IS AN
EVENTFUL WEEK THANKS PRETTY
AMAZING. ALL RIGHT. GOOD MORNING
OUR MEMBERS I WANT TO START BY
THANKING THE CHAIR IN THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR WORKING WITH
ME AND MY STAFF TO IMPROVE THE
BILL IN THE LAST FEW WEEKS
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN SEVENTY
FOUR SIX TO PROVIDE A STATE
INCOME TAX DEDUCTION FOR
CONTRIBUTIONS TO TUITION SAVINGS
PROGRAMS KNOWN AS SCHOLARS SHARE
FIVE TWO NINE ACCOUNTS QUALIFY
TAXPAYERS. FIVE TWO NINE OR FIVE
TWO NINES ARE ACCOUNT VEHICLES
THAT ALLOW INVESTMENTS TO GROW
TAX FREE AND CAN ONLY BE USED
FOR HIGHER EDUCATION PURPOSES
ALTHOUGH CONTRIBUTIONS ARE NOT
CURRENTLY DEDUCTIBLE. EARNINGS
IN A FIVE TO NINE PLAN GROW TAX
FREE AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND
ARE NOT TAXED WHEN THE MONEY IS
USED TO PAY FOR QUALIFIED
COLLEGE EXPENSES. IN EFFORT TO
INCENTIVIZE THIS INVESTMENT IN
HIGHER EDUCATION OVER THIRTY
STATES THIRTY. OFFER FULL OR
PARTIAL TAX DEDUCTION OR CREDIT
CALIFORNIA REMAINS A STATE THAT
DOES NOT. THIS LEGISLATIVE
PROPOSAL WAS PREVIOUSLY
INTRODUCED AB TWO ELEVEN IN
TWENTY NINETEEN BY THEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IAN CALDERON THE MEASURE
RECEIVED WIDE BIPARTISAN
SUPPORT. HOWEVER THE MEASURE WAS
VETOED DUE TO BUDGET CONSTRAINTS
. GIVEN THE RECORD SURPLUS
REVENUE HOWEVER NOW IS THE TIME
TO ENCOURAGE TAXPAYERS TO MAKE
INVESTMENTS IN HIGHER EDUCATION
. THE COST OF HIGHER EDUCATION
CONTINUES TO SKYROCKET AS THE
ANALYSIS PROPERLY NOTES ALLOWING
ELIGIBLE TAXPAYERS THIS TAX
DEDUCTION WILL INCREASE
AFFORDABILITY AND ACCESS TO
HIGHER EDUCATION. IN A ISSUE I
THINK WE CAN ALL AGREE UPON. SO
TODAY I HAVE WITH ME CASEY
O'CONNOR ON BEHALF OF THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE TO PROVIDE
SOME MORE INFORMATION ON THIS
VALUABLE PROGRAM WITH THE
BLESSINGS OF THE VICE CHAIR.
PLEASE THANK YOU AND GOOD
MORNING- MISTER TERRY MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I AM CASEY
O'CONNOR LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR STATE TREASURER FIONA MA WHO
ALSO SERVES AS THE CHAIR OF THE
SCHOLARS YOUR INVESTMENT BOARD
UNDER THE AUSPICES OF THE
TREASURER'S OFFICE. WE WERE
PROUD TO SUPPORT AB TWO ELEVEN
WE'RE VERY PROUD TO SUPPORT SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR TODAY ONE
OF THE GREATEST HURDLES FAMILIES
FACE WHEN CONTEMPLATING WHETHER
TO PURSUE A POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION. IS THE SKYROCKETING
COST OF ATTENDING COLLEGE WHICH
IS GROWING AT A RATE OF TWO TO
THREE TIMES THE RATE OF
INFLATION. IT'S VERY CONCERNING
THAT STUDENT LOAN DEBT AND THE
U. S. HAS NOW TOPPED ONE POINT
SEVEN TRILLION DOLLARS IT HAS
SURPASSED AUTOMOBILE LOANS AND
CREDIT CARDS THE NUMBER ONE
SOURCE OF PERSONAL DATA SIDE OF
MORTGAGES. WITH REGARD TO
STUDENT LOAN DEBT A RECENT STUDY
FOUND THAT 40% MILLENNIAL
HOUSEHOLDS AGE TWENTY EIGHT TO
THIRTY EIGHT. HAVE STUDENT LOAN
DEBT AMOUNTED TO MORE THAN 40%
OF THEIR INCOME. FROM A STATE
PERSPECTIVE CALIFORNIA HAS THE
HIGHEST NUMBER OF BORROWERS
CONTRIBUTING TO THAT ONE POINT
SEVEN TRILLION WITH THREE POINT
EIGHT MILLION BORROWERS IN OUR
STATE. AND THE AVERAGE STUDENT
LOAN DEBT FOR CALIFORNIANS TO
GRADUATE IN TWENTY TWENTY IS
TWENTY ONE THOUSAND A HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS PER STUDENT.
YET DESPITE THESE ALARMING
TRENDS ONLY 56% OF FAMILIES WITH
CHILDREN UNDER THE AGE OF
EIGHTEEN ARE SAVING FOR COLLEGE
OF THAT 56% ONLY 30% ARE USING
QUALIFY FIVE TWO NINE. TAX
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS. THE PASSAGE
OF SB THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR
WOULD LEAD TO A GROWTH IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOLARS SHARE FIVE
TO NINE PLAN. AND WOULD RESULT
IN INCREASED PLAN ASSETS
ALLOWING FOR A WIDE RANGE IN IN
STATE BENEFITS. SUCH AS
REDUCTIONS TO ALREADY LOW FEES
FOR OUR PARTICIPANTS OR
EXPANSION OF PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES DESIGNED TO ASSIST
UNDERSERVED. POPULATIONS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. LIKE OUR
FIVE TWO NINE MATCHING GRANT
PROGRAM WHICH OFFERS ELIGIBLE
FAMILIES EARNING SEVENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR LESS. A
DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR MATCH UP TO
TWO HUNDRED DOLLARS AND A BONUS
OF TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS. FOR
ESTABLISHING AUTOMATIC
CONTRIBUTION PLAN. NATIONALLY
THIRTY FOUR STATES AND
WASHINGTON DC HAVE FULL OR
PARTIAL TAX DEDUCTIONS WELL
CALIFORNIA USUALLY PRIDES ITSELF
ON BEING A LEADER IN THE SPACES.
WE ARE ONE OF ONLY STATES ONE OF
ONLY SEVEN STATES WITH THE TECH
WITH NO TAX INCENTIVE. DESPITE
INCOME TAX WERE ON PAR WITH
KENTUCKY NORTH CAROLINA DELAWARE
MAINE MASSACHUSETTS AND HAWAII.
WITHOUT ANY IN STATE TAX
INCENTIVE MANY CALIFORNIANS ARE
OPTING TO INVEST. AN ESTIMATED
TWENTY FOUR BILLION IN OUT OF
STATE FIVE TO NINE PLANS.
PRIMARILY THOSE WITH HIGHER
FEES. OFFERED THROUGH A
FINANCIAL ADVISER RATHER THAN
INVESTING IN THE LOW CLASS
SCHOLARSHIP FIVE TO NINE PLAN.
ADMINISTERED BY THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. SO WE UNDERSTAND WE
DID A STUDY ON THIS BACK WHEN WE
DID THE BILL AND I CAN TELL YOU
THAT WE HAVE FOUND THAT
APPROXIMATELY NINETY FIVE
THOUSAND. NEW ACCOUNTS WOULD BE
OPENED UNDER THIS MEASURE SIXTY
SIX THOUSAND ACCOUNTS WILL BE
ROLLED OVER FROM OUT OF STATE
PLANS AND TWENTY NINE THOUSAND
NEW ACCOUNTS WOULD OPEN. FOR
STUDENTS IN CALIFORNIA SO. I
UNDERSTAND THAT I'M RUNNING OUT
OF TIME SO I WILL WRAP IT UP SB
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT MEASURE. WE
KNOW THAT WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
IS HUGE HERE AND ANOTHER BENEFIT
WOULD BE A TAX DEDUCTION WOULD
REACH MILLIONS OF PEOPLE FOR
THOSE EXCEED SEEKING WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT. BECAUSE CAREER
PATHS CAN BE ITERATIVE SO CAN WE
VERY MUCH WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR AS WELL AS THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR HELP WITH THIS
BILL. RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE AND IF ANYONE HAS TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS THE M. VETOES THE
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF OUR SCHOLARS
YOUR INVESTMENT BOARD HE'S HERE
IF THERE'S ANY PROGRAM. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANY QUESTIONS OF
THEM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
DO WE HAVE ANY IN Q. MODERATOR
DO YOU HAVE ANY SUPPORT IN Q. IF
YOU LIKE TO TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO ONE FILED BY
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE MOMENT
MISTER CHAIR. AND NOBODY IS
QUEUING UP. GOOD WE HAVE IN THE
IN OPPOSITION HERE PRESS.
MODERATOR ANY OPPOSITION IN Q.
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO. AND
NOBODY IS GOING UP THE STRUCTURE
NINE NINE WOULD YOU LIKE TO GIVE
US A CLOSE SHARE ON. SILENCE
SENATORS HELLO. I HAVE A
QUESTION- AS THERE IS THERE IS A
COMMENT- A AND WE KNOW THIS TO
BE FACT IS THAT PEOPLE ARE
HAVING A HARD TIME RIGHT NOW.
JUST PAYING FOR THE BASICS AND
SO HOW MUCH DISPOSABLE INCOME IS
REALLY. AT THEIR YOU KNOW-
AVAILABLE TO THEM TO DO THIS-
AND MY CONCERN IS THAT OBVIOUSLY
THE LOWER THE INCOME LEVEL THE
LESS LIKELY THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE DISPOSABLE INCOME AND HERE
WE ARE OFFERING A TAX BREAK. TO
THOSE WHO ARE AT THE HIGHER
LEVEL SO- HOW DO YOU. SOMETHING
ABOUT THE NUMBER OF ACCOUNTS
THAT YOU EXPECT THAT COULD BE
OPENED BY IT BUT AGAIN IT.
WITHOUT HAVING- A LOT OF FACTS
IN FRONT OF ME. I'M JUST
CONCERNED THAT WE'RE GOING TO BE
OFFERING ANOTHER TAX BREAK TO
THE HIGHER INCOME KNOWING THAT
LOWER INCOME JUST DON'T HAVE THE
MONEY TO SOCK AWAY IS A GREAT
PROGRAM OUR FAMILY PARTICIPATES
IN THAT HAVE PARTICIPATED FOR
MANY YEARS. BUT I JUST WHAT
REALLY MATTERS IS DO THEY HAVE
THE MONEY TO INVEST THAT'S THE
REAL QUESTION AND DINNER BEFORE
ME TURN IT OVER TO YOU- THIS IS
YOUR CONNOR- I COME I'M- A
COUNCIL FAMILY VEGGIE CATERS I
MYSELF AS AN EDUCATOR FOR OVER A
DECADE. ALSUP TWO LITTLE BOYS
AND THE COST OF EDUCATION- WE
HAVE SEEN. JUST ABSOLUTELY
SKYROCKET YOUR POINT IS VERY
WELL FOUNDED CENTER- THAT THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO ALLOW
FAMILIES- IN. A SALARY IN INCOME
RANGE THAT CAN ACCOUNT FOR
EVERYONE OF FROM ONE HUNDRED
FROM ZERO TO ONE HUNDRED AND
THEN OF COURSE THE MARRIED.
HOUSEHOLD UP TO TWO HUNDRED. IN
A PERFECT WORLD WE'LL BE MAKING
EVEN MORE INVESTMENTS IN OUR
PELL GRANTS AND OUR OUR STATE
SUPPORT SYSTEMS FOR. FOR
YOUNGSTERS TO GO TO COLLEGE I
THINK I'VE SUPPORTED- MOST EVERY
SINGLE BUDGET REQUEST BY C.
ISSUE FOR YOU- OR- TO SOME
EXTENT UC'S AS THE RELEVANT- FOR
THAT VERY PURPOSE. THIS IS PART
OF THE CALIFORNIANS PARTY
AMERICAN EXPERIENCE THAT WE
EDUCATE YOUNGSTERS IRRESPECTIVE
OF THEIR ABILITY- TO PAY AT THAT
THAT IS FALLING SHORT IN MANY
RESPECTS SO. I ACTUALLY
EMPATHIZE- BUT I THINK IT'S A
MATTER OF POLICY IN A MATTER OF
LEGISLATION. THOSE ISSUES ARE
PROBABLY BEST DEALT WITH ON A
NEEDS BASED ASSESSMENT THROUGH
THE CAL STATE FARM- GRANT
PROGRAMS AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE GRANT PROGRAMS AS WELL AS
FEDERAL. BUT I AM ALWAYS
SUPPORTIVE OF THOSE AS WELL. AND
YET AGAIN YOU THE SAN NOTED THE
IS AN CAP IN THE BILL'S FOLK ARE
MAKING FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS ARE WEALTHIER FOLKS
POTENTIALLY WON'T GET THIS TAX
INCENTIVE ALSO I WOULD NOTE THAT
A LOT OF THEM HAVE FOUR OH ONE
K.'S ARE SAVING OUTSIDE OF FIVE
TO NINE PLANS. WE FOUND FIVE TO
NINE PLANS ARE PRIMARILY BEING
USED BY THE MIDDLE INCOME OR
TRYING TO FACILITATE LOWER
INCOME INDIVIDUALS ENTERING THE
FOLD AS WELL AS A REFERENCE MORE
ACCOUNT OWNERS IN CALIFORNIA WE
CAN GROW OUR MATCHING GRANT
PROGRAM IS TO SERVE THOSE FOLKS
THAT MAKE SEVENTY FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS. OR LESS BYE WE MATCH
THEM DOLLAR FOR DOLLAR WE CAN
GROW THAT PROGRAM WITH MORE
MONEY COMING INTO THE COFFERS
FOR OUR FIVE TO NINETEEN GROW
OUR STATE PROGRAMS. BUT I ALSO
WANT TO NOTE- JUST MEMBER NATION
WE FOUND THAT IT'S A COMMON
MISCONCEPTION THAT THESE ARE
USED BY HIGH INCOME HOUSEHOLDS.
THE NORMAL- THE AVERAGE ACCOUNT
BALANCE IS TWELVE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED SEVENTY SIX DOLLARS SO
THAT REALLY GROWS FROM PEOPLE
PUTTING A FEW HUNDRED ASIDE WHEN
THEY CAN'T MAYBE A THOUSAND. BUT
WE DO KNOW THAT MIDDLE AMERICA
MIDDLE INCOME FAMILIES WERE HIT
REALLY HARD THE PANDEMIC AND ARE
NOT A LOT FOR THEM TO UTILIZE
RIGHT NOW AS WELL. AND ALSO
BASED ON A TWENTY FOURTEEN
SURVEY WE CONDUCTED BY THE
INDUSTRY RESEARCH PROVIDED BY
STRATEGIC INSIGHT. CSF DID
PROVIDE US MORE INFORMATION- AND
WE FOUND DATA FROM ITS
MEMBERSHIP SHOWING 70% OF THE
MORE THAN TWELVE POINT SIX
MILLION FIVE TO NINE PLAN
ACCOUNT HOLDERS NATIONWIDE HAVE
INCOMES UNDER A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS. SO THAT IS
UNDER THE CAP THAT SET IN THIS
BILL AND THAT'S GENERALLY WHO WE
FIND UTILIZING THIS PROGRAM. SO
WHILE WE UNDERSTAND THAT THERE
ARE SOME MISCONCEPTIONS OUT
THERE THIS REALLY IS GEARED
TOWARD HELPING OUR FAMILY SAFE
AND IF WE CAN INCENTIVIZE THEM
TO PUT TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS A
HUNDRED DOLLARS A THOUSAND
DOLLARS SIDE- IT'S REALLY TO
GROW THOSE STUDENTS AND THAT'S
WHAT WE'RE FOCUSED ON. BUT WE'RE
ALWAYS WILLING TO CONTINUE THESE
QUESTIONS AS DIALOGUE THE
TREASURES VERY VERY
UNDERSTANDING OF IT SO- I HOPE
THAT IS HELPFUL I CAN SEND. YOUR
OFFICE ALL THE STATE AS WELL.
THE PHONE UP. UNDER THAT. YEAH
AND JUST IT. THE I'M SORRY THAT
THE- INFORMATION THAT YOU JUST
GAVE ME DOESN'T REALLY ADDRESS.
THOSE THAT ARE IN THE- IN THE
LOWER INCOME BRACKETS. IN OTHER
WORDS WHEN YOU SAY THAT THAT WAS
A NATIONWIDE THERE BUT WE'RE A
HUNDRED UNDER A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND. YEAH AND COMES UNDER
HUNDRED TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND. THAT
DOESN'T TELL ME HOW MANY ARE IN
THE LOWER INCOME. THAT JUST SAYS
THEY'RE UNDER HIGH FIFTY
THOUSAND WHICH THEY COULD BE A
FIRE. THAT'S MY WHOLE POINT IS
WE'RE GIVING UP A TAX BREAK
AGAIN. YOU KNOW TWO BILLS THAT
APPEARED TO BE AT THE HIGHER END
I DON'T MEAN HIGHER LIKE IN THE
MILLIONS BUT STILL IN THE HIGHER
IT. WENT AND THAT'S MY WHOLE
POINT. FOR TAKING. OKAY ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE FAMILY
HERE. OKAY THEN I WILL I JUST
CONCLUDE THAT THE SENATE BILL
THIRTEEN SEVENTY FOUR QUITE
SIMPLY PROVIDES A TAX INCENTIVE
OF FOREIGN INVESTMENTS TO A FIVE
TWO NINE SCHOLARSHIP PROGRAM
WELL I'LL BY ALLOWING FOR THIS
DEDUCTION TO QUALIFY TAXPAYERS
SICK LAST THREE RIVALS- EMOTION MOVED BY THEN THE WINNER. OKAY
KALRA THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT
FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS CAPITO. NIELSEN AYE
NIELSEN AYE DRAWS SO. HERTZBERG
WIENER RIGHT WIENER HI TWO ZERO
TWO ZERO LINK OF YOUR BILL ON
CALL. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT WE
HAVE A- SENATE AND SALAS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT THE
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
WHICH WILL ADVANCE EQUITY
MEASURES IN THE CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL PROGRAMS AND I WOULD LIKE TO
THANK THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR
THEIR DILIGENT WORK ON THE BILL
AND ACCEPT THE TECHNICAL
AMENDMENTS ON PAGE FIVE OF THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS CURRENTLY
HIGHER INCOME HOUSEHOLDS ARE FAR
MORE LIKELY TO OWN ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES THAN LOWER INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS OF COLOR AND
IRONICALLY THIS IS ESPECIALLY
TRUE IN EMISSIONS OVERBURDENED
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE THE MOST
NEED. ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES THE
CLEAN CARS FOR ALL PROGRAM IS
SPECIFICALLY INTENDED TO ADDRESS
THE EXISTING INEQUITY IN ACCESS
TO CLEAN ZERO EMISSION AND
HYBRID VEHICLES OVER THE LAST
SIX YEARS CLEAN CARS FOR ALL HAS
REPLACED OVER ELEVEN THOUSAND
EVEN ZERO EMISSION AND HYBRID
VEHICLES AND TO LOW INCOME
HOUSEHOLDS REPLACING OLDER HEAVY
POLLUTING VEHICLES. SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO WILL LOWER THE COST
TO PARTICIPATE IN THE CLEAN CARS
FOR ALL PROGRAM BY EXEMPTING
CARS BOUGHT AND SOLD THROUGH THE
PROGRAM FROM STATE PROPERTY
TAXES WAIVING THE THREE POINT
94% TAX WHICH WILL MAKE THE
PROGRAM MORE AFFORDABLE FOR ALL.
IT ALSO REQUIRES THE- THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO IDENTIFY
CURRENTLY UNDERSERVED GROUPS AND
DEVELOP STRATEGIES TO PROMOTE
OUT REACH AND LOWER BARRIERS FOR
THOSE GROUPS TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL TODAY I HAVE
MISTER ALLEN ABS OF THE
LEGISLATIVE THERE ARE OFFICER
FOR THE BAY AREA AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AND AS WELL
AS CHRIS CHAVEZ FROM THE
COALITION FOR CLEAN IT CLEANER
WHO SHOULD BE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE THANK YOU IF
YOU HAVE SOMEONE HERE PRESENT
THOUGH CORRECT YES MISTER ACCESS
HERE. PLEASE GOOD MORNING VICE
CHAIR NIELSEN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M ALLEN ABS FOR THE
BAY AREA AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT TESTIFYING TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO. AND TO EXPLAIN THE
IMPORTANCE OF A CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL PROGRAM IN THE BAY AREA TO
SUPPORT EQUITY IN ADVANCING A
CLEAN CAR FUTURE. CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL TO RETIRE AND REPLACE
PROGRAM WHERE INCOME QUALIFIED
RESIDENTS IN COMMUNITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY BURDENED BY
POLLUTION. CAN TURN AN OLDER
VEHICLE AND GET AN INCENTIVE TO
PURCHASE OR LEASE A HYBRID PLUG
IN HYBRID ELECTRIC VEHICLE OR
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLE THAT
IS EIGHT YEARS OLDER NEWER. IN
THE THREE YEARS THAT THE BAY
AREA A QB IS ADMINISTERED THIS
PROGRAM WE HAVE SUPPORTED
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED VEHICLE PURCHASES. WITH
TWO THIRDS OF THOSE OCURRING IN
OUR MOST DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES CURRENTLY WE AVERAGE
ABOUT ONE HUNDRED V. VEHICLE
PURCHASES A MONTH. THE HOUSEHOLD
INCOME AND BICKEL CHOSEN
DETERMINES THE AMOUNT OF MONEY
YOU CAN RECEIVE FROM THIS
PROGRAM WITH GRANTS RANGING FROM
FIFTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS TO
NINETY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
DEPENDING ON INCOME IN THE
VEHICLE. BUT THE AVERAGE CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL VEHICLE CURRENTLY
COSTS TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS WHILE THE AVERAGE. CLEAN
CARS FOR ALL INCENTIVE IS ONLY
EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS WITH
AVERAGE LOAN FINANCING FOR
PURCHASING THE VEHICLE BEING
FOURTEEN THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED
DOLLARS. THUS IT STILL REQUIRES
A SIGNIFICANT OUT OF POCKET
EXPENSE FOR MOST ELIGIBLE
APPLICANTS. PROVIDING AN
ADDITIONAL INCENTIVE OR LIMITING
THE TAX BURDEN ON INDIVIDUALS
PARTICIPATING IN THE PROGRAM
WOULD HELP EXPAND THE APPLICANT
POOL. REDUCE PARTICIPANT COSTS
AND SUPPORT CALIFORNIA'S EQUITY
IN ZERO EMISSION GOALS. I LOOK
FORWARD TO ANSWERING ANY
QUESTIONS YOU HAVE AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND- THANK YOU TO SENATOR
GONZALEZ FOR HER LEADERSHIP ON
THIS ISSUE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
WHEN YOU. AND YOU HAVE A WITNESS
IN Q. YES KRISTER KRISTOFFERSON
THE COALITION FOR CLEAN AIR VERY
GOOD MISTER CHAVEZ THE FLOOR'S
YOURS. GREAT GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS
KRISH FATHER'S NINETY DEPUTY
POLICY DIRECTOR COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR. I'M ALSO CONFIGURED
THE SENDER GONZALEZ IS THAT YOU
CAN TAKE HER FOR OFFERING THIS
BILL. WE SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO WHICH WOULD
STRENGTHEN THE CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL PROGRAM THIS PROGRAM HELPS
LOW INCOME RESIDENTS AND POOR
ENVIRONMENTALLY BURDEN
COMMUNITIES WITH HIGHER THEIR
OLD POLLUTING VEHICLES AND
REPLACE THEM WITH CLEANER
MODELS. LOW INCOME RESIDENTS IN
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES HAVE
THE GREATEST BURDENS CLEAN
TRANSPORTATION. AT THE SAME TIME
THE FED TO BENEFIT THE MOST FROM
CLEAN TRANSPORTATION BOTH
FINANCIALLY THROUGH REDUCE YOUR
MAINTENANCE COSTS. AS WELL TO
IMPROVE AIR QUALITY IN EMISSION
REDUCTIONS. FIFTY FOR A TARGET
HOUSEHOLD HELPFUL DISPENSARIES
MAKING UP 21100% OF FEDERAL
POVERTY LINE. BOTH OF THE FUNDS
HOWEVER HAVE GONE TO HOUSEHOLD
AT 210025% OF THE POPULATION OR
LOWER. IT'S ALSO WORTH
HIGHLIGHTING THAT MUCH AS HE
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS. THESE
PARTNERSHIPS INCLUDE SERVING
HARD TO REACH FARM WORKER IN A
CULTURAL COMMITTEES IN THE SAN
JOAQUIN VALLEY TO HELPING
CONNECT A GREEN CARD FOR ALL
PARTICIPANTS AND OTHER CLIMATE
WITH WITH OTHER CLIENT PROGRAMS
LIKE WEATHERIZATION ROOFTOP
SOLAR. SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO
BUILD UP THE BEST OF THE GREEN
CARD FOR ALL PROGRAM WHILE
RECOGNIZING THAT MORE MUST BE
DONE TO ENSURE THAT THAT THE
PROGRAM AND ACCESS TO CLEAN
VEHICLES AVAILABLE TO MOST
UNDERSERVED CALIFORNIANS. SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY P. REDUCES THE
COST OF PARTICIPATING CLEAN CARS
FOR ALL I WADE IN THE SALES TAX
VEHICLES BOUGHT AND SOLD TO THE
PROGRAM. WILL ALSO REQUIRE THE
CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES BOARD
TO WORK WITH THEIR DISTRICT AND
LOCAL COMMUNITY GROUPS TO
IDENTIFY AND DEVELOP PROGRAMS TO
DEVELOP A TO REDUCE BARRIERS.
THEY ARE CURRENTLY KEEPING MANY
ELIGIBLE AND UNDERSERVED
CALIFORNIANS FOR PARTICIPATING
IN THE PROGRAM THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR TESTIMONY NOW WE'RE
GOING TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
HERE IN ROOMS- AT TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT YES SIR.
RIGHT THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
READ ADDRESS ON BEHALF OF VALLEY
CLEAN AIR NOW REALLY EXCITED TO
WORK WITH THECENTER ON THIS
BILL IN SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING CHAIR. ANTHONY SAMPSON
THE SAMPSON ADVISORS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA NEW CAR
DEALERS ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY HERE IN THE ROOM. SEEING
NONE MISTER MODERATOR WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE IF YOU COULD
PLEASE QUEUE UP. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN COURT. THE
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS
TRANSPORT FOR SB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
TWO. MADAM CHAIR NOBODY IS
GEARING UP. GOOD WILL MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION WE HAVE NOT RECEIVED
ANY LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES-
SO WE'LL SEE IF ANYONE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SEEING
NONE WILL GO TO THE CONFERENCE
LINE AND SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. TESTIFYING IN
OPPOSITION TO-SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
ONE ZERO. NOBODY IS QUEUING UP
OUT OF HERE VERY GOOD WILL BRING
THE- THE MATTER BACK TO THE-
COMMITTEE IS THERE ANYONE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO- THERE IS A MOTION
BY SENATOR WIENER. CENTER DRAWS
A DID YOU WANT TO SAY ANYTHING
OR JUST. JUST OF COURSE ON IT
YES JUST THE OF THANK THE AUTHOR
I'M I'M CURIOUS- IF THE AUTHOR
ONE OF YOUR WITNESSES- WHAT DOES
THIS- TAX EXEMPTION ACTUALLY
TRANSLATE INTO AS FAR AS DOLLARS
AND CENTS. IF YOU CAN GIVE US.
AN IDEA NOW BUT- THAT'S A GOOD
QUESTION WELL I THINK THEY SAID
THAT THAT HAPPENED IN THE TRIBES
IF YOU WANT TO PROVIDE- SOME
ADDITIONAL CONTACT. SO WE FOUND
THAT THE AVERAGE CLEAN CARS FOR
ALL VEHICLES IS ABOUT TWENTY
EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS- EITHER A
NEW A NEW CAR TYPICALLY IT'S A
USED VEHICLE AND SO- WHEN YOU
LOOK AT A ABOUT A FOUR PERCENT-
SALES TAX EXEMPTION. IT GETS
CLOSE TO A THOUSAND DOLLARS.
OKAY THANK YOU THE SHAPE THAT.
I'M AND A COMMON I HAVE IS I
THINK THIS IS AN EXCELLENT IDEA-
I LIKE THE BILL AND I'D LIKE TO
BE LISTED AS A CO AUTHOR WHEN
YOU GET READY TO AMENDED- WE DO
HAVE A MOTION AYE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED BUT FIRST
AMEND AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATORS
CAMBIADO HI CABALLERO HI NIELSEN
THE- NIELSEN NO DURAZO. RASO HI
HERTZBERG. WINNER WINNER HI.
THREE ONE. WE WILL PUT THE BOOK
THE BILL ON CALL- CENTER ARCHER
LET I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE YOU'RE
NEXT BECAUSE YOU'VE BEEN WAITING
BY DO YOU MIND IF WE TAKE UP
SENATOR DIED TUESDAY- BEFORE ON
THE COUNTER I THINK IT'LL BE-
FAIRLY QUICKLY. RIGHT ABSOLUTELY
SENATOR DIED ITEM NUMBER FOUR IN
THE CALENDAR FIVE EXCUSE ME SB
TEN FIFTY. THANK YOU OUT MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS- S. B. TEN FIFTY
WOULD AUTHORIZE TOLLING ISSUANCE
OF BONDS NECESSARY TO ADDRESS
SIGNIFICANT CONGESTION AND LONG
TERM RESILIENCY NEEDS A STATE
ROUTE THIRTY SEVEN. IN MY
DISTRICT THE TOLLING WOULD BE
GOVERNED BY THE BAY AREA
INFRASTRUCTURE FINANCING
AUTHORITY THAT'S BAY FIVE- FOR
SHORT A JOINT POWERS AUTHORITY
COMPRISED OF THE METROPOLITAN
TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION. IN
THE BAY AREA TOLL AUTHORITY WHO
BRINGS SIGNIFICANT EXPERIENCE.
DELIVERING COMPLEX
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS AND
ISSUES THAT I DON'T SB THIRTY
SEVEN IS A MAJOR CORRIDOR
EXTENDING FROM U. S. ONE A ONE
AND A MOTTO TO INTERSTATE EIGHTY
IN VALLEJO IT SERVES AS A VITAL
CONNECTION BETWEEN THE COUNTIES
OF MARIN. NAPA SONOMA SOLANO IT
IS ALSO UNIQUE WITH LONG
STRETCHES OF LOW LYING. ROADS
SURROUNDED BY ECOLOGICALLY RICH
WETLANDS AT THE EDGE OF THE SAN
PABLO NATIONAL WILDLIFE REFUGE
REFUGE MAKING IT PARTICULARLY
VULNERABLE. TO FLOODING AND SEA
LEVEL RISE. THERE'S BEEN
RECOGNIZE BY CAL. TO BE ONE OF
OUR MOST AT RISK TRANSPORTATION
ASSETS WITH THE POTENTIAL TO BE
INUNDATED- BY TWO THOUSAND AND
FORTY. ANYONE WHO'S DRIVEN ON
HIGHWAY THIRTY SEVEN ALSO KNOWS
IT IS SOME OF THE WORST
CONGESTION IN THE REGION
IMPACTING COMMUTERS VISITORS AND
FREIGHT MOVEMENT SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK. ESTABLISHING TOLLING
AUTHORITY IS A CRITICAL STEP
TOWARDS PROVIDING THE NECESSARY
REVENUE TO IMPROVE RESILIENCY IN
THIS VITAL TRANSPORTATION
INFRASTRUCTURE. FROM SEA LEVEL
RISE AND FLOODING WHILE ALSO
DEALING WITH CONGESTION
PROVIDING ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS
IN IMPROVING TRANSIT. OPTIONS IN
THE REGION. THE BILL SPECIFIES
THAT TOLL REVENUE WILL INCLUDE
AN INTERIM IN OLDHAM IT
PROJECTS. AS WELL AS ECOLOGICAL
RESTORATION AND ADAPTIVE
IMPROVEMENTS. MEMBERS THIS IS A
MASSIVE- PROJECT IT'S AN
EXPENSIVE ONE IT WILL TAKE
MULTIPLE FUNDING SOURCES TO
COMPLETE. WHILE TOLL ROADS ALONE
CANNOT MEET THE NEEDS OF THE OF
THIS PROJECT THERE ARE A VITAL
SOURCE OF. LOCAL MATCHING FUNDS
THAT WILL INCREASE THE PROJECT'S
COMPETITIVENESS FOR ADDITIONAL
STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDING.
LASTLY AS THE BILL MOVES MOVES
FORWARD I'LL BE ADDING A
DEFINITION OF LOW INCOME IN
EXTENDED THE DISCUSS. ANY LOW
INCOME DRIVER WITH A FAST TRACK
TO ADDRESS EQUITY IMPACT ON
PEOPLE'S. FIVE TWO WITNESSES
WITH ME OF SUPPORT- TO TESTIFY-
REBECCA LONG TO BE HAVE TO MATCH
FALL TRANSPORTATION COMMISSION
AND DARYL HALLS. OF THE FLORIDA
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY. GOOD
MORNING A TEAR CABALLERO VICE
CHAIR NIELSEN AND MEMBERS MY
NAME IS REBECCA LONG AND I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF LEGISLATION AND
PUBLIC AFFAIRS AT THE
METROPOLITAN TRANSPORTATION
COMMISSION- MTC- A UNIQUE
GOVERNING AND FINANCING
STRUCTURE. SB TEN FIFTY WILL
SUPPORT NEAR TERM ABILITY NEEDS
AND LONG TERM RESILIENCE THE
STATE ROUTE THIRTY SEVEN A
CRITICAL EAST WEST COMMUTE AND
GOODS MOVEMENT CORRIDOR. IN THE
NORTH BAIT THAT RUNS THROUGH FOR
COUNTIES INCLUDING SOLANO NAPA
SONOMA AND MARIN. THE BILL
AUTHORIZES TOLLS ON STATE ROUTE
THIRTY SEVEN TO HELP MANAGE
CONGESTION AND GENERATE NEW
REVENUE TO IMPROVE MOBILITY ON A
PORTION OF THE CORRIDOR THAT IS
JUST A SINGLE LANE IN EACH
DIRECTION. WHILE ALSO GENERATING
FUNDS TO HELP ADDRESS LONG TERM
RESILIENCE IN THE FACE OF RISING
SEAS WHICH STUDIES INDICATE WILL
FULLY IN A DATE THE CORRIDOR
WITHIN A FEW DECADES. FROM A
GOVERNMENT STANDPOINT. THE BILL
ESTABLISHES A NEW ENTITY THE
STATE ROUTE THIRTY SEVEN TOLLING
AUTHORITY TO ADMINISTER THE
TOLLS. THAT RATHER THAN CREATE A
BRAND NEW ORGANIZATION WITH THE
SIGNIFICANT COSTS AND RISKS
ASSOCIATED WITH THAT THE BILL
LEVERAGES. EXISTING RESOURCES
AND EXPERTISE OF MTC BY
DESIGNATING AN AFFILIATE OF MTC.
THE BAY AREA INFRASTRUCTURE
FINANCING AUTHORITY OR BAY FAT
AS THE GOVERNING BODY. FOR THE
NEW STATE ROUTE THIRTY SEVEN
TOLLING AUTHORITY. WHICH MEANS
THAT AND SEE STAFF WITH OUR
EXISTING EXPERTISE WILL STOP
THIS BODY. IN SUMMARY SB TEN
FIFTY WILL BUILD ON EXISTING
INSTITUTIONAL EXPERTISE TO
AUTHORIZE TOLLS ON A ROADWAY
WHERE MOTORISTS HAVE NO TRAVEL
ALTERNATIVE TO BEING STUCK IN
CONGESTION. THE TOLLS AUTHORIZED
BY THE BILL WILL HELP COMPLETE A
FUNDING PLAN OUT OF CARPOOL LANE
IN EACH DIRECTION MAKING TRANSIT
AND CARPOOLING. VIABLE IN THE
QUARTER FOR THE FIRST TIME WHILE
ALSO GENERATING ADDITIONAL FUNDS
TO SUPPORT THE CORRIDORS LONG
TERM RESILIENCE. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AND HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU MAY
HAVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. MISTER HALL'S FORTY MADAM
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE
DARYL HALL SECOND DOOR TO THE
SLAUGHTER TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY WE'RE THE PARTNER
AGENCIES IT'S WORKING WITH MTC.
CALTRANS UNDER DODD. ARE NORTH
BAY COUNTY PARKER'S. OF 50% A
QUARTER SINCE ON A COUNTY WHERE
THE COUNTY WITH THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING ONE OF OUR RESIDENTS GO
WEST ON THIRTY SEVEN TO GO TO
WORK MORE IN CINEMA COUNTY
SOURCES YOU CRITICAL EQUITY
PROJECT FOR US. THERE'S NO
TRANSIT SERVICE OUT THERE AT ALL
NOW THIS THE FUNDING WILL
PROVIDE. TRANCERS BETTER ACCESS
TO JOBS. AND ALSO OBVIOUSLY LESS
TIME SPENT IN TRAIN TRAFFIC. IN
ADDITION WE'VE WE'VE BEEN A
PARTNER WITH THEM TO SEE ON BAY
FOR THE BAY AREA FINANCING
AUTHORITY WHICH EXISTS FOR THE
EXPRESS LANE PROGRAM. OR
COUNTIES ONE OF THREE COUNTIES
ARE PART OF A FOR SYSTEM. IT
WOULD WORKING WITH HIM FOR TEN
YEARS IT'S TO DO IT JENNIFER
CHEN GENERATING. SIGNIFICANT
PROGRESS IN FACT WE HAVE A BIG
LARGE PROJECT THAT'S BEING A BAY
FOR PROJECT IT'S GOING START OF
I. EIGHTY. SON ACCOUNTING AND
CONSTRUCTION THIS YEAR WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON FOR NUMBER OF
YEARS THEY'RE GONNA BE OPERATE
THAT FACILITY. SO BASS HAS A
PROVEN ENTITY IN OUR IN OUR
REGION. WE'RE BIG SUPPORTER OF
BOTH PAY FOR BUT ALSO IMPROVING
THIRTY SEVEN SEPT INTERNET
QUESTIONS. THANKS FOR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IS THERE
ANY HERE IN ROOM TO TWO HIGH.
THAT WOULD TO. AT TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT. OF. JAMES CAMERON WITH
THE CINEMA COUNTY TRANSPORTATION
AUTHORITY WE SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE. MISTER MODERATOR
CAN YOU CHECK THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE TO SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THANK YOU
MEDICARE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR SB CAN
FIFTY PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED
BY ZRO AT THIS TIME. WHEN FILED
BY ZERO THIS FIND SUPPORT FOR SB
TEN FIFTY. AND WE'LL GO TO LINE
EIGHTY EIGHT ANYBODY ELSE BUT IT
ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME. A GOOD
MORNING CAN HELP YOU KNOW
REPRESENTING THE CINEMA LAND
TRUST IN SUPPORT OF THAT YOU CAN
FIFTY THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. NEXT PLEASE ENTER NOBODY
ELSE WAS QUEUING UP AT THIS TIME
VERY GOOD WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO OPPOSITION THERE WAS NO LEAD
OPPOSITION WITNESS IDENTIFIED
AND SO WE WERE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO INDIVIDUALS IN ROOM TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION OF S. B.
TEN FIFTY. SAYING NO ONE MOVED
WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR CAN YOU PROMPT AND SEE
IF THERE'S ANYONE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TEST FOR IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MEDICARE TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR- SB TEN FIFTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME WHEN FALL BY ZRO. NOBODY
IS GOING UP. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
WILL BRING THE- THE BILL BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. NO IT IS NOT THAT
SENATOR HERTZBERG MOVES ABOUT.
SAYING NO COMMENTS- WE WILL
ALLOW YOU TO CONCLUDE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
THE FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS CAPITO HI CABALLERO HI
NIELSEN HI NIELSEN HI DORADO.
DORADO HI HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI
WIENER ALL RIGHT WIENER I. FIVE
ZERO ZERO FIVE TWO ZERO WILL
HOLD IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
REMOVE ON TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT SENATOR ARCHULETA. YOU ARE
UP S. B. TWELVE NINETY ONE.
UNDER THE FOR THE FLOORIS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND-
MEMBERS. I AM PLEASED TO SUBMIT
FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION SENATE
BILL TWELVE NINETY ONE. WHICH
WOULD DIRECT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO ADMINISTRATIVELY APPROVED
HYDROGEN FUEL CELL STATIONS AS
THEY DO CURRENTLY FOR CHARGING
STATIONS EQUITY OPPORTUNITY FOR
BOTH. IN ORDER TO MEET OUR
FUTURE CLEAN TRANSPORTATION
GOALS INCLUDING THE
TRANSPORTATION OR THE TRANSITION
TO ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES SALES
THERE OF AN INCREASE OF THE
NUMBER OF VEHICLES ON THE ROAD
THAT ARE ZERO EMISSIONS- THE
AVAILABILITY OF FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE MUST INCREASE. WE
KNOW CONSUMERS WILL NOT ADOPT
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES IF THEY
IF THE REQUISITE FUELING
INFRASTRUCTURE IS NOT WIDELY
AVAILABLE AND THAT SEEMS TO BE
THE PROBLEM NOT HAVE BEEN OF
INFRASTRUCTURE FUELING STATIONS.
SO THIS BILL ADDRESS THAT TO
THAT END S. B. TWELVE NINETY ONE
CREATES A PATH TO EASE THE
INITIAL PERMITTING PROCESS
RAJINDER FUELING STATIONS AND
WELL THIS BILL PRESERVES- LOCAL
AUTHORITY TO DENY A PERMIT BASED
ON SAFETY TO PUBLIC OR PUBLIC
HEALTH THE MEASURE REQUIRES.
LOCAL OFFICIALS TO DISCLOSE
CONCERNS AND OFFER SOLUTIONS
WORKING TOGETHER WITH THE
COMMUNITIES AND THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY TO MAKE SURE THAT ANY
TIME A FUELING STATION IS- PUT
ON THE TABLE THAT- LOCAL
AUTHORITY HAS FULL AUTHORITY TO
PARTICIPATE. IN APPROVING OR
DENYING. UNDER THE ENERGY
COMMISSION'S ACCOUNTABILITY
METRICS FOR ITS HYDROGEN STATION
PROGRAM PERMITS MUST BE SECURED
WITHIN EIGHTEEN MONTHS BUT BASED
ON DATA COLLECTED IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE JOINT CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION AND CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES REPORT SHOWS THAT
GETTING TO ONE HUNDRED STATIONS
AND THAT IS OUR GOAL. RIGHT NOW
CALIFORNIA ONLY HAS FIFTY TO GET
TO OUR GOAL OF A HUNDRED THE
STATION SOMETIMES PERMITTING
TAKES UP TO FIVE HUNDRED DAYS IN
THIS BILL WILL OPEN UP IN
STREAMLINED THIS PROCESS. IS
CITY OR COUNTY WILL STILL
ADMINISTRATORS APPROVED AN
APPLICATION TO INSTALL ELECTRIC
VEHICLE CHARGING STATIONS OR
HYDROGEN FUEL STATIONS THROUGH
THE ISSUANCE OF A BUILDING
PERMIT. WE ARE JUST LOOKING FOR
EQUALITY IN ADDITION A CITY HAS
THE AUTHORITY TO REQUIRE
ADDITIONAL PERMITTING IF
NECESSARY SENATE BILL TWELVE
NINETY ONE WILL EASE PERMITTING
REQUIREMENTS WITHOUT SACRIFICING
LOCAL CONTROL Y. INSURING THAT
ELECTRIC CHARGING STATIONS AND
HYDROGEN. FUELING STATIONS ARE
BEING INSTALLED IN ORDER TO KEEP
PACE WITH THE STATE'S GOAL OF
INCREASING ELECTRICAL ELECTRIC
VEHICLE USAGE AND HYDROGEN
FUELING STATION FOR THESE
REGIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE AND WITH ME TODAY MADAM
CHAIR I HAVE- TESTIFYING IN
SUPPORT. OF THE BILL TO RESET
COOK ON BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
ARJUN A COALITION. WELCOME THE
FOURS YEARS HI GOOD AFTERNOON
SENATOR MEMBERS TERESA COOK ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA HYDROGEN
COALITION IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL- BY SENATOR ARCH ALETTA AS
STATED WE'VE GOT A LOT OF WORK
AHEAD OF US TO- ENCOURAGE
CONSUMER ADOPTION OF ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLES. IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT WE'RE GIVING
HOUSEHOLDS CHOICES BETWEEN
BATTERY ELECTRIC VEHICLES AND
FUEL CELL ELECTRIC VEHICLES
BECAUSE BOTH TECHNOLOGY TYPES
HAVE DIFFERENT ADVANTAGES AND
DISADVANTAGES TO MEET THE VERY
DIVERSE NEEDS OF DRIVERS IN THE
STATE OF HOW- IS THE- AUTHOR
POINTED OUT- PERMITTING IS A BIG
CHALLENGE FOR BOTH CHARGING AND
HYDROGEN INFRASTRUCTURE. AND SO-
TWELVE NINETY ONE WOOD AT LEAST
IN THE BEGINNING EASE AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
OF A HYDROGEN FUELING STATION
BUT IT'S IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER
THAT IF THE BUILDING OFFICIAL
FINDS ANY SAFETY OR PUBLIC
HEALTH ISSUES ASSOCIATED WITH
THE PROPOSED PROJECT WE CAN BE
DIRECTED TO A- DISCRETIONARY
PERMIT REQUIRING FURTHER REVIEW
AN ADDITIONAL WORK SO. HOPEFULLY
WE STRUCK A GOOD BALANCE WITH
THIS BILL IF YOU WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR ITS WORK ON
THE AMENDMENTS AND ARM ASK FOR
YOUR I. PHONE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED
THAT WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. SINGMAN
WORLD MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. MISTER
MODERATOR COULD YOU PROMPT-
TESTIMONY AND SEE IF THERE'S
ANYBODY THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR WOULD YOU PLEASE
REITERATE WHAT BILL WE ARE ON
YES WE ARE ON S. B. TWELVE
NINETY ONE BY SENATOR ARCHULETA
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF SB TWELVE NINETY ONE PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME WHEN FILED BY ZERO. WE
DO A ONE QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT
PLEASE. NOBODY ELSE- PLEASE TAKE
THIS OPPORTUNITY AND HIT ONE
ZERO. TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR
SB TWELVE NINETY ONE WE'LL GO TO
LINE NINETY ONE HE'S GOING. GOOD
AFTERNOON THAT THE BILL BE ABLE
FERRARI ON BEHALF OF EHRLICH
HE'D IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR NO ONE ELSE
QUEUED UP. VERY GOOD WILL MOVE
ON TO OPPOSITION WE DO NOT HAVE
A LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESS
IDENTIFIED IS THERE ANYONE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. SAYING NO ONE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE TELECOM. SORRY
ARE YOU IN OPPOSITION I. DID
JUST WANT TO EXPRESS OUR
CONCERNS OF THE BILL DAMON
CONKLIN AND- ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF CITIES A
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS WE- HAVE SOME CONCERNS-
WITH THE BILL WE SHARE THAT OUT
ONLINE GOALS OF THE BILL- BUT-
DON'T SEE EYE TO EYE ON LOCAL
AGENCIES BEING THE BARRIER
IMPEDIMENT- TO THE PERMITTING
PROCESS. BUT LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH- BOTH THE AUTHOR OF
THE BILL IN THE SPONSORS OF THE
BILL WORKING FORWARD ON- MEETING
THOSE THAT CONCERNS- IF THE BILL
WERE TO MOVE FORWARD THANKS VERY
MUCH VERY GOOD THANK YOU REAR
MET VERY MUCH FOR YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY SIR ANYONE ELSE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED I MAY
HAVE MOVED TOO FAST. SINGMAN
WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU CAN PROMPT
ANYONE IN OPPOSITION TO PLEASE
IDENTIFY THEMSELVES. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THE TEST PLAN
OPPOSITION TO S. B. TWELVE
NINETY ONE. OH EIGHT EIGHT ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. ONE FILED BY
ZERO. AND NOBODY IS GIVING OUT.
VERY GOOD- WILL BRING THE BILL
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE ARE THERE
ANY COMMENTS CONCERNS I'LL
ENTERTAIN A MOTION. THE BILL IS
MOVED BY SENATOR HERTZBERG THE
MOTION IS TO PASS IN RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON TRANSPORTATION
CENTER ARCHULETA WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CONCLUDE. YES MANAGER I WOULD
JUST LIKE TO THANK OF ALL THE
CHAIRMAN I'M J. ALL THE A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN THE CHAIR-
THIS IS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY TO
EQUALIZE WHAT WE'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH ENERGY AND I CALL IT THE
TREASURE CHEST OF ENERGY WE OPEN
THAT UP IT SHOULD INCLUDE
EVERYTHING WE'RE START LOOKING
FOR ZERO- ADMISSIONS WERE TRYING
TO. MAKE SURE THAT CALIFORNIA
LEADS THE WAY FUEL CELL
BATTERIES FUEL CELL HYDROGEN
BATTERIES WHATEVER TERM YOU USE
WHAT IS HAPPENING IT'S A NEW
TECHNOLOGY CAL STATE LA IN IN
MY- COLLEAGUES HOMETOWN THE
ENTIRE FLEET OF CAL STATE LA
AUTOMOBILES ARE RUN ON FUEL CELL
BATTERIES- THEY'RE ABLE TO FUEL
UP. IN A MATTER OF MINUTES EACH
AUTOMOBILE GETS ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED MILES AND- ECONOMICALLY
FEASIBLE BECAUSE THIS IS WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO AND I HOPE
ONE DAY THAT ALL THE CAL STATE
SCHOOLS ARE DOING THE SAME
THING. HAVING THESE FUELING
STATIONS RIGHT NOW AS I SAID WE
HAD FIFTY WE'RE SHOOTING FOR A
HUNDRED AND MAYBE ONE DAY WE'LL
HAVE A THOUSAND TO GIVE EVERYONE
AN OPPORTUNITY TO PURCHASE THE
AUTOMOBILES THAT. RUNS ON FUEL
CELL BATTERIES RATHER THAN JUST
ELECTRIC SO IT OPENS UP THE DOOR
BUT THIS- STREAMLINED THE
PROCESS WILL BE THERE I JUST
HUNG UP THE PHONE WITH THE
FORMER CITY MANAGER OF A
DISTRICT CITY MANAGER WHO IS A-
FORMER PRESIDENT OF THE CITY
MANAGERS ASSOCIATION. IN
MONTEBELLO HE'S EXCITED TO GO
AHEAD AND START THE PROCESS AND
HOPING THAT SOME OF THE CITY'S-
IN OUR DISTRICT AROUND AREA
START OPEN UP THE DOORS BECAUSE
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT WANT TO
CONSTRUCT THE FUELING STATIONS
AND THIS WILL MAKE IT A LOT
FASTER SO WITH THAT I ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SAN
CUBBY. HI COPYRIGHT I NIELSEN HI
NIELSEN ALL RIGHT TORONTO.
TORONTO HI HERTZBERG- I WIENER
ALL RIGHT WIENER HI. FIVE ZERO.
I HAVE FIVE EYES NO ZERO- WILL
PUT THAT ONCALL AS WELL. BUT IF
THERE'S THE- WE'RE ALL HERE OKAY
WELL THAT BILL IS OUT I THINK
THAT'S A FIRST SO FAR THIS
MORNING- I'M A BILL IS OUT SO
MOVE ON TO ITEM NUMBER NINE
CENTER ARCHULETA S. B. THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE. AND ONCE AGAIN
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS OUTLINED IN THE
ANALYSIS. TODAY I'M PRESENTED
SENATE BILL THIRTEEN NINETY
THREE WHICH SEEKS TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES WITH DECARBONIZATION-
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING BUILDINGS
BY REQUIRING LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
TO CONSIDER CERTAIN FACTORS
BEFORE APPROVING ORDINANCES THAT
WOULD REQUIRE GAS APPLIANCES BE
REPLACED WITH ELECTRIC
APPLIANCES AND THAT'S THE GIST
OF IT. MOST OF US HAVE GAS
APPLIANCES- SOME OF THE OF HOMES
AND BUILDINGS AND APARTMENTS ALL
HAVE GAS APPLIANCES AND YES OF
COURSE WE'RE LOOKING TO THE
FUTURE TO REPLACE TO REPLACE OLD
BUT MAKING SURE THAT WE DO IT-
AFFECTED BILLY. AND WITH
PATIENCE IN THIS IS WHAT THE
BILL IS ABOUT SIGNIFICANTLY- THE
BILL WOULD REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS. WHEN ADOPTING
ORDINANCE THAT REQUIRED THAT
REPLACEMENT OF A FOSSIL FUEL
FIRED APPLIANCE WITH ELECTRIC
APPLIANCE UPON THE ALTERATION OR
RETROFIT OF THE RESIDENTIAL OR
NON RESIDENTIAL BUILDING TO
SIMPLY CONSIDER GUIDANCE AND
BEST PRACTICE PUBLISHED BI
ANNUALLY BY THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION. AGAIN THE
BILL WILL SIMPLY REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CONSIDER THE
GUIDANCE IT DOES NOT MANDATE
SPECIFIC OUTCOMES REQUIRE THE
ORDINANCE TO CONTAIN SPECIFIC
PROVISIONS. THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OF ADOPTED THE
ORDINANCE TO SUBMIT TO THE
COMMISSION A COPY OF YOUR DEBTS
AND WOULD STAND REQUIRED THE
COMMISSION TO DETERMINE WHETHER
THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT CONSIDERED
THE COMMISSION'S GUIDE LINES. IF
THE COMMISSION DETER THAT LOCAL
DID NOT CONSIDER THE GUIDELINES
AND GUIDANCE THEN THE BILL WOULD
ALLOW THE LOCAL GOVERNMENT TO GO
BACK AND CONSIDER THE GUIDANCE
MAKE ANY MODIFICATIONS IF
NECESSARY AND RESUBMIT THE- THE
ORDINANCE WHEN IT COMES TO
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
CALIFORNIA HAS LARGELY FOCUSED
ON NEW CONSTRUCTION IN FACT OVER
THE PAST SEVERAL YEARS MANY
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE ADOPTED
WHAT ARE OFTEN REFERRED TO AS
REACH COACH WHICH ARE LOCAL
ENERGY ORDINANCE REQUIRING MORE
STRINGENT ENERGY REQUIREMENTS
THAN THOSE SET BY THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY CODE. THESE REACH COACH
WHICH ADDRESSED NEW CONSTRUCTION
MUST BE REVIEWED AND APPROVED BY
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
HOWEVER THERE ARE UNIQUE
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH
DECARBONISATION AND
DECARBONISING EXISTING BUILDINGS
COMPARED TO NEW BUILDINGS THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION
RECENTLY IDENTIFIED COST AS THE
MOST SIGNIFICANT BERRIER
ACCORDING TO THE COMMISSION AN
ELECTRIC PANEL UPGRADE MAY COST
BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE HUNDRED AND
FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS WHICH IS
PAID FOR BY THE HOMEOWNER OR THE
PROPERTY OWNER IN A SCENARIO IN
WHICH EVERY HOUSE BUILT BEFORE
NINETEEN NINETY REQUIRES
ELECTRIC PANEL UPGRADE IT WOULD
COST APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
TO FORTY BILLION DOLLARS. THIS
DOES NOT EVEN INCLUDE THE COST
OF THE APPLIANCE IN THE
INSULATION THESE COSTS
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT LOW
INCOME AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES THESE COMMUNITIES
FACE ADDITIONAL UNIQUE BARRIERS
BECAUSE SYSTEMIC INEQUITY IN
EQUITY A HISTORY OF LOWER ACCESS
TO CAPITAL AND FINANCE A GREATER
ENERGY BURDEN AND LOWER RATES.
FOR HOME AND BUSINESS OWNERSHIP.
AS LOCAL JURISDICTIONS BEGAN
ADOPTING ORDINANCES TO ADDRESS
EXISTING BUILDINGS CALIFORNIA
LAW MUST BE UPDATED TO ENSURE
THAT THESE ORDINANCES ADOPTED
WELL TAKEN IMPORTANT FACTORS
INTO CONSIDERATION I BELIEVE
THAT BY REQUIRING LOCAL. LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO CONSIDER STATE
GUIDANCE. WE CAN ACHIEVE THE
GOAL THEY MUST CONSULT WITH THE
STATE. WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY
BE AFTER THIS IMPORTANT BILL IS
ANTHONY SAMPSON I'LL BE OUT FOR
THE- A. O. SMITH CORPORATION AND
DON- COPAY. ON BEHALF OF THE AIR
CONDITIONING HEATING AND
REFERRED A REFRIGERATION
INDUSTRY AN INSTITUTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE
AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH A GOOD
MORNING AND THAT IN CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER- ANTHONY SAM
SOME SAMPSON ADVISERS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE L. SMITH
CORPORATION IT WAS MISS ONE OF
THE WORLD'S LEADING
MANUFACTURERS OF RESIDENTIAL AND
COMMERCIAL WATER HEATERS AND
BOILERS. AND ALONG WITH ITS
SUBSIDIARIES OF THE LARGEST
MANUFACTURER AND SELLER OF
RESIDENTIAL COMMERCIAL WATER
HEATING EQUIPMENT INCLUDING
ELECTRIC HEAT PUMP WATER HEATERS
IN NORTH AMERICA- TURNING TO THE
BILL SENATOR ARCHULETA ID AN
EXCELLENT JOB SUMMARIZING IT SO
I JUST WANT TO KNOW A COUPLE OF
POINTS. FIRST I THINK THE
RELEVANT CONSIDERATION FOR THE
COMMITTEE HERE TODAY IS WHETHER
THE STATE OUGHT TO PLAY SOME
ROLE. TO HELP GUIDE LOCAL
DECISION MAKERS AS THEY SEEK TO
ADOPT ORDINANCES REQUIRING OTHER
REPLACEMENT OF GAS TO ELECTRIC
APPLIANCES AS A SENATOR NOTED
THERE'S A LOT OF UNIQUE
CHALLENGES ASSOCIATED WITH
TRANSITIONING THE EXISTING BUILT
ENVIRONMENT TO ELECTRIC. AS TO
THE NEW NEW CONSTRUCTION AND SB
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE IS SIMPLY
AN EFFORT TO ENSURE THOSE
CHALLENGES ARE CONSIDERED. AND
RELATED TO THAT ALL THIS WANT TO
READ RATE ONE POINT- THAT THE
SENATOR NOTED WHICH IS THE
CURRENT LAW. REQUIRES LOCAL
STATE SEEK TO ADOPT REACH CODE
ORDINANCES ADDRESSING NEW
CONSTRUCTION TO GO THROUGH
REVIEW AND APPROVAL PROCESS AT
THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION. NO SUCH REQUIREMENT
EXISTS FOR THESE TYPES OF
ORDINANCES THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TODAY EVEN THOUGH
DECARBONIZING THE EXISTING BUILT
MEANT IS FAR MORE CHALLENGING
AND COMPLICATED. SB THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE SEEKS TO ESTABLISH
THAT PROCESS AND IT DOES SO BY
MERELY REQUIRING LOCALS TO
CONSIDER NOT ADEQUATELY
CONSIDERED NOT FOLLOW SIMPLY
CONSIDER CEEC GUIDANCE WITHOUT
MANDATING. OUTCOMES I'LL END BY
NOTING THAT THE LEAGUE OF CITIES
C. SACK AND ENERGIES T. AND
OTHERS HAVE RAISED LEGITIMATE
CONCERNS WITH THE PREVIOUS
VERSION OF THE BILL DURING AND
AFTER THE LAST COMMITTEE
HEARING. THE AMENDED VERSION
WHICH WAS WORKED ON IN
CONSULTATION WITH THOSE GROUPS
WITH THIS COMMITTEE HAS BEEN ON
SIGNIFICANTLY AND WILL SHOW. AND
THAT LOW HAVE BEEN THE FLEX. AND
RESOURCES NEEDED TO ADOPT
THOUGHTFUL AND PRAGMATIC
RETROFIT REPLACEMENT ORDINANCES.
AND ON THAT NOTE. WE ARE- AND I
YOU KNOW I COULD SPEAK FOR THE
CENTER VERY MUCH COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THOSE IN
OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS THEIR
REMAINING CONCERNS AND JUST ONE
AGAIN THANK THE AUTHOR IN THE
COMMITTEE AND COMMITTEE STAFF.
FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS BILL AND
ORIGINAL VOTE TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS DON
KHAKI WITH MCCUE KEPT CAN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF THE AIR
CONDITIONING HEATING AND
REFRIGERATION INSTITUTE. H. RISE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE- AND I WOULD NOTE
AS WELL IN TERMS OF AGE RACE
MEMBERS. REPRESENTING OVER THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY MANUFACTURERS OF
HEATING VENTILATION AIR
CONDITIONING COMMERCIAL
REFRIGERATION EQUIPMENT-
NATIONALLY AND INTERNATIONALLY.
H. RIGHT AND ITS MEMBER
COMPANIES HAVE A LONG HISTORY OF
SUPPORTING ENERGY EFFICIENCY.
AND CLIMATE PROTECTION MEASURES.
WE'RE PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE WHICH
HELPS OF REQUIRE CONSIDERATION
OF GUIDANCE FROM THE CC. ON THE
WELL KNOWN CHALLENGES OF
DECARBONISING EXISTING BUILDING
STOCK FOR PROPOSALS. IN DOING SO
SB THIRTEEN NINETY THREE HELPS
CALIFORNIA LOCALITIES TO MOVE
PRAGMATICALLY AND EFFECTIVELY
FORWARD ON. BUILDING
DECARBONIZATION REQUIREMENTS. AT
AN OPTIONS IN IN DOING SO ALSO
HELPING TO PROVIDE FOR A LEVEL
OF CONSISTENCY IN. REVIEWING
CONSIDERATIONS. THAT ALSO HELP
H. RIGHT MEMBERS WITH COMPLIANCE
WITH THESE EFFORTS ARE WITH
THAT. PLEASE TO SUPPORT THE BILL
AND HAPPY ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE IN ROOM. TWENTY
TWO HUNDRED THEY WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
HI MAKE SNYDER ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA BUILDING INDUSTRY
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE. SEEING NO ONE ELSE WILL
MOVE ON TO THE TELECONFERENCE
LINE IS OR ANYONE ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IF SO
PLEASE- IDENTIFY YOURSELF. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR UP TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT FOR S. B. THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE PLEASE PRESS. ONE
ZERO ONE FIVE EIGHT ZERO.
EXPRESSED SUPPORT FOR SB
THIRTEEN NINETY THREE AND WE
WILL GO LIVE EIGHTY SIX YOU ARE
OPEN. A GOOD AFTERNOON THAT I'M
SURE MEMBERS YELEY GARRICK WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NEXT PLEASE
. MY NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD
. GOOD AFTERNOON SENATOR
CABALLERO THIS IS KIND OF
WALKING IN CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA STATE I TRADE
COUNCIL IN ADDITION TO THE
COALITION OF CALIFORNIA UTILITY
EMPLOYEES AND PROUD SUPPORT
POSITION THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WHAT WE WANNA LINE FIFTY NINE-
AS A REMINDER FOR EVERYBODY ELSE
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT FOR THE THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE HE'S GOING TO FIFTY
NINE. YEAH I'M SURE MEMBERS REX
W. HI MY BEHALF CALIFORNIA
BUSINESS PROPERTIES ASSOCIATION
ALSO SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. I'M SURE NOBODY ELSE QUEUED
UP AT THE START THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO
OPPOSITION THERE IT IS NO TO
LEAD OPPOSITION IDENTIFIED AS OR
ANYBODY IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED YES SIR. WELCOME HELLO
UGH GOOD MORNING OR GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAIR AND MEMBER YOUR
DOLPHIN HAVE LEAVING CALIFORNIA
CITIES HAVE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO
REGISTER COMMENTS FOR THE-
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
COUNTIES- WE WANT TO FIRST BY
THANK UP FOR START BY THINKING.
THE SENATOR AND THE SPONSORS FOR
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS ON APRIL
EIGHTEENTH THAT IS MOVED US FROM
AND OPPOSED INTO AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION WE DID
SUBMIT THE LETTER. LATE LAST
NIGHT SORRY IF THAT IT WAS LATE
TO YOU GUYS- I DID WANT TO
MENTION THAT ORGANIZATIONS DO
SHARE A LOT OF THE GOALS THAT
THE SENATOR IS TRYING TO DO WITH
THIS BILL THE STATE HAS ASKED US
TO CONTINUALLY DECARBONISE AS
QUICKLY AS WE CAN. WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE HAVE THE TOOLS
AND THE ABILITY TO DO THAT SO WE
THE GOAL OF HAVING MORE STE C.
GUIDANCE TO CITIES WHEN THEY'RE
DEVELOPING THESE ORDINANCES
WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT CLARIFIED
IN THE BILL. ADDITIONALLY WE DO
HAVE A COUPLE MORE RESERVATIONS
ABOUT SOME THE CONSIDERATIONS
THAT ARE REQUIRED IN THE BILL
BUT ARE LOOKING FOR TO CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH THE AUTHOR AND THE
SPONSORS ON THIS ONE THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE. THANK YOU
TERRY MEMBERS AND A SENATOR OR
TO LET OF. I'VE MY NAME IS
KATHERINE BRANDENBURG REPRESENTS
AND THE CLEAN POWER. WE ARE
PROVIDED A LETTER LATE TO YOUR
OFFICE LAST WEEK. IN OPPOSITION
OF THIS BILL. AS CINEMA COUNTY
OR CINEMA CLEAN POWER REPRESENTS
CINEMA COUNTY AND MENDOCINO
COUNTIES. AND THEY HAVE ALREADY
CREATED AN ORDINANCE. TO DO JUST
WHAT THIS BILL IS DOING SO WE
BELIEVE- AS IT'S DRAFTED IT WILL
SLOW DOWN THE PROGRESS THE TWO
COUNTIES HAVE MADE SO WE WOULD
LIKE TO WORK WITH THE SENATOR ON
TRYING TO RESOLVE THAT ISSUE.
THANK YOU VERY GOOD THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IS THERE ANYONE ELSE
IN ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED.
SAYING NO ONE WILL MOVE ON TO
THE TELECONFERENCE LINE IS THERE
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LIKE MR MODERATOR. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
AND- IF WE DID GET SOME MARKET
HAS FIGHTERS SUPPORT WOULD YOU
LIKE TO TAKE THOSE- YES WE MIGHT
AS WELL JUST TAKE THEM ALL
TOGETHER. OKAY THANK YOU
MEDICARE IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
TO A SB THIRTEEN NINETY THREE
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO. WE WILL GO TO LINE SIXTY
FOUR- CABALLERO AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS VICTORIA ROME
WITH NATURAL RESOURCES DEFENSE
COUNCIL. AND WE GREATLY
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS AND
THE SPONSORING AUTHORS
ENGAGEMENT ON THE BELL. HOWEVER
WE HAVE HIGHLIGHTED- PRIMARY
REMAINING CONCERNED WITH A
RESUBMISSION REQUIREMENTS THAT
PROVISION AFTER THAT WE REMAIN
OPPOSED AT THIS TIME THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I NEXT WILL
THE LINE EIGHTY YOU ARE OPEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON DANIEL BROUGHT ON
BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA- GO IN OPPOSITION
ANNALYNNE ARE COMMON THREATS
MADE BY ENERGY THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. RIGHT SEVENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I SEVENTY
THREE ARE OPEN. HI THIS IS ANIS
HANG WITH BROKEN VALLEY CLEAN
ENERGY RESPECTFULLY OPPOSE.
THANK YOU. I APOLOGIZE OR MADAM
HERE THOSE ARE MOST OF THEM CUED
UP JUST IN ADVANCE FOR THE
OPPOSITION WE WILL LINE UP FORTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ROB GROWS SEVEN CALIFORNIA
EDISON. RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO
THE BILL- BUT WE- ARE ALIGNING
OUR STATEMENTS WITH THE FACT IN
THE CALIFORNIA CITY TO LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
OFFER SOME MORE. ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NINE EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. AFTERNOON
CARE MEMBERS BENNIFER CANNON
HILL WITH ERIN REED AND
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
SILICON VALLEY CLEAN ENERGY OKAY
CALLING IN OPPOSITION WE REMAIN
OPPOSED TO THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK SEVENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
HILLARY SAVER ON BEHALF OF
CENTER COAST COMMUNITY ENERGY
ESPECIALLY IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. AND THE FINAL REMINDER
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO TO EXPRESS
OPPOSITION FOR SB THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE I NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM SURE
MEMBERS ARE UNABLE TO CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY CHOICE ASSOCIATION- ON
BEHALF OF OUR TWENTY THREE CPA
PROVIDING ELECTRICAL SERVICE TO
ELEVEN MILLION CUSTOMERS IN OVER
TWENTY CITIES AND COUNTIES
ACROSS THE STATE. IT REMAINED
RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED THANK YOU
THANK YOU. THANKS FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MARK FENSTER
MAKER ON BEHALF OF THE CHAPTERS
WE REMAIN OPPOSED FOR THE
REASONS PROVIDED BY ENERGY SEE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. MADAM
CHAIR WE DID ACOSTA Q. VERY GOOD
WE'RE GOING TO BRING SB THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE SENATOR HERTZBERG.
MOVES THERE TO PROMOTE THE BELL
OF THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED BUT FIRST DEMAND AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS YOU HAVE THERE IS
AN- I RECOMMENDATION- ON THIS
BILL RIGHT NOW AS A SENATOR YOU
MAY CONCLUDE. A MANAGER AT I
THANK YOU FOR YOUR SUPPORT AND
URGE AN IBOOK THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND I EXPECT THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
ALL OF THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
HAD SOME CONCERNS YES I'D I'D
LIKE TO GO AHEAD AND END UP.
JUST FOR A SECOND ADDRESSTHAT
WE ARE WORKING EVERY SINGLE DAY
WITH THAT AND I YOU CAN HEAR
FROM BOTH SIDES THAT WE ARE
COMING TOGETHER. AND AGAIN IT'S
A EQUALITY WHICH WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PEOPLE WHO ARE THINKING
ONE DAY WILL I GET A KNOCK ON
THE DOOR AND I'VE GOT TO CHANGE
MY APPLIANCES FROM GAS TO
ELECTRIC CAN I AFFORD THAT. IT
MIGHT GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY WITH
THE CITY'S BE GIVEN AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH THE
STATE WE'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
WORK IT OUT AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR TIME. AND- THE AMENDMENTS
WILL FOLLOW GREAT THANK YOU SO
MUCH LIKE THAT- PLEASE GIVE US.
A PLEASE CALL THE ROLE WE HAVE
TO VOTERS WITH. SENATORS CAN BE
A- HI COPYRIGHT. I NIELSEN.
DURAZO HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI
WIENER. TWO ZERO TWO TWO ZERO
AND WE'LL PUT THAT ON CALL.
THANK YOU MR ARCHULETA I'M YES
LET'S MOVE ON TO SENATOR
HERTZBERG ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN
WHICH IS SB NINE SIXTY SEVEN.
YEAH.
SENATOR HERTZBERG THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. I SENDS CALLING
CONCERNING. MY MUSICIAN SON IS
GETTING MARRIED THIS WEEKEND.
ACTUALLY THAT'S ALWAYS AN
EXCITING EVENT YEAH TOP OF THE-
THAT GOOD SO WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO DO HERE- SOME OTHER STATES
HAVE DONE THIS- A COLORADO
MARYLAND TO VIRGINIA. BASICALLY
WE'VE GOT A SITUATION WHERE ARE
FROM A HEALTHCARE PERSPECTIVE
WE'RE TRYING TO. REYES MANY
FOLKS AS POSSIBLE TO IF THEY'RE
ELIGIBLE TO JOIN COVERED
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW IT'S HELP
TO POINT COVER CALIFORNIA'S HELP
TWO POINT NINE MILLION PEOPLE
FIND HEALTH HEALTH INSURANCE
OFTEN AS WE KNOW IS IT JUST A
DISCOUNT. NOW DESPITE THE HARD
WORK AND ALL THE OUT REACH
THAT'S ENGAGED IN THAT EFFORT
NEARLY ONE MILLION CALIFORNIANS
STILL REMAIN UNINSURED IT UP OUT
OF THIS ONE MILLION WE BELIEVE
ABOUT NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE ACTUALLY ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
FREE HEALTHCARE. AND SO WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT ADDS A
CHECK BOXING YOUR PERSONAL
INCOME TAX RETURN AND ASK IF YOU
WANT TO. ROUTE THE- SHARE WITH
THE FRANCHISE TAX- THAT CHECK
BOX SO THAT ON THE RETURN A
TAXPAYER CAN INDICATE WHERE THEY
HAVE AN INTEREST IN NO COST OR
LOW COST HEALTH CARE INSURANCE.
AND THEN OF COURSE HAVING
COVERED CALIFORNIA FOLLOW UP
IT'S JUST ANOTHER INVENTIVE
CREATIVE WAY TO TRY TO.
IMPLEMENT COVERED CALIFORNIA THE
MOST EXPENSIVE WAY POSSIBLE LAST
RIVAL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WE
HAVE TO LEADS PER WITNESSES
LISTED. JOSE TORRES CÁC US WHO
IT IS YES. PRESENT YEAH WELCOME
. THANK YOU MY FRIEND COURSE-
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBER JOSE TOWARDS ON BEHALF OF
HEALTH ACTS CALIFORNIA THE STATE
WIDE HEALTH CARE CONSUMER
ADVOCACY COALITION AND A CO
SPONSOR AND SUPPORT OF SB NINE
SIX SEVEN. S. CENTER HERTZBERG
MENTIONED THIS BILL WOULD CREATE
A CHECK BOX ON STATE INCOME TAX
RETURN FORMS THAT WOULD ALLOW
PEOPLE TO MARK IF THEY ARE
INTERESTED IN RECEIVING MORE
INFORMATION ABOUT LOW COST OR NO
COST HEALTH CARE COVERAGE. SO
HAVING HEALTH CARE COVERAGE
IMPROVES HEALTH OUTCOMES AND
CALIFORNIA HAS DONE GREAT WORK
IN LEADING THE WAY IN REDUCING
THE UNINSURED RATE IN THE STATE
AS CENTER MENTIONED- THIS WOULD
BENEFIT THOSE WHO ARE UNINSURED
AND PROVIDE THEM WITH
INFORMATION ABOUT THE VARIOUS
HEALTH CARE COVERAGE OPTIONS
THAT MAY BE AVAILABLE AVALABLE
TO THEM. AND SB NINE SIX SEVEN
WOULD ALSO CONNECT PEOPLE WHO
MAY BE ON AND UNDER INSURED AND
SIMPLY NOT KNOW WHAT OTHER
OPTIONS EXIST AND ARE AVAILABLE
FOR THEM OUT THERE. COVER
CALIFORNIA AS MENTIONED ARE YOU
DOES GREAT WORK IN THEIR OUR
REACH AND THIS IS A NEW AVENUE.
FOR THEM TO REACH OUT TO HEALTH
CARE CONSUMERS. AND WE HOPE-
COMMITTEE CAN SUPPORT THIS BILL
WITH AN AYE VOTE. I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. WE'RE GONNA MOVE ON TO
DOCTOR JEAN MAHU IS FROM THE
AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION OF
SAN DIEGO. AND- HE'S ON THE LINE
. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE. MY
NAME IS DR JEAN MA AND I'M A
MEMBER OF THE AMERICAN HEART
ASSOCIATION SAN DIEGO DIVISION
BOARD OF DIRECTORS HAVE BEEN
EMERGING POSITION NOW FOR TWENTY
SIX YEARS AND SEEING FIRSTHAND
THE IMPORTANCE OF ACCESS TO
HEALTH CARE HOUSE ON INDIVIDUALS
AND THEIR FAMILIES SUCH AS
IMPROVED HEALTH OUTCOMES.
CREATED HERE IN STATE COLLEGE
PREVENTION MEASURES IN LONGER
TERM SURVIVAL RATES FROM CHRONIC
DISEASES SUCH AS CARDIOVASCULAR
DISEASE ONE IN THREE AMERICAN
ADULTS SUFFER FROM CHRONIC HEART
DISEASE AND STROKE. WE KNOW THAT
THOSE WHO ARE UNDERINSURED WHO
DO NOT HAVE ACCESS TO HEALTH
INSURANCE OF HIGH MORTALITY RATE
AND POOR BLOOD PRESSURE AND
GLUCOSE CONTROL THAN THEIR
INSURED COUNTERPARTS AND IS
OFTEN MORE PREVALENT IN
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. ON MY LAST
SHIFT I CURED FOR DONALD WHO NOT
DELAYED TAKING CARE FOR HIS LEFT
ARM AND LEFT LEG WEAKNESS.
BECAUSE OF A CONCERN OVER THE
FINANCIAL IMPLICATIONS OF A LACK
OF HEALTHCARE COVERAGE. BUT ALSO
UNFORTUNATELY NEVER OBTAIN BLOOD
PRESSURE MEDICATIONS. FOR WHAT
WAS OTHERWISE A FULLY
PREVENTABLE CAUSE OF HIS STROKE.
SB NINE SIXTY SEVEN OF THE
COMMONSENSE MEASURE THAT BUILD
ON EXISTING OUTREACH EFFORTS. TO
THOSE WHO MAY BE UNINSURED OR
UNDERINSURED AND INFORMS THEM.
OF LOWER NO COST HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE OPPORTUNITIES. ACCESS
TO HEALTH CARE COVERAGE IS
ESSENTIAL TO IMPROVING HEALTH
EQUITY. ANALYST REST EXISTING
HEALTH AND SOCIO ECONOMIC
DISPARITIES THAT OUR STATE FACES
TODAY. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY AND-
DR VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. IS
THERE ANYONE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. SEEING NONE
IT WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE MISTER
MODERATOR IF YOU COULD PROMPT
AND SEE IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT. YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR
SB NINETY SIX SEVEN THE SOUTH
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT
THIS TIME WHEN FELL BY ZERO. AND
WILL THE LINE AB THREE GIRL.
MADAM CHAIR THE ARMSTRONG ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVE ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I AM
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD
ANYBODY ELSE- PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR
SB NINE SIXTY SEVEN AND TWENTY
EIGHT EUROPEN. HELLO JONATHAN
GOES THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER CALLING IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. NINE SIX SEVEN THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THANK YOU. NEXT PLEASE
ENTER NOBODY ELSE QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME VERY GOOD WE DO NOT
HAVE ANY LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES WITNESSES IDENTIFIED
SO MANY SEE IF THERE'S ANYONE IN
ROOM TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. THING NINE WILL MOVE
ON TO THE TELECONFERENCE LINE IF
YOU COULD PROMPT MISTER
MODERATOR IT ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU
ARE NOT PLEASE SB NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO. NOBODY'S
QUEUING UP THIS TAX VERY GOOD
WILL BRING THE MATTER BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE- THERE ARE NO
QUESTIONS SO SENATOR HERTZBERG
AYE I WILL MOVE YOUR BILL AND-
ASK IF YOU IF YOU COULD PLEASE.
THEY'RE ALL. MOTION IS TO PASS
BUT FIRST BE REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
SENATORS CAMBIADO HI CABALLERO
HI NIELSEN. DORADO HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HI WIENER. TWO ZERO
TWO TWO ZERO WE WILL PUT THAT IN
ARBIL ON CALL AND- MOVE ON TO
SENATOR STERN WHO IS HERE.
SENATOR STERN YOU ARE HERE ON SB
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX WELCOME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR-
AND MEMBERS- YOUR WHERE WE'RE
FACING MAJOR HOUSING CRISIS THIS
BILL. TRIES TO PUT ANOTHER TOOL
ON THE TABLE THAT- OUR LATE
COLLEAGUE WHO LEFT THE
LEGISLATURE BUT IS. STILL HERE-
SENATOR HILL IN SPIRIT- TO TRY
TO MAKE SURE THAT WHEN WE'RE
BUILDING AFFORDABLE HOUSING
ESPECIALLY THE KIND THAT DOESN'T
COST THE STATE ANYTHING THAT
NONPROFITS ARE DEVELOPING FOR
OUR LOWEST INCOME RESIDENTS-
THAT WE- TAKE FULL ADVANTAGE OF
THESE ACTIVITIES AND THAT WE'RE
WE'RE LOOKING FOR- FOR THOSE
KINDS OF EXTREMELY LOW INCOME
HOW HOUSEHOLDS. WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S ONLY TWENTY FOUR FOUR
DOUBLE HOMES IN THE ENTIRE STATE
AVAILABLE FOR EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME CALIFORNIANS AND WE NEED
TO DO BETTER ABOUT THAT UNDER
CURRENT LAW NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS
WHO USE PUBLIC FUNDS TO DEVELOP
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. ARE AWARDED
A 100% TAX EXEMPTION ON THEIR
PROPERTY TAXES PROVIDED THE 90%
OF THE RESIDENTS ARE LOW INCOME.
AND THIS IS BEEN AN EFFECTIVE
INCENTIVE HOWEVER THE PROGRAM IS
CAPPED RIGHT NOW IS TWENTY
MILLION DOLLAR TOTAL VALUATION
SO IN THEORY YOU COULD BE
BUILDING LARGER OR MORE
AFFORDABLE UNITS- BUT RIGHT NOW
THAT CAP HAS BEEN A LIMIT WE
RECOGNIZE THE GOVERNOR'S. VETO
MESSAGE ON A ON A TWENTY
NINETEEN BILL- THAT I REFERENCE
FROM SENATOR HILL WE WANT TO
WORK THROUGH THOSE ISSUES GOING
FOURTEEN FROM A POLICY
PERSPECTIVE WE JUST APPRECIATE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS I'M THEIR
DILIGENCE ON THIS ISSUE AND
WE'RE TRYING TO LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD ESSENTIALLY.
TREATING NONPROFIT DEVELOPERS
THAT ONLY USE PRIVATE FUNDS THE
SAME AS ANY OTHER DEVELOPER THAT
WAS USING PUBLIC FUNDS- SO WE
WANT TO HAVE THOSE INCENTIVES IN
PLACE WHEN IT- GO BEYOND- THE
CURRENT MAXIMUM OF TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS- AND WE THINK
THIS BILL TAKES A MEANINGFUL
STEP FORWARD. AND WITH THAT I
WANTED TO INTRODUCE MY- ARC
EARLY TESTIMONY HERE- FROM
DANIEL WILSON WHO WORKS WITH
UNITE HERE LOCAL ELEVEN- WHICH
REPRESENTS MANY FRONTLINE
WORKERS WE'RE IMPACTED BY.
HOUSING AFFORDABILITY AS WELL AS
REMOTE. VERY GOOD WILL. WE WILL-
READ MORE NEWS HERE IN- IN
PERSON SO WHEN WE START WITH
RAND MARTIN. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS RANDY MARTIN
ON BEHALF OF THE AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION I'M VERY QUICKLY
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU ALL HEARD
THIS ISSUE BEFORE- HF ACTUALLY
HAS A VERY LARGE HOUSING
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM THEY
CURRENTLY OFFER ABOUT THIRTEEN
HUNDRED UNITS TO VERY LOW AND
EXTREMELY LOW INCOME PEOPLE IN
THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES. THEY'VE
DEVELOPED OVER THE LAST FOUR
YEARS AND THEY HAVE DONE THIS
ALL WITH PRIVATE FINANCING AS
THE CENTER HAS INDICATED THERE
IS A DIFFERENCE IS HOW THEY'RE
TREATED RELATIVE TO THIS
PROPERTY TAX EXEMPTION THEN
THOSE NONPROFITS THAT DEVELOP
HOUSING WITH PUBLIC FUNDS THAT
ARE OFFERED THROUGH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT. WE SIMPLY
WANT TO BE ABLE TO LEVEL THE
PLAYING FIELD SO THAT WE GET THE
SAME INCENTIVE ON THAT THOSE
DEVELOPERS GET ON THAT MONEY
GOES BACK INTO THE OPERATIONS OF
THE PROGRAM OF THE OF THE
HOUSING IT ALSO GOES IN TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE RENT IS KEPT- AS
LOW AS POSSIBLE. RIGHT NOW WE'RE
CHARGING ABOUT FOUR TO SIX
HUNDRED DOLLARS A MONTH FOR HOLE
IN THOSE PROPERTIES WHICH IF YOU
KNOW L. A.'S RENTAL MARKET IS
REALLY REALLY LOW- SO WE HOPE
YOU'LL SUPPORT THIS BILL.
FORWARD THANK YOU VERY GOOD
THANK YOU SO MUCH- IT WILL MOVE
ON TO DANIELLE WILSON WHO'S ON
THE PHONE. SHE'S FROM UNITE HERE
LOCAL ELEVEN. WELCOME GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MY NAME'S
DANIEL WILSON AND I'M SPEAKING
ON BEHALF OF THE NIGHT FOR LOCAL
ELEVEN REPRESENTING THIRTY
THOUSAND HOTEL. FOODSERVICE IN
STADIUM WORKERS IN LOS ANGELES
AND ORANGE COUNTY. ANY OF THE
PANDEMIC NEARLY ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS LOST THEIR JOB. OUR
MEMBERS ARE SOME OF THE LOWEST
PAID WORKERS AND SERVICE
INDUSTRY. THE ONLY REASON THAT
WE WERE ABLE TO AVOID WIFE HAD
LOTS OF HOUSING IS THE EXTENDED
UNEMPLOYMENT FICTION MORATORIUM
AND REGULAR. HOWEVER AS FOR
INDUSTRY RECOVERS AND JOBS ARE
COMING BACK RIGHT HIKES ARE
MAKING OUR MEMBERS LIFE
DIFFICULT AS EVER. MR AND CELERY
HEARABLE PRE I MAKE TIME FOR
WORKING PEOPLE WHETHER WE CAN
ARE EATEN UP BY HOUSING COSTS
ALTERNATELY PUSH THEM AND THEIR
FAMILIES OUT OF THE
NEIGHBORHOOD. THAT THEIR LABOR
HAS HELPED TO MAKE THE PROPER. I
CAN THINK OF ONE MEMBER WHO I
KNOW THE WORK THAT I ONLY ASK
THAT JUST MOVED TO CALIFORNIA
FEET BECAUSE THAT IS THE ONLY
PLACE YOU CAN AFFORD TO BUY A
HOME. THE OVERWHELMING TREND
AMONG THE WORKING POOR IN LOS
ANGELES THIS MAKES IT ALL THE
MORE IMPORTANT TO DO WITH THIS
BILL SEEKS TO ACCOMPLISH THAT IS
TO ALLOW THE COMMUNITY TO HELP
pHOUSING. THE BILL INSURANCE
NONPROFIT INCLUDING RELIGIOUS
INSTITUTIONS AND HALF PARTLY
HOUSING TRUST THANK YOU NOT YOU
FIND. OUT THAT THEY CAN QUALIFY
FOR THE SAME PROPERTY TAX
EXEMPTION AT THE STATE FUNDED
PROJECT. IT WILL MEAN AFFORDABLE
HOUSING AT LOWER COST TO THE
STATE NEEDS TO BE ACTIVELY.
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
TEST. TODAY REMOVED TO UP.
INSTEAD HERE IN TWENTY HUNDRED
THERE ANYWAY WOULD WOULD LIKE TO
SEE A TO FINANCED. SINGMAN WILL
MOVE ON TO- TESTIMONY ON THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE. YOU COULD
MISTER MODERATOR IF YOU COULD
PLEASE PROMPT- ANYONE WHO WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY. THANK YOU IF
YOU WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO IN
SUPPORT ONE FILED BY ZERO. AND
WE WILL GO ONLINE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR BROOK ARMOR WITH THE
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS ROUNDTABLE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. IF YOU
WILL THE LINE FIFTY NINE YOUR
OFFICE. AFTERNOON I'M SURE
MEMBERS REX W. HI MY BEHALF
CALIFORNIA BUSINESS PROPERTIES
LOCATION IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. AND IF
THERE ARE ANY ADDITIONAL
PARTICIPANTS WILL IT- WANTING TO
PRESS FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. SHARE THIS I THINK YOU DOING
UP. I NEED YOU TO YOUR OFFICE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AFTER
MALCOLM FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEMOCRATIC RENTERS COUNCIL AS
WELL AS FROM MONTEREY COUNTY
RIGHT TO UNITE IS STRONGLY
SUPPORTING THIS VERY IMPORTANT
AND THAT IS THAT WE NEED TO
CREATE THEM A 100% AFFORDABLE
HOUSING UNITS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. FINE WE SHOULD BE
WITH US ONE SECOND PLEASE.
THEY'RE STILL WITH THE OPERATOR
THEY MIGHT HAVE A QUESTION-
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MOVE ON. SURE
WE CAN COME BACK TO THEM IF THEY
STAY ON THE LINE. ARE THEY JUST
THEY JUST GOT IN THE QUEUE MY
THIRTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. CNN
HOUSING IS A HUMAN RIGHT IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THERE ARE NO
OTHER PARTICIPANTS QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME I DON'T CARE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH- WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
ON TO THE OPPOSITION THERE ARE
NO LEAD OPPOSITION WITNESSES
IDENTIFIED SO LET ME CHECK AND
SEE IF THERE'S ANYBODY IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION.
SINGMAN WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE SEE IF
THERE'S ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE
TO TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION ON THE
LINE. IF YOU ARE IN OPPOSITION
TO OUR SB FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX.
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO ONE FIVE EIGHT ZERO. AND
LOCAL LINE THIRTY SIX ANYBODY
ELSE PLEASE GOT IT ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME TO PUT YOURSELF IN Q.
THIRTY SIX YOU ARE OPEN. THIRTY
SIX DID YOU NEED TO TAKE
YOURSELF OUT THE LATE ONE ZERO
AGAIN. IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY LINE THIRTY SIX. THERE
WILL REOPEN YOUR LINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THIRTY SIX ONE ZERO EACH
TIME AND IT'S PUTTING YOU IN AND
OUT. HIT IT ONCE AND ALL YOUR
LIFE. ONE MORE TRY ONE THIRTY
SIX WOULD YOU LIKE TO TESTIFY.
YOU'RE NOT DOING THAT NOW.
TECHNOLOGY IS BEAUTIFUL WHEN IT
WORKS. ALL RIGHT WELL WE'LL
BRING THE- THE BILL SB FOURTEEN
FIFTY SIX BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
ARE THERE ANY QUESTIONS. CENTER
YOU JUST FOR THE RECORD FROM THE
PERSON FROM LOCAL LEVEL THE
ADVOCATE WHO TESTIFIED CAN YOU
JUST EXPLAIN TO THOSE PEOPLE WHO
ARE NOT FROM THE CITY OF LOS I
MEAN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES WAS
THE DISTANCE BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
CITY. AND L. A. X. I KNOW IT IS
BUT YOU CAN JUST WHAT DO YOU
THINK THAT DISTANCES BECAUSE
YOU'RE MAKING THE POINT OF IT
HARD SOMEONE HAD A FARTHER TO
TRAVEL. IF YOU'RE STILL THERE.
DANIELLE WILSON IF YOU'RE STILL
THERE SIXTY MILES WHICH CITY I
DON'T KNOW. PRETTY FAR. OR
SOMEONE OKAY NOT ON THE LINE.
FAR ANY RUSH HOUR. RUSSIA AND
THERE'S RUSSIA TODAY IS NOT RUSH
IT'S TRAFFIC OUR- WELL IN ITS
ALI X. WHO WHO RUN IN THE RIGHT
MIND GOES BY ALLIE EXCEPT YOU
DON'T HAVE TO- OKAY SO WITH THAT
EMOTION SEND HERTZBERG. SO MOVED
THERE IS A THERE IS A MOTION AND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS BUT FIRST
BE REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATION CENTER STERN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CONCLUDE APPRECIATE
THE COMMITTEE'S ANALYSIS THE
MOTION- THIS CAP IS IN MY VIEW
OUTLIVED ITS- USEFUL LIFE AND
IT'S TIME TO. USE EVERY TOOL WE
CAN BUILD LOW INCOME HOUSING
FOR. THE MOST NEEDY CALIFORNIANS
I'M IN ANYWAY WE CAN
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL SENATORS CAMBIADO HI
CAMBIADO HI NIELSEN NIELSEN HI
COROZZO. HERTZBERG ALL RIGHT
HERTZBERG AYE WIENER. THREE
ZERO. THREE WELL WHAT WE'LL PUT
IT ON CALL AT THREE VOTE IN
FAVOR WILL PUT ON CALL AND- I DO
WANT TO SAY WE'RE NEARING THE
END OF OUR HEARING- WE HAVE
BILLS ON CALL NEED ALL
THE MEMBERS TO RETURN TO THE
HEARING IMMEDIATELY SO WE CAN
LEFT THE CALLS AND START GETTING
THESE BILLS OUT WE DO HAVE ONE
MORE BELT IT SENATOR WIENER'S
BILL ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN SB
ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX AND HE IS
EXPECTED. BACK HERE- PRESENTLY
BUT WHAT I'D LIKE TO DO IS TO-
CALL BACK THAT- WE HAVE NOT
TAKEN UP THE CONSENT IS THAT
CORRECT. SO I NEED A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT ITEMS. VERY GOOD
SENATORS EIGHTY FIVE POINT.
EIGHTY FIVE POINT TWO NINE MILES
MALICK'S CALIFORNIA LIFE FOR IT
ISN'T HEALTHY HOW MANY HOURS
THAT IS A TRAFFIC BUT THESE
THAT'S- REFER CATION FOR THAT IS
TRUE. THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT-
THAT CONTENT CALENDAR IS S. B.
FOURTEEN EIGHTY NINE. SB
FOURTEEN NINETY FOUR SB FOURTEEN
NINETY SIX AND CENTER HERTZBERG
HAS MOVED THE CONSENT CALENDAR
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL SENATORS
CAPITO HI CABALLERO HI NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HI DURAZO COROZZO HI
HERTZBERG RIGHT HERTZBERG AYE
WIENER. BORDER. ZERO WE'LL PUT
THAT ON CALL AS WELL THE ARRIVAL
OF SENATOR WIENER. SO LET'S SEE
HOW FAR OUT HE WITH HIS HE WAS
EXPECTED BACK AT. SIX NINETY
NINE WHICH IS JUST LIKE RIGHT
HERE. I'D LIKE TO LIFT THE CALL
ONCE AND- AND TAKE IS IF WE CAN
DO THAT. UPPERS IN THIS BILL IF
HE LETS ME. WE COULD HAVE DONE
THAT THROUGH HIM. YEAH JEWISH
CARCHIDI YES.
INSTEAD HE WANTS ME TO PRESENT.
OKAY SO M. C. MAYBE STILL BE.
THE CAUCUS.
I'VE BEEN ADVISED THAT ITEM
NUMBER FIVE WHICH IS SB TEN
FIFTY BY SENATOR DODD HAS AS THE
FIVE VOTES NEEDED SO THAT BILL
IS OUT.
YES THERE IS.
THANK YOU TO EVERYBODY FOR YOUR
PATIENCE. IT'S THE ALMOST THERE
I DON'T KNOW HOW MANY TIMES
PEOPLE HAVE TOLD ME I'M ALMOST
THERE THE BRIDGE TO GETTING IN
THE CAR.
VERY GOOD NETWORK IT WAS THAT
FOR YOU BECAUSE REQUIRES CAUCUS
WORK VIS. VIS THERE ARE
POSSIBLE. WE'RE READY TO AT TAKE
A BAR FINAL BILL WHICH IS ITEM
NUMBER SEVENTEEN ON THE AGENDA
HELLO. SB ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX
CENTER WIENER THE FLOOR'S YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IN CALLING
MY APOLOGIES FOR- OR THE LIKE-
SO- FIRST OF ALL I WANNA THANK.
THE CHAIRMAN THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING PRETTY INTENSIVELY WITH
US ON THIS BILL IN THE LAST. WE
ARE. ACCEPTING NOT THE CASE NOT
THE AMENDMENTS THAT ARE OUTLINED
IN THE ANALYSIS. BUT RATHER-
AMENDMENTS THAT WE WORKED OUT
WITH THE COMMITTEE I THINK
THEY'VE BEEN- DISTRIBUTED ALSO
SORT OF- SUMMARIZE THEM. ONE IS
TO DELAY THE OPERATIVE DATE BY
ONE YEAR OR SO TO GO INTO
EFFECT. JANUARY FIRST FIRST
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR- TO GIVE
THESE- MORE TIME TO. DEVELOP
LOCAL REGULATIONS- TO. THE NEXT
ONE IS TO PROHIBIT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS FROM ADOPTING AN
ORDINANCE ENFORCING ANY
REGULATION. THAT PROHIBITS
RETAIL SELLING MEDICAL CANNABIS
BY DELIVERY OR HAS THE EFFECT OF
PROHIBITING- THAT DELIVERY
WITHIN THEIR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS. THE FOCUS OF THE
BILL BECOMES DELIVERY- THE NEXT
ONE IS THAT TO INDICATE THAT
STATE THE INDICATE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS- MAY IMPOSE ANY
REQUIREMENT INCLUDING BUT NOT
LIMITED TO LICENSING
REQUIREMENTS. IMPOSITION AND
COLLECTION OF TAXES OR SECURITY
IN PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY
REQUIREMENTS AS LONG AS THOSE
REQUIREMENTS DO NOT HAVE THE
EFFECT OF PROHIBITING RETAIL
SALES. A MEDICAL CANNABIS AND
THEN ALSO MAKING SOME CLARIFYING
CHANGES AROUND THE SEQUEL
EXEMPTION I IN THE BILL WE ALSO
WORK WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY- COMMITTEE ON THAT.
REPRESENT US OUR COLLEAGUES ON
SB. ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX- IT- THE
GOAL OF THE BILL IS TO MAKE
SURE- WHAT WAS PROMISED BECAUSE
- WITH PASSAGE OF PROP TWO.
FIFTEEN MORE TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AGO WHICH IS SAFE ACCESS TO
MEDICAL CANNABIS ABOUT PROMISES
REAL. IF IT WASN'T IT WAS TWENTY
SIX YEARS AGO THAT THE VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA LEGALIZED MEDICAL
CANNABIS. UNFORTUNATELY TWENTY
SIX YEARS LATER AND A LARGE
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA 62% OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES. IT IS ILLEGAL
. CATEGORICALLY TO PURCHASE
MEDICAL CANNABIS SO WE LEGALIZE
MEDICAL CANNABIS. BUT THEN
ALLOWED MASSIVE. LEGAL
CRIMINALIZATION OF ACTUALLY
BUYING OR SELLING MEDICAL
CANNABIS I SAW THE EMPTY PROMISE
TO SAY YOU ARE ALLOWED TO
POSSESS AND USE MEDICAL CANNABIS
BUT WE'RE GOING TO FORCE YOU TO
BUY IT ON THE ILLEGAL MARKET
WHICH IS WHAT HAS HAPPENED 62%
OF CALIFORNIA CITIES A
CATEGORICALLY BANNED THE SALE OF
ANY CANNABIS WHETHER ADULT USE
OR MEDICAL AND ALL THAT DOES IS
FORCE PEOPLE ONTO THE ILLICIT
MARKET SO IF AN ELDERLY WOMAN
WHO HAS ARTHRITIS AND NEEDS
CANNABIS FOR HER TREATMENT.
SHE'S NOW GOING TO HAVE TO GO ON
THE ILLICIT MARKET THE PURCHASER
CANNABIS WITH ALL THE SAFETY
ISSUES THAT THAT RAISES- AND YOU
KNOW EVERYTHING ELSE THE CONS
FROM THE ILLICIT MARKET SO WHAT
THIS BILL DOES IS IT BETTER THIS
BILL ONLY APPLIES TO MEDICAL
CANNABIS DOES NOT APPLY TO ADULT
USE THAT HAVE NOTHING TO DO WITH
PROP SIXTY FOUR. PROP SIXTY
FOUR- ALLOWED CITIES LOCAL
CONTROL TO DECIDE WHETHER TO
ALLOW ADULT USE PROP SIXTY FOUR
HAD NOTHING TO DO WITH MEDICAL
CANNABIS- AND- WHAT THIS BILL
WILL DO IS TO SAY THAT CITIES-
ARE NOT ALLOWED TO CATEGORICALLY
BANNED. THE SALE OF MEDICAL
CANNABIS. CITIES WILL BE ALLOWED
UNDER ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX TO PUT
READ REGULATIONS PLACE. ABOUT
TIME- AND WHERE YOU CAN- I DO
THINGS FOR EXAMPLE IF YOU WERE
IF YOU I NEED A STORAGE FACILITY
TO DELIVER MEDICAL CANNABIS. I'M
MAKING SURE IT'S NOT MAYBE RIGHT
IN THE MIDDLE OF A RESIDENTIAL
NEIGHBORHOOD CITIES WILL HAVE
FLEXIBILITY- BUT THEY CANNOT GET
ARE EXPLICITLY OR AND OF FACT
PROHIBIT DELETE THE SALE OF
MEDICAL CANNABIS- TO PEOPLE. WHO
NEED A- SO I KNOW THERE'S BEEN
OPPOSITION FROM SOME OF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT GROUPS AND WILL
OF COURSE ALWAYS WORK WITH THEM-
I WILL AY THAT THE OPPOSITION
HAS BEEN DRAMATICALLY.
OVERSTATED AND THERE'S THE
TRYING TO CREATE A PERCEPTION
THAT IT'S EASY TO GET LEGAL
CANNABIS ANYWHERE THAT IS
COMPLETELY FALSE AGAIN 62% OF
CALIFORNIA CITIES CATEGORICALLY
BANNED THE SALE OF CANNABIS-
THIS BILL WILL MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE WHO NEED MEDICAL CANNABIS
WHETHER FOR HIV. OR CANCER BIRTH
RATE S. THEY WILL BE ABLE TO
OBTAIN IT LEGALLY AND SAFELY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK OPERATOR I'D GO
OUT WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY ARE
AMY JENKINS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
CANNABIS INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION-
AND DON DUNCAN FROM AMERICANS
FOR SAFE ACCESS. VERY GOOD
WELCOME. GOOD AFTERNOON
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS DON
DUNCAN ON THE GULF COAST FOUNDER
AND A MEMBER OF THE BOARD OF
DIRECTORS OF AMERICANS FOR SAFE
ACCESS WITH THE NATION'S LEADING
MEDICAL CANNABIS PATIENT
ADVOCACY ORGANIZATION AND A BIG
PART OF OUR MID MISSION IS TO
INSURE THAT WE REMOVE AS MANY
OBSTACLES AS POSSIBLE FOR
CANNABIS FOR THERAPEUTIC USE AND
FOR RESEARCH AND THIS BILL TAKES
US CLOSER TO THAT GOAL A LOT OF
PEOPLE ASK ME IF THAT GOAL STILL
MATTERS IN THE ERA OF
LEGALIZATION AND THE ANSWER IS
YES- THAT WE STILL HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO TO MAKE SURE THAT
PEOPLE HAVE THE SAME ACCESS TO
THIS MEDICINE. AS THEY HAVE TO
OTHER MEDICINES FOR INSTANCE WE
DON'T- TELL A DIABETIC TO GO TO
THE NEXT CITY OVER TO GET THEIR
INSULIN AND WE DON'T TELL
PATIENTS THAT ARE CITY DOESN'T
PERMIT CHEMOTHERAPY. AND SO I
WELL I DON'T HAVE A MISSION IF
YOU WILL TO SEE TO IT THAT
CANNABIS IS TREATED LIKE OTHER
MEDICINES IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA- THE VOTERS APPROVED
PROPOSITION TWO FIFTEEN- THEY
HAVE CONSISTENTLY SUPPORTED IT
AND IT'S VERY IMPORTANT THAT WE
DON'T FORGET IN THE AGE OF
LEGALIZATION THAT WE STILL HAVE
WORK TO DO TO FULFILL THAT
PROMISE AND TO MAKE SURE THAT-
THERE'S SAFE LEGAL AND- LOCAL
ACCESS TO CANNABIS FOR MEDICAL
PATIENTS IN CALIFORNIA BECAUSE
EVEN IN THE AGE OF LEGALIZATION
THEY STILL HAVE AIDS AND CANCER
AND CHRONIC PAIN AND OTHER
SERIOUS CONDITIONS. AND WE STILL
HAVE AN OBLIGATION AND AN
IMPORTANT ROLE TO PLAY IN
ENSURING THAT- THAT ACCESS AND
IT DOES BEAR IN MIND THAT THERE
ARE STILL MAJORITY OF
JURISDICTIONS AND THE STATE
ASSEMBLY HAVE NO CANNABIS ACCESS
AT ALL SO IF YOU'RE BEDRIDDEN OR
YOU DO NOT HAVE A VEHICLE YOU
MAY BE IN A VERY DIFFICULT
POSITION WHEN IT COMES TO
ACCESSING LEGAL CANNABIS AND
YOUR HOMETOWN SO- AMERICANS FOR
SAFE ACCESS SUPPORTS AT ELEVEN
SIX WE WANT TO CONTINUE THAT
WORK OF IMPLEMENTING PROPOSITION
AT TEN AND SO I HOPE THAT YOU
WILL SUPPORT THIS BILL. TO HELP
US DOWN THAT PATH THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AMY JENKINS ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA. CANNABIS
INDUSTRY. ASSOCIATION WE'RE VERY
PROUD SPONSOR OF THE SPELL AND I
DO WANT TO ECHO THE SENTIMENTS
EXPRESSED BY. A SENATOR WIENER
WE WORKED VERY HARD WITH
COMMITTEE STAFF TO YOU. I TRY TO
GET TO SOME AMENDMENTS THAT
WOULD PROVIDE SOME COMFORT- IN
TERMS OF WHAT IS PERMISSIBLE AND
WHAT IS NOT. TO WHAT THE
SENATORS POINTS- THIS IS ABOUT
MEDICINAL CANNABIS THIS IS NOT
ABOUT ADULT USE- WE HAVE THE
LOWEST. RATE IN THE NATION AMONG
STATES SUPPORTING ILLEGAL
CANNABIS AT PER CAPITA- AGAIN
THIS IS THIS IS LIMITED TO
MEDICAL BUT I THINK IT JUST
SPEAKS TO THE CHALLENGES
ASSOCIATED WITH TRYING TO-
OBTAIN. LEGAL SAFE TESTED
QUALITY PRODUCTS. SO FOR THESE
REASONS WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL AND WE WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FOR HIS ON GOING EFFORTS
TO EXPAND ACCESS TO MEDICINAL
PATIENTS. AND WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. IS THERE ANYONE
ELSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT. MANAGER MEMBERS
RANDY MARTIN ON BEHALF OF THE
PARENT COMPANY BETTER KNOWN
AROUND THE CAPITOL AS KHALIFA IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS SAID BREAK LET THEY'LL
DO WITH APEX GROUP ON BEHALF OF.
PURELY FROM PERFECT UNION TO
VERTICALLY INTEGRATED CANNABIS
COMPANIES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
IS THERE ANYONE ELSE IN ROOM
TWENTY TWO HUNDRED THAT WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT.
SEAMAN WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE IS OR
ANYBODY ON THE TELECONFERENCING
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR
YOU. THANKS PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME ONE EIGHT ZERO
YOUR SUPPORT TO US SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY SIX- LINE NINETY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU YOUR
OPEN. I REMEMBER AS ANY FRANCO-
WITH THAT BEING A COMPLIANCE
MANAGER WITH MABBITT IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU. MY NINETY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. I NINETY FIVE. I
NINETY FIVE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PLAY. IT WAS WILL GO MY HUNDRED
BY ONE HUNDRED. ONLY CREATE YA
ABOUT THAT FOR. THANK AS FINAL
REMINDER PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT FOR- SB
ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX. AND WE WILL
GO TO LINE NINETY SEVEN.
AFTERNOON AN APPEARANCE MATTERS
JASON BRYANT ON BEHALF OF THE
CANNABIS DISTRIBUTION
ASSOCIATION WE ARE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I NINETY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
LEARNED BOPHA DOCTOR BRAINERD
GROWTH RATE IN FRONT OF ELEVEN
EIGHTY SIX PATIENTS WILL HELP.
THANK YOU THAT MADAM CHAIR NO
ELSE CUED UP THIS TIME. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU VERY MUCH NOW
GOING TO HONOR. TO LEAD WITH IN
ENOUGH. MISTER MODERATOR RAIN
HAVE TO ASK THAT BE CLOSE. VERY
GOOD I WE HAVE TO LEAVE
OPPOSITION WITNESSES CERA
DOCKETS THE- COUNTY READ OF.
ANALYSTS- I SAID THE END NO FROM
THE LEAGUE'S CAL CITIES. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIRTY CAD ON BEHALF OF
THE RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES
OF CALIFORNIA AND THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
LOCAL CONTROL CENTRAL TO THE
PASSAGE OF BOTH THE ORIGINAL
MEDICAL CANNABIS REGULATION AND
SAFETY ACT IN PROPOSITION SIXTY
FOUR. AND CONTINUED AND
CONTINUED ANDCOMBINED AND
MARKERS THAT CALIFORNIA'S
CANNABIS REGULATION WAS NEVER
INTENDED TO COMPEL THE SIDING OF
CANNABIS BUSINESSES WERE LOCAL
CONDITIONS MADE THEM A POOR FIT.
RATHER LOCAL JURISDICTIONS WERE
AND REMAIN A CRITICAL PARTNER IN
CANNABIS REGULATION ABOUT WHO'S
WILLING PARTICIPATION THIS
PROGRAM CANNOT SUCCEED SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY SIX WOULD DISREGARD THIS
INTENT AND RUNS CONTRARY TO THE
SPIRIT OF PROPOSITION SIXTY FOUR
IS COMMITMENT TO LOCAL CONTROL.
SB ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX PROCEEDS
ENTIRELY FROM THE PREMISE THAT
THERE ARE SERIOUS FEARS TO
MEDICAL CANNABIS IN CALIFORNIA
THE BILL HAS NOT PROVIDED A
DEMONSTRATE MEDICAL ACCESS
BARRIERS ANALYSIS LOOKING AT
TRANSITTIMES WE DEFY IF AND
WHERE ACCESS IS AN ISSUE NOR
DOES IT DEFINE WHAT ADEQUATE
ACCESS IS. COUNTIES HAVE BEEN A
PARTNER WITH THE STATE AND
IMPLEMENTATION MARKERS THAT
ENSURING CANNABIS ACCESS THIRTY
THREE COUNTIES ALLOW FOR BOTH
MEDICAL AND ADULT USE CANNABIS
RETAIL WHICH ACCOUNTS FOR A
TOTAL POPULATION OF TWENTY SIX
MILLION OR SIXTY SEVEN POINT 4%
COUNT. TWENTY COUNTIES YOU
AUTHORIZE CANNABIS RETAIL BUT
HAVE LEAST ONE INCORPORATED CITY
THAT DOES AND IN MANY CASES
MULTIPLE CITIES IN ADDITION A
NUMBER OF CITIES AND COUNTIES
ARE CURRENTLY BRINGING ON BOARD
REGULATIONS TO PERMIT CANNABIS
RETAIL. THAT'S FIFTY THREE FIFTY
THREE COUNTIES COVERING THE VAST
MAJORITY OF CALIFORNIA FURTHER
THE BILL APPEARS LOCAL CONTROL
IN JURISDICTIONS THAT PERMIT
CANNABIS MEDICAL RETAIL NOW AND
INTO THE FUTURE BY SEVERELY
LIMITING THEIR ABILITY TO
REGULATE CANNABIS BUSINESSES.
THE BILL WOULD PROHIBIT COUNTIES
AND CITIES FROM ADOPTING
REGULATIONS BEING TO. TO I
RECENTLY RESTRICT ACCESS TO
BROADEN AND HIGHLY OPEN AND THE
DEFINITION OF AND REASONABLE IN
THE BILL A LITTLE MORE THAN A
RECIPE FOR ON ANY MEDICATION FOR
MANY YEARS TO COME. FURTHER
AMENDING EXISTING LOCAL CONTROL
LOCAL ORDINANCES THAT WERE THAT
WERE DEVELOPED AND IMPROVED IN A
OPEN PUBLIC PROCESS WILL POSE A
SIGNIFICANT FISCAL IMPACT ON
JURISDICTIONS I CANNOT BE RECOUP
BY FEES. IN ADDITION IT'S LARGER
RESTRICTIONS A SINGLE RETAILER
OR DELIVERY SERVICE WHICH IS
LIKELY THE CAPACITY SMALL.
JURISDICTION CAN MARKET CAN'T
SUPPORT CANNOT RECOVER THREE
WITH COST JUST ONE OR TWO
DELIVERY OPERATION. LASTLY I
LIKE TO THINK THEY CAN FOR THE
THOUGHT. CROSS AMANDA. WE
BELIEVE THAT THIS CRESSMAN OF
ARKANSAS MORE OF A APPRECIATIVE
OF THE AUTHOR ACCEPTING OF THE
MOMENT. THE PREMISE HOWEVER
MOVING LOOK. REMAINS THEREFORE
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOU KNOW
THAT THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR AND
MEMBERS AT LEAST ARE CITY IKANA
WITH THE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA
CITIES AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO SENATE BILL ELEVEN EIGHTY
SIX. WHICH WOULD SEVERELY
UNDERMINE LOCAL DECISION MAKING
UNDER. THE MEDICINAL AND ADULT
USE CANNABIS REGULATION AND
SAFETY ACT OTHERWISE KNOWN AS
NOW CARISSA. IN CONSTRUCTION OF
BOTH THE MEDICINAL AND ADULT USE
FRAMEWORKS THE CRAFTERS
RECOGNIZE THE CRITICAL NEED FOR
LOCAL CONTROL. PRIMARILY AS PART
OF CITIES AND COUNTIES LAND USE
AUTHORITY. BASED ON POPULATION
BY REGION AND WITH THE
STATISTICS ALREADY STATED BY MY
COLLEAGUE. ROUGHLY SIXTY SEVEN
POINT 4% OF THE POPULATION
RESIDES IN CITIES AND COUNTIES.
THAT HAVE ACCESS TO RETAIL.
BASED ON THIS WE HAVE
DEMONSTRATED COMMITMENT TO
STANDING ACCESS WITHOUT
UNDERMINING LOCAL CONTROL
PROMISED TO CITIES AND COUNTIES.
UNDER MARKERS. PLEASE CONTINUE
TO OPT INTO THE REGULATED MARKET
EACH YEAR AND MANY HAVE A
CANNABIS ITEM ON THE BALLOT FOR
THIS ELECTION CYCLE. THIS TAKES
MONTHS OF PLANNING CONSULTING
WITH EXPERTS STAFFING UP
ETCETERA ALL OF WHICH REQUIRES
BOTH UP FRONT AND ONGOING
RESOURCES. THE DECISION MAKING
AND PLANNING PROCESSES ARE
EXTREMELY NUANCED AND A STATE AS
LARGE AS OURS CERTAINLY WE KNOW
THAT ONE SIZE DOES NOT FIT ALL.
PERMITTING ANY NEW INDUSTRY
PARTICULARLY ONE WITH WELL
DOCUMENTED STATE REGULATORY
CHALLENGES IS A COMPLEX MATTER.
CHANGING THE LOCAL AUTHORIZATION
RULES WHILE THE STATE IS STILL
IN THE IMPLEMENTATION PHASE
PHASE OF THE REGULATORY
FRAMEWORK WILL BREAK THE
PARTNERSHIP AND TRUST THAT BUILT
THIS INDUSTRY. LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS WERE AND REMAIN A
CRITICAL PARTNER IN THE CANNABIS
REGULATION AND WITHOUT WHO'S
WILLING PARTNERSHIP THIS PROGRAM
CANNOT SUCCEED. SB ELEVEN EIGHTY
SIX WILL UNDOUBTEDLY INCLUDE THE
GRADUAL BUT CONSISTENT PROGRESS
THAT LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE
MADE TOWARD EXPANDING CANNABIS
RETAIL ACCESS THROUGH PERMITTING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. FOR THESE
REASONS WE OPPOSE SB ELEVEN
EIGHTY SIX AND RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR NUMBER. VERY GOOD
THANK YOU VERY MUCH- IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE IN ROOM TWENTY TWO
HUNDRED THAT WOULD LIKE TO
TESTIFY IN OPPOSITION. SEEING NO
ONE WILL MOVE ON TO THE
TELECONFERENCE LINE IS OR
ANYBODY ON THE PHONE LINE THAT
WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
OPPOSITION. YOU MEDICARE TEST
PLAN OPPOSITION TO S. B. ELEVEN
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO AT THIS TIME
ONE EIGHT ZERO YOU ARE NOT THEY
SHOULD DO SB. ELEVEN EIGHTY SIX.
I DON'T CARE NOBODY IS COMING UP
THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WILL BRING THE BILL BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
CONCERNS CENTER HERTZBERG. JANA
RECONCILE THE POINT MADE BY THE
AUTHOR AND THE POINT MADE BY THE
CITIES AND THE COUNTIES NUMBERS
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIANS FOR AN EIGHTY TWO
CITIES. AUTHOR THAT INDICATES
WITH 62% WAS A PERCENT SIR THE-
62% YEAH- ALSO IT'S ALL A. K.
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR
CITIES THREE HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR
CITIES OKAY. SO WHEN YOU PRESENT
IN TERMS OF YOUR COUNTIES WHICH
COUNTIES ARE. ARE ARE YOU HAVE
L. A. COUNTY FOR EXAMPLE THAT
SAYS YES BUT EIGHTY SEVEN OF THE
CITY SAY NOW THIS EIGHTY EIGHT
CITIES IN ACCOUNTING. SO M
QUESTION IS IN TERMS OF THE
POINT MADE IN THIS ONLY RELATES
TO THE MEDICAL SIDE NOT TO ADULT
USE IF YOU COULD. FURTHER ANSWER
THAT QUESTION BECAUSE I THINK
THE POINTS THE FACT THAT THE
VOTERS OF CALIFORNIA PASSED THIS
CERTAINLY THE ISSUE OF THIS
COMMITTEE. HAS BEEN SINCE I
CHAIRED IT AT SOME TIME AGO IS
ALWAYS BEEN LOCAL CONTROL
CONTROL BUT THIS SEEMS TO ME TO
BE- A LITTLE OVER THE TOP IF YOU
CAN HELP ADDRESS THAT AT LEAST
ON THE CITY SIDE OF THINGS THAT
APPRECIATE THAT BECAUSE- THE
AUTHOR MAKES A PRETTY
COMPELLING. POINT OF VIEW. ON
THIS. ASSEMBLY PASSED ALONG TIME
AGO THE VOTERS VOTED FOR IT. AND
YOUR ARGUMENTS ABOUT PERCENTAGES
IN COUNTIES CITIES AND I'D LIKE
TO ADDRESS THIS POINT FOR
APPRECIATE THE QUESTION THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CLARIFY WHAT WE
DID IS WE LOOKED AT- STARTED
WITH THE COUNTY TO LOOK AT WHICH
OF THEM- OPTED INTO THE
REGULATED FRAMEWORK. FOR THOSE
THAT DID NOT HAVE ACCESS IN THE
COUNTY UNINCORPORATED AREAS WE
LOOK TO SEE IF THEY HAD CITIES
WITHIN THAT COUNTY. TOPPED ENDED
OPTED INTO THE REGULATED
FRAMEWORK AND BASED ON
POPULATIONS IN THOSE REGIONS WE
FOUND THAT THOSE THAT HAVE OPTED
INTO THE REGULATED FRAMEWORK
ACCOUNT FOR ABOUT 64% OF THE
POPULATION. AGAIN BASED ON. A
SPECIFIC DATA FOR POPULATION BY
REGION WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT B.
B. DATA THAT THE AUTHOR IS USING
TREATS ALL CITIES AND COUNTIES
THIS. LISTS OF POPULATE. FINALLY
IN CITIES THAT HAVE HIGHER
POPULAR. THERE IS IN TAX. BASED
ON THE NUMBER OF. LIVE IN THAT
REGION PARTICULAR MANAGER WITH
FELLOW. BECAUSE YOU KNOW I'VE-
I'VE- KUNIS. CLOSE TEACHER AND
ONE ONE COUNTY. BUT SEES MCGUIRE
. YOU CAN LIKE WHAT FOR HER MY
ON THE- OR SOMETHING. SO YOU
POINT IS THAT- THERE'S AN
ACCOUNT. BUT THE I THIS IS MATT.
THIS IS MEDICINE BASICALLY FOR
FOLKS. YOU SAY WELL BASED UPON
POPULATION IS THAT REALLY AN
HONEST ASSESSMENT OF THE NUMBER
I DON'T KNOW IT JUST. SEEMS TO
ME IT'S KIND OF A-A NOT REALLY
ACCURATE BECAUSE YOU DON'T YOU
MIGHT BE THE COUNTY. YOU MIGHT
ALPINE COUNTY HAS NO CITIES
RIGHT. YOU MIGHT HAVE TO DRIVE
EIGHTY MILES TO GO SOMEPLACE
ELSE DID YOU DO THAT DIAGNOSTIC
IN TERMS OF. PATIENT CONVENIENCE
AND A LIKE A LIKE TO GET SOME
SENSE OF THAT BECAUSE- THE FACT
THAT YOU GOT THROUGH IN THIRTY
CITIES AND- IN. CALIFORNIA DON'T
ALLOW ACCESS TO SOME OF THE
VOTERS PASSED. FOR MEDICINE IS A
PRETTY BIG DEAL THAT HAT'S AN
INTERESTING COMMENT AND ACTUALLY
SPEAKS TO A LARGER ISSUE OF AND
RULE CALIFORNIA WHERE YOU USED
TO DRIVING FOR. ANY SERVICES
WHETHER IT'S TRADITIONAL MEDICAL
SERVICES YOUR GROCERIES YOUR GAS
EXCEPT TRACK. BUT ACTUALLY THAT
A LARGE PROPORTION OF REAL
CITIES OUR WORLD COUNTIES OFTEN.
TO PROVIDING FOR A WHOLE ENTIRE
REGULATORY SCHEME. AND ACTUALLY
IN SOME CASES THEY ALLOW A LOT
OF THINGS LIKE CULTIVATION
MANUFACTURING PROCESSING. BUTTON. RETAILS ARE PART. BECAUSE I'M
NOT. THERE'S A LOT OF TIMES IT
LIMITS. COMMERCIAL LEARN. AND
THEN YOU'LL SEE SEIZE WITHIN
THOSE. PICK UP RETAIL BUT NOT A
- THE COLD. SO I THINK IN TERMS
OF AN OUTSIDE A LOCAL BIT THE-
IN RULE CAN YOU. IN INTO CAN AND
WE HAVE A FEW COUNTIES THAT.
DON'T HAVE ACCESS THAT WOULD
THIS WOULD BE VERY DIFFICULT
LIKE ALPINE WHICH IS THIRTEEN
HUNDRD PEOPLE MOST OF PEOPLE
ARE HEADING TO ELDORADO OR AND
THEN BRING COUNTY TO. GET THEIR
NORMAL SERVICES INCLUDING.
POTENTIALLY THE MEDICAL CANNABIS
WE ALSO HAVE THERE WAS ANOTHER
COUNTY WHICH IS MAROPOST AGAIN
HAS NO CITY- AND SO IT'S IT WILL
BE CHALLENGING FOR THEM. TO HAVE
ESSENTIALLY ORDINANCES FOR.
RETAIL AND FRANKLY THERE WILL BE
NO READ THAT GOES INTO IT
BECAUSE- I MEAN THEY'RE NOT EVEN
GETTING. BASIC SERVICES WITHIN
THEIR COUNTY A LOT OF TIME
SURPRISE HAD ONE MORE QUESTION-
IT DOESN'T LITTLE BIT DIFFERENT
IN THE- MEDICINES WHICH
SHOULDN'T YOU IF YOU GET. IT IS
A THINKING ON THAT. SHOULDN'T
YOU LOOK AT THIS IS TAMMY
PHARMACIES ARE THERE. RIGHT IF
YOU'RE GONNA GO TRAVEL TO A BIG
BOX RETAILER SOMETHING BUT
SHOULD THIS BE IF THIS IS
MEDICINE RIGHT AND THAT'S WHICH
ONLY TALKING ABOUT CORRECT SIR.
SO SHOULDN'T YOU DO LOOK AT
APPLES TO APPLES COMPARISON TO
SAY OKAY. YOU KNOW YOU MIGHT
HAVE TO GO VERY FAR FOR THIS
KIND OF MEDICINE BUT EVERY OTHER
MEDICINE THAT'S REGULATED BY THE
BOARD OF PHARMACY. YOU CAN GO
CLOSER TO THAT SHOULD THAT BE A
BETTER. ANALYSIS IN TERMS OF
LOOKING AT THE IMPACT OF CENTER
WE HAS MADE NO I THINK WE'RE
WILLING TO HAVE THOSE
CONVERSATIONS I THINK PART OF IT
IS THE PROMISE DOESN'T REALLY
HAVE ANYTHING THAT SETS UP. WHAT
IS ADEQUATE ACCESS WHAT WE NEED
TO MOVE FORWARD SO WE'RE WILLING
TO HAVE. THOSE CONVERSATIONS
MOVING FORWARD DEFINITELY AND I
WANT TO SAY THAT IS PART OF THE
REASON THAT WE- FOUGHT SO HARD
ORIGINALLY FOR LOCAL CONTROL WAS
MAKING SURE THAT COMMUNITIES.
HAVE THE ABILITY TO MAKE.
DECISIONS THAT MAKE SENSE FOR
THEM AND WE'RE GOING THAT THE
DIFFERENCE IN REAL SUBURBAN AND
URBAN AND BETWEEN COUNTIES AND
CITIES. BECAUSE THEY ALSO ARE
VERY DIFFERENT. SELL. WITH THAT
AGAIN WE- FOR THE FIRST
CONVERSATIONS. ABOUT HOW WEAK
ALL WORK TOGETHER TO IMPROVE.
GOOD THANK YOU- AND I THAT IS.
THAT THE BOTTOM LINE FOR ME IN
TERMS OF LOOKING AT THIS IS
THAT- AND I'M A BIG ADVOCATE FOR
LOCAL CONTROL NO QUESTION ABOUT
IT BUT- BUT HAVING SAID THAT- I
THINK THAT THERE'S STILL THE
RESISTANCE TO CONSIDER MARIJUANA
- AT A MINIMUM FOR MEDICINAL
PURPOSES. AND TO THE EXTENT THAT
THAT CALIFORNIA LAW CHANGED BUT-
MAYBE THE MINES- ARE HAVING A
HARD TIME WITH IT STILL WE NEED
TO UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE-
THERE ARE MEDICATIONS. THAT ARE
PRESCRIBED BY DOCTORS THAT ARE
MUCH MORE SERIOUSLY HARMFUL TO
INDIVIDUALS- THAT ARE ADDICTIVE
IN A WAY THAT- THAT LEAVES DEATH
THAT THAT ARE. AVAILABLE MUCH
MORE READILY AVAILABLE AND SOME
OF THAT SOME OF OUR COMMUNITIES
AND OTHERS AND SO MANY CASES- I
WILL SUPPORT THE BILL- AND I
HOPE THAT YOU'LL CONTINUE THE
CONVERSATIONS I THINK THE
AMENDMENTS. REALLY- MOVE. NOBODY
LIKES TO HEAR YOU GOT TO DO
SOMETHING BUT IT MOVES IN IN THE
DIRECTION THAT- THAT I THINK
WILL BE BETTER FOR CITIES AND
COUNTIES TO BE ABLE TO- TO SET
THE LIMITS AROUND- AT WHERE
THINGS CAN BE STORED. TO BE USED
FOR DELIVERY- BUT- BUT ALSO
PROVIDES AN OPPORTUNITY FOR
DELIVERY SERVICE IN THE
COMMUNITY BECAUSE THAT'S
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT IF YOUR ILL
AND YOU WERE ABILITY TO IT TOO
TO BE MOBILE IS NOT. NOT THERE
THEN IT'S VERY DIFFICULT- TO BE
ABLE TO GET OUT WHAT IS A ARE A
RELATIVELY- WELL WHICH I THINK
IS A REALLY GOOD MEDICATION FOR
MANY OF THESE VERY SERIOUS
ILLNESSES. BENJAMIN THE BILL.
THERE IS A MOTIONS AND HERTZBERG
YES THIS IS THE- CENTER THE RISE
OF MAY BE OFF THE WALL KIND OF
QUESTION BUT HE IS THERE- A BIG
DIFFERENCE. THE AREA THAT COLD.
ARE THEY THE SAME ONE THE AREAS
THAT DON'T SELL IT IS THERE ANY
KIND OF CONNECTION THERE OR-
ASSISTING YEAH JUST CURIOUS I
DON'T- SO IF YOU LOOK AT LIKE
HUMBOLDT OR MENDOCINO COUNTY
WHICH IS SOME OF THE BIG
CULTIVATORS BAY- I THINK- LESS
OF AN ISSUE- I WILL TELL YOU
THAT- YOU'RE JUST WHAT WITH
RECENT WITH RESPECT TO THE TO
THE OPPOSITION. TO DISABLED 67%
OF CALIFORNIA IS LIVE IN A
JURISDICTION THAT ALLOWS US
WITHOUT A PROBLEM WELL THAT'S OF
COURSE BECAUSE OUR BIG CITIES
OUR BIGGEST CITIES TEND TO ALLOW
THEM LA SAN FRANCISCO YOU KNOW
SAN JOSE SEN SO THAT THAT'S IT
WITHOUT RESPECTFULLY IT'S VERY
MISLEADING WE HAVE WE ACTUALLY
ARE HOPING AT SOME POINT SOON
WE'LL HAVE AN ACCURATE MAP. THAT
SHOWS THE AND I AM WHAT IT MIGHT
TAKE IS THAT IT WAS SO MASSIVE
SWATH OF RED AND LITTLE BUBBLES
WHERE YOU CAN EASILY DATA- BUT
YOU KNOW RIGHT NOW. THERE ARE
TEN. THIS LITERALLY THE COUNTY
AND EVERY CITY AND THAT CAN BE
BANDS THAT THAT'S ALPINA CA
MADERA AMERICA MODOC PLUMAS
SIERRA SUTTER AND TO HIM OUT SO
IF YOU HAVE HIV OR CANCER OR
YOU'RE LIVING IN CHRONIC PAIN
YOU NEED IN ONE OF THOSE
COUNTIES YOU ARE OUT OF LUCK AND
IF YOU'RE NOT MOBILE YOU'RE
REALLY OUT OF LUCK YOU CAN GET
YOUR PRESCRIPTIONS IN THE MAIL.
THEY COME OUT THEY COME OUT
OPIOIDS DO YOU BUT YOU CAN'T GET
HIM MEDICAL CANNABIS DELIVERED
TO YOUR HOME IN ORANGE COUNTY
WITH WITH IT WAS AT TWO POINT
FIVE FIVE BILLION PEOPLE- LIVE
IT TWO POINT FIVE FIVE MILLION
PEOPLE IN ORANGE COUNTY LIVE IN
A JURISDICTION THAT BANS ALL
CANNABIS REPRESENT 80% OF THE
POPULATION ORANGE COUNTY. THIRTY
THIRTY FIRST IN ORANGE COUNTY
CATEGORICALLY BACK THE SALE OF
ANY. INCURRING COUNTY 96% OF
KERN COUNTY RESIDENTS LIVE IN A
JURISDICTION WHERE CANNABIS
SALES ARE PROHIBITED. BUT KERN
COUNTY AND TEN OUT OF ITS TWELVE
CITIES CATEGORICALLY BANNED.
CANNABIS THESE ARE NOT TINY
MICRO COUNTIES WHERE YOU JUST
HAVE TO TRAVEL. FIVE MILES DOWN
THE ROAD THESE ARE BIG COUNTIES
WHERE PEOPLE MIGHT HAVE TO
TRAVEL FIFTY SEVENTY FIVE
HUNDRED MILES. THAT'S
INCONVENIENT FOR ANYONE. AND IF
YOU HAVE TO TRAVEL SEVENTY FIVE
MILES TO GET YOUR MEDICINE YOUR
MEDICAL CANNABIS. YOU'RE
PROBABLY JUST GONNA FIND YOUR
GUY DOWN THE STREET TO COME IN
CELLS YOU ILLEGAL CANNABIS.
WHICH COULD BE LACED WITH
FENTANYL. WHICH COULD BE
UNHEALTHY IN SOME OTHER WAY
WHICH THEY COULD HAVE GOTTEN
FROM AN ILLEGAL GROW AT THAT THE
CHAIRS AND SO FOCUSED ON IT'S
DESTROYING OUR ENVIRONMENT
BECAUSE IT'S NOT REGULATED. SO I
YOU KNOW I OFTEN DO BELIEVE IN
LOCAL CONTROL BUT WE TRUSTED THE
CITIES. AND PROP TWO FIFTEEN
APPROX SIXTY FOUR TOGETHER
RIGHT. AND IT'S TRUST BUT VERIFY
AND NOW WE'RE VERIFYING AND THE
CITY'S OVERWHELMINGLY. HAVE NOT
DONE THE RIGHT THING HERE. AND
FOR WHATEVER POLITICAL REASONS-I'M NOT TRYING TO BE CRITICAL OF
THE CITY THAT JUST HASN'T
HAPPENED. AND SO WE NEED A
LITTLE BIT. OF MODESTY STATE
INTERVENTION. THE STATE FOR
MEDICAL CANNABIS YOU HAVE TO
ALLOW DELIVER YOU HAVE TO ALLOW
PEOPLE TO GET IT AT THEIR HOME-
AND SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
LIVE OAK. THE YOU VERY. S.
WIENER- YOU HAVE A MOTION THE
MOTION. IS. DO PASS AS AMENDED
AND- I PUT MY NOTES OF. THAT I
WAS READYTO MOVE I GOTTA. THE
PASSES AMENDED BUT FIRST AMEND
AND REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS SENATORS CAMBIADO
HI CABALLERO HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN
NO DURAZO DORADO HI HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HI WIENER AYE WIENER I
. FORTY ONE FORTY ONE THAT BILL
IS OUT. ALL RIGHT- NOW WE'RE
READY TO MOVE ON TO- REVIEW ALL
THE BILLS THAT ARE ON CALL BUT
BEFORE WE DO THAT I WANT TO
THANK THE MODERATOR FOR HIS HELP
TODAY APPRECIATE YOU- BEING ON
THE LINE AND MAKING SURE WE GET
OUR WORK DONE- PROVIDING AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO
TESTIFY REMOTELY- WE'RE GOING
TO. MOVE ON TO- FILE ITEM NUMBER
ONE S. B. TWO OH SEVEN BY
SENATOR DOLLY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. HEARD VOTE IS
THREE TWO ZERO SENATOR NIELSEN.
NIELSEN HI SENATOR HERTZBERG.
HERTZBERG HI. FIVE DAYS AT BILLS
OUT FIVE ZERO WE'RE GOING TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWO S. B. EIGHT
FIFTY FOUR BY SENATOR SKINNER.
CURRENT BIRD IS THREE TO ZERO
SENATOR NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI. FORTY
ONE THAT GOES OUT FORTY ONE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER THREE S. B.
EIGHT EIGHT FOUR I SENATOR
MCGUIRE. SEE A CURRENT VOTE IS
TWO TWO ZERO SENATOR CAFIERO HI
ABIERTO HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN NO
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI. FORTY
ONE THAT GOES OUT FORTY ONE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX SB TEN
NINETY NINE BY SENATOR RIGHT
KASKI CURRENT VOTE IS TWO TWO
ZERO SENATORS CAPITO HI
CABALLERO HI HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
HI WIENER. WIENER HI. FIVE ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT FIVE TWO ZERO.
I FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN S. B.
ELEVEN OH FIVE BY SENATOR HUESO
CURRENT VOTE IS TWO TWO ZERO
SENATORS CAPITO HI ABIERTO- I
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG AYE WIENER.
WIENER AYE FIVE TO ZERO THAT
PHYLLIS OUT FIVE ZERO. FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE SB THIRTEEN NINETY
THREE. CURRENT VOTE IS TWO TWO
ZERO SENATORS NIELSEN. FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE S. B. THIRTEEN
NINETY THREE. SENATORS NIELSEN
NIELSEN NO DURAZO DORADO HI
WIENER. WIENER NO. THREE TWO
BEDFELLOWS OUT THREE TWO TWO
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN SB THIRTEEN
AT SEVENTY FOUR SENATOR BYRD OR
JUST CURRENT VOTE IS TWO TWO
ZERO SENATORS CAPITO HI
CABALLERO I DURAZO DRUGS SO HI
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI. AFTER
THAT BILLS OUT FIVE TWO ZERO
FILE ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN S. B.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR NEWMAN CURRENT VOTERS TO
ONE SENATORS CAPITO HI ZERO I
HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI. FORTY
ONE THAT GOES OUT FOR TWO ONE.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TWELVE SB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY TWO BY CENTER IN
DALLAS CURRENT VOTERS THREE TO
ONE SENATOR HERTZBERG HERTZBERG
HI. FORTY ONE THAT BILL IS OUT
FORTY ONE. FILE ITEM NUMBER
THIRTEEN S. B. THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE I SENATOR BATES CURRENT
VOTE IS TWO TWO ZERO SENATORS
CABALLERO HI CABALLERO HI
NIELSEN. NIELSEN AYE HERTZBERG
HERTZBERG HI. THE BILL IS OUT
FIVE ZERO. FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN SB FOURTEEN ELEVEN BY
SENATOR MELINDA. CURRENT VOTE IS
TWO TWO ZERO SENATORS CAPITO HI
CABALLERO HI NIELSEN. NIELSEN
AYE HERTZBERG HERTZBERG HI I
BILL IS OUT FIVE ZERO. FILE ITEM
NUMBER FIFTEEN SB FOURTEEN FIFTY
SIX BY SENATOR STERN CURRENT
VOTE IS THREE TWO ZERO SENATORS
DORADO. DRAWS I WINNER WINNER I
HAD BILLS OUT FIVE ZERO. SENATOR
WIENER'S I THAT. YES THAT EIGHT
THIRTY FOUR. CURRENT VOTE IS
THREE TWO ZERO SENATORS NIELSEN
. HERTZBERG AYE HERTZBERG HI
WHAT IS YOUR- AND BILLS OUT
FORTY ZERO. WE ARE WE DONE- THAT
WE HAVE THE CONSENT. GOT PRO AT
EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN I THOUGHT WE'D
FINISH THAT ONE MY APOLOGIES
FILE ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN SB
NINE SIXTY SEVEN BY CENTER
HERTZBERG CURRENT BIRD IS TWO
ZERO SENATORS NIELSEN. NIELSEN
HI TO ROSEAU ROSEAU HI WIENER
WIENER I. THAT THE BILL IS OUT
FIVE TWO ZERO. AND FINALLY OUR
CONSENT AGENDA ITEMS WHICH ARE
THE LAST THREE ITEMS ON OUR
AGENDA. CURRENT VOTE IS FOUR TWO
ZERO SENATOR WINNER WINNER I.
THOSE BILLS ARE OUT THAT CONSENT
IS OUT FIVE ZERO. VERY GOOD
THAT- THAT CONCLUDES OUR HEARING
ON BILLS TODAY THANK YOU TO ALL
THE INDIVIDUALS WHO PARTICIPATED
IN PUBLIC TESTIMONY IF YOU ARE
NOT ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE
SUBMIT YOUR COMMENTS OR
SUGGESTIONS IN WRITING TO THE
GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE COMMITTEE
OR VISIT OUR WEBSITE YOUR
COMMENTS AND SUGGESTIONS ARE
IMPORTANT TO US. AND WE WANT TO
INCLUDE YOUR TESTIMONY IN THE
FITIAL HEARING RECORDS THANK YOU
AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION THANK YOU TO
EVERYONE FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
COOPERATION WE HAVE CONCLUDED
THE AGENDA THE SENATE COMMITTEE
ON GOVERNANCE AND FINANCE IS
ADJOURNED.